FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD EVENING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NOT A PROBLEM
NOT NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL OF SOME OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
THOSE CENTERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF NOW AND IF YOU HAVE
SUPPORT STAFF YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY THEM AS WELL. I'M HERE
SHE CENTER MORLOCK PRESENT. NO
STAFF THANK YOU NEXT GREEN.
SENATOR MIKE MORRELL HERE NO
STAFF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE BRIAN DOLLY HERE NO STAFF
THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR MELENDEZ
WOULD YOU JUST TURN YOUR VIDEO
ON QUICKLY SO WE CAN JUST SAY
YOU. AND WE'LL MOVE ON. AND
JUST A KNOWLEDGE OF YOUR THERE
WAS NO STAFF. HE JUST SAY YOUR
NAME AND WHAT YOU HAVE STAFF
PRESENT PLEASE. SENATOR
MELENDEZ I DO NOT HAVE STAFF
PRINT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THAT
THAT'S ALL OF OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS CORRECT I THINK IT IS
WE ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE LEDGE ANALYST'SOFFICE AND
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVES WILL
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE THEIR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BERECOGNIZED THE TO USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UN MUTE PLEASE
SELECT ON YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU'RE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- HERE IN THE GALLERY AS
WELL AS- INTO A HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
PARTICIPANT PHONE CALL IN
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT SIX FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES. THE WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
COMMITTEE WEB TO THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID A COLLISION FEEDBACK YOU
MUST BEGIN WITH YOUR DEVICE YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO DISRUPTED MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE SERVICE
OR A HEARING ROOM OR THE-
CHAMBERS. OR HAD THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
JUST INTO THE NEW USE. OF
ONLINE TOOLS OF TECHNOLOGY WE
JUST ASK THAT YOU BE PATIENT.
THIS EVENING'S HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON OUR END OF SESSION
BUDGET PACKAGE. WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WILL HEAR ALL OF THE
BILLS. PRIOR TO RECEIVING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. WHICH WE WILL
TAKE. UP FOR ALL OF THE BILLS
AT ONCE THAT'S THE WAY WE RUN
OUR BUDGET HEARINGS THE LAST
SEVERAL HEARINGS. AFTER PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WE WILL TAKE ACTION.
BEFORE WE BEGIN ON IF MR
STEPPING CHAU WILL PLEASE CALL
ROLE SO THAT MEANS WE MAY
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. THIS IS
SEVEN SHOP REVIEW. FOR THE
SENATORS MITCHELL HERE. NIELSEN.
BEL AIR. CABALLERO DOLLY. HERE
PROBABLY HERE. THE RAZA ROGER
HERE. HERTZBERG. PORTATO HERE
THE TITLE HERE. LEYVA HERE
FAVOR HERE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ PRESIDENT. MELENDEZ
PRESENT. MORNING HERE MONNING
HERE MORLOCK OR LACK. MOORLACH
PRESENT MORE PRESENT. MORRELL
AMARELA HERE IN PRESENT. I
DON'T. AB I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
ON THE SCREEN CENTER LBCC ON
THE SCREEN BRIEFLY SIR THERE WE
GO THANK YOU. COULD YOU SAY
PRESIDENT CLINTON. MORRELL
MORALE. YES MORALE HERE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER. CHANGERS THANK YOU WHAT
AREA HELLO HELLO HELLO HELLO.
PAN HERE. RAFI RAFI RAFI HERE
SKINNER. MY COUNTY HERE MY
CASHIER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE A CONSULTANT NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM BEFORE WE
START WITH THE BILLS I JUST
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE AND THANK SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO HELP US NAVIGATE THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WORK IN
PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THE YEAR. I FULLY ANTICIPATE
AS I KNOCK ON WOOD THAT THIS
WILL BE OUR LAST BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING OF THE DAY OF
THE YEAR AND SO I'D LIKE TO
CERTAINLY THANK VERTICALLY THIS
YEAR AS WE HAVE UTILIZED
TECHNOLOGY. WE WERE THE FIRST
COMMITTEE TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
HEARING THAT UTILIZED REMOTE
PARTICIPATION. AND WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY AND SO I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF THE I. T. AND DESK
PROFESSIONALS WHO HELPED US
NAVIGATE. CERTAINLY THE SENATE
SERGEANTS WHO DO A FINE JOB ALL
THE TIME. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE- PHENOMENAL STAFF OF THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE. AND
THE REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- ALL EVERY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE ON HAS
THE MATERIALS THEY NEED ARE
WELL PREPPED AND PREPARE TO
COME INTO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS- AS WE EMBARK ON THE
JOURNEY OF. NAVIGATING THE
BUDGET FOR THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY OF THE WORLD. BUT ALSO
LIKE TO OF COURSE THINK
FINANCE. AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE LEDGE ANALYSTS I JUST HAVE
TO SAY ALL WITH REGARD TO THE
LEDGE ANALYSTS- NOT ONLY THE
WORK THEY DO- TO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE WITH REGARD TO THE
BUDGET. BUT I HAVE TO TIP MY
HAT IN TERMS OF A VERY
PROGRESSIVE FORWARD THINKING-
ACTION AT THE LEDGE ANALYSTS
TOOK THIS YEAR. BOB AROUND ANTI
BIAS EQUITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
TRAINING WITHIN THEIR OWN
OFFICE THESE ARE IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE
CONSCIOUS OF- BUT PARTICULARLY
NOW THAT YOU HAVE PARTICULAR
SIGNIFICANCE. GIVEN THE RECENT
EVENTS IN OUR HISTORY SO I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE L. A. L. FOR
TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO
ADDRESS THOSE CRITICAL ISSUES.
WITHIN THE RANKS OF THEIR
ORGANIZATION O THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIRTY NIELSEN ANY
REMARKS YOU LIKE TO OFFER SIR.
QUESTION MATTER PRESIDENT
FAMILY OR MADAM CHAIR UP WHEN
WILL BE ACTUALLY VOTING ON THIS
PACKAGE OF BILLS SENSE THIS OF
ALL THE INFORMATION FOR THE
NIGHT WILL BE TOMORROW THE NEXT
DAY OR DO WE KNOW AT THIS
POINT. NO SIR WE OF THE HEARING
THAT ENDED UP NOT HAPPENING I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT DAY OF THE
WEEK THAT WAS WAS THE HEARING
THAT WAS GOING TO BE
INFORMATIONAL TONIGHT SIR WE
WILL BE VOTING- WE ARE GOING TO
VOTE WE ARE WE WILL BE VOTING
SIR. REMOVING NO VOTING YES SIR
WE WILL BE VOTING TONIGHT OKAY
YES WE WILL BE VOTING. I THINK
WE HAD TALKED ABOUT A PREVIOUS
HEARING WE'D CONSIDER TO HAVE
IT TO BE AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING BUT WE CANCEL THAT IF
YOU RECALL AND THEN WE PUT BOTH
AGENDAS. TOGETHER FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ON IT WAS CLEAR THAT WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE ACTION. SO ON
THE IT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING AFTER WE HEAR ALL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AS WE'VE DONE
THE PAST WILL GO DOWN AND CAST
THEIR VOTE. WILL THIS BE JUST
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR OR ALL OF
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILLS AS
WELL. SIR IT IS OUR INTENTION
TO- TAKE VOTES TODAY ON BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR WHICH IS AB EIGHTY
SIX. AND TO TAKE VOTES ON ITEMS
THREE THROUGH TWELVE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY AT ANY OTHER
COMMENT SUSTENANCE NIELSEN.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND LET'S BEGIN WITH OUR
FIRST BILL AB SIX RELATED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON L.
A. L. I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO PRESENT FIRST AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF HEARING FROM OUR
TWENTY GENERAL MR BECERRA- AND
THEN FOLLOWED BY FINANCE IF
THEY HAVE ANY COMMENTS LET'S
GET STARTED WITH THE L. A. O.
ON. AB. SIX MEETING I'M SURE
SENATORS ANNUALLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF THIS BILL THE
BILL HAS FOUR MAJOR PROVISIONS
FIRST- IN ADDITION TO THE
STATE'S UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
PLANS THIS BILL WOULD PERMIT
CIVIL PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS
OF THE STATE'S UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES LAWS TO ALSO BE
DEPOSITED INTO THE PUBLIC
RIGHTS LAW ENFORCEMENT SPECIAL
FUNDS FOR CONSUMER PROTECTION
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES. SECONDS
THE BILL WOULD ALSO PROVIDE DOJ
WITH UP TO SIXTEEN ADDITIONAL
EXEMPT POSITIONS- THE WHICH
WOULD BRING THEIR TOTAL TO
THIRTY THREE. THIRD THE BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE DOJ TO USE ITS
OWN AUTHORITY TO SEEK CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS OF
CERTAIN WATER POLLUTION LAWS
INSTEAD OF ONLY BEING ABLE TO
BRING SUIT UPON COMPLAINT BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. FOURTH AND FINALLY-
STATES ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF SEEKING AROUND TO
TWENTY SIX POINT FOUR BILLION
FROM CERTAIN OPIOID
DISTRIBUTORS AND MANUFACTURERS.
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF THE
OPIOID CRISIS. AND SO THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO HELP FACILITATE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND TURN
INTO A STATEWIDE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS TO
MAXIMIZE CALIFORNIA'S SHARE OF
ANY SETTLEMENT REVENUES. IT
WOULD ENCOURAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO FILED OPIOID
LAWSUITS BEFORE AUGUST TWENTY
FOURTH TO JOIN THE SETTLEMENTS
AND ALLOWS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO RELEASE OR DISMISS ANY
CLAIMS AFTER THAT DATE.
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE STATE PORTION OF ANY
SETTLEMENT MONIES- BETTER
RECEIVED BE USED IN A MANNER
CONSISTENT WITH THE FRAMEWORK
OF THE SETTLEMENT AND WOULD
ALSO BE SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATION. THESE PROVISIONS
WOULD ONLY GO INTO A FACT OF A
STATE WIDE OPEN RATED CREMINS
WAS ENTERED INTO AND WOULD BE
REPEALED AS OF JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WITHOUT
WILL CONCLUDE OUR SUMMARY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ATTORNEY GENERAL BECERRA
WELCOME SIR. BETTER CHAIR AND
NO SENATORS THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH FOR LETTING ME COME BY I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY FOR
EVERYONE AND SO I'LL KEEP MY
REMARKS VERY BRIEF AND- TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS FIRST- THE
PRINCIPLE- REASON FOR AB SIX-
IS THE OPIOIDS I SETTLEMENT
THAT. A MONTH AGO I WOULD HAVE
TOLD YOU THAT WE WORK-
CONTINUING TO TRY BUT NO REAL
SIGNS THAT WE WERE ON THE
HORIZON OF SUCCESS THERE ARE
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED LAWSUITS BY
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES STATES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COUNTIES AND
CITIES TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
THE TERRITORIES WHO ARE SUING
ANY NUMBER OF DEFENDANTS-
DEALING WITH OPIOIDS
MANUFACTURERS DISTRIBUTORS
PHARMACIST. WE ARE ON THE CUSP
OF A SETTLEMENT WITH A NUMBER
OF THOSE MAJOR- DEFENDANTS
THAT- ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO WE
SUBMITTED A DEMAND AND TO THEM
AND WE RECEIVED A COUNTER WHICH
WAS. I THINK A LOT OF US A
LEGITIMATE SERIOUS COUNTER
WHICH GIVES OF THE US THE
PROSPECT OF SETTLING. AND
HERE'S THE IMPORTANT PART. FOR
US TO SETTLE THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED LAWSUITS AND TO SETTLE
THE FIFTY FOR THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WHO HAVE SET UP FILE
LAWSUITS THE TWENTY FIVE OR THE
TWENTY SIX MAJOR CITIES WILL
FILE LAWSUITS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
OUGHT TO COME TOGETHER BECAUSE
THE ONLY WAY THESE SETTLEMENTS
WORK IS IF THE DEFENDANTS AS A
RESULT OF SETTLING CLAIMS HAVE
WHAT THEY CALL GLOBAL PEACE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
BEING BLINDSIDED BY LAWSUIT. SO
AB FIVE BECOMES IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT CARRIES FORWARD- A
PROVISION IT'S ABOUT FOUR
PARAGRAPHS THAT THE MAIN PARTS
OF THE AB SIX THAT OCCURRED
LATE TO OPIATES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. ONE IT SAYS THAT IF
THERE IS A SETTLEMENT. IT HAS
TO CONTINUE TO TERM IN THERE
THAT SAYS THAT MOVING FORWARD
NO OTHER JURISDICTIONS IN THE
STATE WILL BE FILING NEW CLAIMS
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE IT
POSSIBLE T. CLOSE THE DEAL IF
DEFENDANTS ARE STILL SEEN NEW
CLAIM BEING FILED AGAINST
IMPACT THEIR PEACE PLAN SIDE.
SECONDLY IT ALSO SAYS THAT
NOTHING TAKES EFFECT UNTIL
SETTLEMENT IS AN ACTIVE AND THE
SETTLEMENT AND THE TERMS OF THE
SETTLEMENT WILL DRIVE HOW THIS
IS. HOW THE- ANY RESOURCES ARE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TO THAT END TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND SO I HOPE THAT-
ALONG WITH THE OTHER IMPORT
PROVISIONS. THAT THE CENTERS
WILL RECOGNIZE WE HAVE A CHANCE
ACTUALLY THREE. WHAT HAS BEEN
A- DECADES LONG PROBLEM WITH
OPIOIDS AND NOW PROVIDE RELIEF
AT A TIME QUITE HONESTLY WHERE
I THINK MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE STATE ARE STRAPPED
TRYING TO PROVIDE. DECENT
HEALTHCARE TO A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA SO LET ME STOP THERE
HE QUESTIONS ON OPIOIDS OR
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER TWENTY GENERAL LIVES
HERE IF THE PROBLEM FINANCES
HAS ANY COMMENTS BEFORE OPENING
UP TO MEMBER QUESTIONS FINANCE.
AMADOR SENIOR APARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER DORSEY- QUESTIONS
MEMBERS OF THE- IF YOU LET US
KNOW HERE JEFF YOUR QUESTION TO
THE L. A. O. OR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SENATOR NIELSEN I THANK
YOU SIR. ATTORNEY GENERAL
BECERRA QUESTION. YES AFTER
GENERAL THE CITY'S AND COUNTIES
VOICED SOME STRONG OPPOSITION
AND THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THIS ON DOWN. ARE-THOSE CONCERNS GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WE PROCEED HERE.
EIGHT CENTER YES SIR AND- I
JUST GOT OFF A CALL WITH US THE
SECOND A NUMBER OF THE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES- THEIR CONCERN
WAS THAT THEY WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAD A SEAT AT THE
TABLE AND ABSOLUTELY THEIR
RIGHT. AND THAT WILL BE
GUARANTEED THROUGH THE
SETTLEMENT ITSELF AND WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU SENATORS AT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PROVISIONS IN
EIGHTY SIX THAT RELATE TO THE
OPIOIDS SETTLEMENT. AS I SAID
ABOUT FOUR PARAGRAPHS THAT ARE
OPERATIVE IT'S VERY NARROW AND
WHAT IT SAYS IT SIMPLY SAYS
LET'S GET GOING LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE TRY TO GET EVERYBODY ON
BOARD BECAUSE THE WAY THE
SETTLEMENTS WORK. THE
DEFENDANTS PROFFER RESOURCES TO
SETTLE THE CLAIMS THEY WILL NOT
LET GO OF RESOURCES UNTIL THE
CLAIMS ARE RELEASED. THE FEWER
CLAIMS THAT ARE BASED THE LESS
MONEY THAT THEY WILL- I LOOK AT
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY'LL SEND
TO US SO FOR US TO GET THE 100%
SHARE THAT. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT SHOULD
RECEIVE UNDER THE OVERALL
SETTLEMENT WE HAVE TO BE A
CLOSE THE DOOR ON NEW
LITIGATION FOR THESE DEFENDANTS
AND SO THIS BILL SIMPLY. SAYS
MOVING FORWARD. NO MORE NUKES
CAN BE FILED. ALL THIS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE COUNTIES IN THE
CITIES. THAT HAVE ALREADY FILED
THEIR CLAIMS BEFORE AUGUST
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY.
ALL THOSE JURISDICTIONS GET TO
DECIDE DO THEY WANT TO CONTINUE
WITH THEIR LITIGATION WHAT DO
THEY WANT TO JOIN THIS
SETTLEMENT. THAT WILL BE UP TO
THEM THEY WILL NOT BE FORCED TO
CHOOSE. BUT THE JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE NOT YET FILED. THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO WAIT. NOW
AND SAY WAIT NOW WE WANT TO
FIVE. THEY WILL GET TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO THEIR FULL SHARE IN
THE SETTLEMENT. BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO LOCK THE DOOR SO WE
CAN NOW NAIL THE SENATE DOWN
AND GET IT MOVING. SO WE CAN
ALL WITH A CALIFORNIA LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF THE STATE GET
OUR FAIR SHARE. THEN THE-
MISTER TURNER GENERAL AS FAR AS
THE ON THE APPORTIONMENT THERE
FROM OF THE QUOTE SETTLEMENT-
HOW ARE EACH COUNTY HELP WITH
DETERMINE WHAT THEIR SHARES
WILL BE. AND THE EXTRA
OPERATIVE EXPRESSION CENTER YOU
GET RIGHT ON IT SO. THERE IS NO
YET THAT NO SETTLEMENT TODAY
THERE ARE TERMS THAT ARE BEING
NEGOTIATED BUT WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IS THE OUTLINES OF THE
DEAL- PRETTY MUCH FIXED BECAUSE
SOME OF THAT IS DONE BY THE
PLAINTIFFS THE GOVERNMENTS THAT
ARE SUING. AND GENERALLY
SPEAKING THE OVERALL APPROACH
WILL BE THAT WE WILL TAKE THE
PART OF RESOURCES THAT THESE
DEFENDANTS COLLECTIVELY WILL
PROVIDE. AND IT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED 70% OF IT WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO OPIOIDS ABATEMENT
DEAL WITH ADDICTION TO DEAL
WITH- PREVENTION THE THINGS
THAT COMMUNITIES NEED AT HOME
FOR THEIR FAMILIES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES. 15% OF THE POT
WILL BE RESERVED EXCLUSIVELY TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CONTINUE TO DO THE OPIOIDS WORK
THE WAY THEY THINK THEY CAN
SUPPLEMENT WHAT IS THE 70% POT.
AND THEN THE OTHER 50% POT IS
LEFT FOR THE STATE GOVERNMENT
ALSO SUPPLEMENT THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ON OPIOIDS FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FIFTEEN. STATE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
SAY AS TO WHAT HAPPENS TO THE-
LOCAL SHARE LOCALS DON'T HAVE A
SAY IN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
STATE SHARE EVERYONE IN THE
SETTLEMENT STATE AND LOCALS
WILL PARTICIPATE IN DETERMINING
HOW THE SEVENTY PERCENT. IS
ALLOCATED IF THEY DON'T AGREE
THE MONEY SITS IN A LOCAL IN A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA POT NOT IN
ARE NOT IN YOUR- BUDGET I'M
SORRY NINETY YOUR GENERAL FUND
IT SITS IN A- SETTLEMENT POT.
UNTIL ALL THE JURISDICTIONS
LOCAL AND STATE AND DETERMINE
HOW THAT MONEY WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED. THANK YOU ONE LAST
QUESTION. THIS ALSO EXTENDS
YOUR AUTHORITY GREATLY IN A
SORT OF UNPRECEDENTED WAY WERE.
AGENCIES AND ENTITIES CAN
INITIATE LITIGATION BUT YOU
SEPARATELY AND INDEPENDENTLY
CANTU. WHY WHY IS THAT
NECESSARY. ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
THE FISHING GAME PROVISION HERE
THAT IS RIGHT. SIR OCCASION
WHILE I. SENATE WHAT THAT'S
CLEAN UP LANGUAGE OR TRY TO
CLARIFY REMEMBER UNDER THE COST.
THAT OF JUSTICE THE ATTORNEY
HAS INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY. TO
INITIATE ACTIONS TO DEFEND THE
PEOPLE WITH THE RESOURCES AND
THE VALUES OF THE STATE AND WE
HAD A RETURN CASE RECENTLY
WHERE. BECAUSE WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH FISH AND WILDLIFE THEY ARE
STATE LIENT I AM THE ATTORNEY
FOR THE FISH AND WILDLIFE WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOLLOW OUR FIDUCIARY DUTY OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO. PROTECT THE
INTERESTS OF OUR CLIENTS EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
AUTHORITY TO SUE. WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ABIDING BY OUR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY TO OUR
STATE CLIENT. SO THAT THERE
WON'T BE ANY CONFLICT BETWEEN
WHAT I CAN DO INDEPENDENTLY AND
WHAT I MUST DO AS COUNSEL FOR
BY STATE AGENCY CLIENT. WE
ALWAYS MAKE AN EFFORT TO DEFER
TO OUR STATE AGENCY CLIENT AND
WHAT WE DO. BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S CLEAR THAT IF THERE
IS A NEED TO DIFFERENTIATE.
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE DOES NOT LOSE ITS
JURISDICTION. TO INITIATE
ACTIONS THAT THE CONSTITUTION
GIVES US SO TO AVOID. WORK WE
WERE TRYING TO GET THIS CLEAN
UP LANGUAGE INTO THE BILL THAT
WAS THE ACTUAL BASIN BILL AB
SIX. BEFORE IT CAN BE. IN CLEAR
THAT UP I DON'T BEACHWOOD
SETTLEMENT COULD RUN AND WE
DON'T WANT TO MISS THE TRAIN
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIA BEING THE LARGEST
STATE. GETS INTO THAT
SETTLEMENT. AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE- MISTER LETTING OTHER
STATES B. AS TO THE POT. WELL
EXCUSE ME I DO UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHORITIES OF THE. ATTORNEY
GENERAL REPRESENTING AGENCIES.
BUT AS A- LOOK AT HOW HAVE BEEN
DONE HISTORICALLY. THIS IS A
DEPARTURE. BECAUSE YOU ARE NOW
IT KNOWLEDGE IN A SEPARATE AND
INDEPENDENT TRACK. AND IF YOU
DON'T LIKE IT YOU'RE GOING TO.
INVITE YOUR OWN ACTION. AND
THAT'S THE TICKET. AND TO ME I
DON'T THINK THAT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT IT'S A GREAT
EXPANSION OF THE AUTHORITIES OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL I WOULD
LOOK AT IT IN THAT MANNER
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO CONVINCE
ME ON THIS AND OTHER WORDS
MISTER TURNER GENERAL. LET ME
LET ME TRY THE OTHER ROUTE
HERE- CENTER BECAUSE YOU
PROBABLY GOT A GOOD POINT HE
WOULD NOT BE CONSISTENT IN IT
WOULDN'T MAKE SENSE FOR THE
ATTORNEY FOR A STATE AGENCY TO
BE DOING SOMETHING OTHER THAN
WHAT THE STATE AGENCY SETS. AND
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO REALLY-
ABIDE BY OUR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY AS WE- PROTECT
THE INTERESTS OF OUR CLIENTS
AND SO I DON'T THINK YOU'VE
EVER YOU COULD PROBABLY EVER
BRING UP THE CASE IN YOUR
MEMORY WHERE YOU'VE SEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BE AT
ODDS WITH THE STATE AGENCY
CLIENT- IN COURT. AND SO WHAT
WE DON'T EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
CLEAR THAT. IF OUR STATE AGENCY
CLIENT FOR EXAMPLE IS IT GOING
TO GET INVOLVED IN A PARTICULAR
MATTER. THAT IT DOESN'T-
PRECLUDED ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE FROM BEING ABLE TO TAKE
ACTION TO INITIATE ACTION. IF
OUR EIGHT STAGES. FINE IS NOT A
VOTERS. AND WE DON'T WANT IT TO
BE PERCEIVED THAT NO YOU CAN'T
DO THAT BECAUSE YOU STAGE IT
AGENCY CLIENT. IS A DAY IN THAT
ACTUALLY SO LET E EXPLAIN.
THOUGH THERE THE PUT THAT.
EXPLANATION COULD POINT ON WHAT
I JUST SAID. I AM A THE STATE
PROSECUTOR. FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO HAVE FIFTY
EIGHT OTHER LOCAL PROSECUTORS
THE DA'S IN OUR FIFTY ACCOUNTS.
THE SAME STATUTE THAT WE'RE
REFERRING TO THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO CLEAN UP PROVIDES TO THOSE
FIFTY EIGHT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
THE SAME POWERS THAT I'M
TELLING YOU THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO CLARIFY THAT THE AG AT WHICH
IS TO TAKE INDEPENDENT ACTION
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE STATE
AGENCY FISH AND WILDLIFE SAYS
AND SO IT WOULD BE INCONGRUOUS.
TO SAY THAT ANYONE OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS HAVE
THE INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY TO
TAKE ACTION REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THIS- THE STATE AGENCY FISH AND
WILDLIFE SAYS. AND THE-
ATTORNEY GENERAL SUPERVISORS
FIFTY EIGHT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
WOULD NOT SO WHAT WE'RE SIMPLY
TRYING TO DO IS CLARIFY THAT.
THE WAY THIS STATE HAS TO WORK
AGP REPRESENTING ALL STATE
AGENCIES SHOULD NOT UNDERMINE
THE INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY THAT
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES. TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE BUT
AGAIN TO YOUR POINT IS I THINK
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT IT WOULD
BE INCONGRUOUS DEFINED. THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE ACTING
AGAINST THE INTERESTS OF ONE OF
ITS STATE AGENTS CLIENTS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EXPLANATION
ATTORNEY GENERAL CONSIDER ME
REMAINING A SKEPTICAL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ANSWER. YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM MADAM.
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO THE AGE
FOR THAT X. AYE AYE AYE. AND I
AND I APOLOGIZE WE'VE BEEN
PLAYING PHONE TAG- TODAY IT TO
REALLY ADDRESS THIS EXACT ISSUE
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY- BY THE
GOOD SENATOR NIELSEN AYE I AM I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
AS WELL AND PART OF THE
CHALLENGES. ANY TIME YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WATER. IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. IT IS A SUBJECT OF
GREAT CONCERN MOSTLY BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH AND THAT
THAT EXISTS THERE'S ONE BIG
DEBATE OVER WHETHER WERE USING
TOO MUCH WHETHER- MORE SHOULD
BE USED FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AS
OPPOSED FOR FARMING AND- AND AS
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A SUBJECT OF
LITIGATION OVER THE OVER THE
YEARS AND PART OF THE CHALLENGE
WITH THE LANGUAGE. AS IT IS IN
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AND
IT WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME
JUST SAY TO PUT A. POINT OPIOID
SETTLEMENT IN WITH THE BILL
THAT'S GOING TO SIGNIFICANTLY I
BELIEVE IMPACT RURAL CALIFORNIA
AND- CREATES PARANOIA IN THE
WATER ROSE I GET WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IN REGARDS
YOU TAKE POSITION- AGAINST-
YOUR CLIENTS AND I BELIEVE IT
AND I KNOW YOU AND I KNOW THAT
THAT. WOULD BE THE WAY YOU
WOULD HANDLE IT. BUT YOU WON'T
BE THE AG FOREVER AND SO I GET
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW WE'RE
SETTING UP THE SYSTEM AND RIGHT
NOW IT REQUIRES. VISION AND
MYLIFE TO- ACTUALLY INSTITUTED
DO AN INVESTIGATION- AND ANY AS
YOU SAID YOU CAN DO IT
SEPARATELY BUT UT IT REALLY
IS. IS THROUGH THE AT THE A GS
SEVEN OF THE FISH AND WILDLIFE.
I'M A AND THERE THERE'S GREAT
CONSTERNATION ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
WHAT WE'RE REALLY DOING HERE
AND WHETHER IT'S A GREAT
EXPANSION OF THE AUTHOROF YOUR
OFFICE TO GO INTO. AN AREA
WHERE- THERE MAY BE A CONFLICT
IN TERMS OF HOW- AND HOW THE
SITUATION OCCURRED IN AND SOME
OF THE BIGGER PICTURES WHICH IS
ARE WE- ARE WE REALLY
RESTRICTING. FLOWS AND IS THIS
A SITUATION THAT- THAT REQUIRES
THE AG TO COME AND SO I JUST I
HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
PUTTING THESE TWO TOGETHER
NUMBER ONE AND I'VE HEARD. MY
PHONE HAS BLOWN UP OVER THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE-
BECAUSE IT IS CREATING GREAT
ANXIETY IN ROCK CALIFORNIA AND
SO I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE
HI. I'M NOT SURE I AGREE WITH
THAT THE- THE ANALYSIS THAT
IT'S AN EXPANSION THAT IT'S NOT
AN EXPANSION THAT IS IT JUST
CLARIFYING AND SO THAT'S THAT.
I GUESS. THAT'S MY CONCERN.
SENATOR EFFECTIVE AT IF I COULD
HAVE QUICKLY TRY TO REACH. OR
YES. YEAH SO CENTER THANK YOU
FOR THE THAT THE COMMON. THE
REASON THIS CAME UP. BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PHARMACY JUST
AS WE HAVE THAT IN A MINUTE
FORTY AND WE WOULD EXERCISE IT
IF NECESSARY BUT WHAT WE WOULD
DO IS TRY TO EXERCISE AND WHEN
WE HAVE A STATE AGENCY.THAT IS
INVOLVED AND MAYBE TAKING A
PARTICULAR POSITION BECAUSE
AGAIN IT WOULD BE A VIOLATION
OF OUR OF OUR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS IF THAT AGENCY HADN'T
SPOKEN OR IS. STANDING DOWN. WE
DON'T WANT THE IMPRESSION TO BE
THAT. FIFTY EIGHT D. A.'S. CAN
GO AHEAD AND TAKE ACTION
INDEPENDENTLY REGARDLESS EVEN
IF THE- FISHING BY LIKE DECIDED
TO WALK INTO THIS. BUT THE
STATE EIGHTY EIGHT G. WHO
REPRESENTS THIS ALL OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE CALIFORNIA. AND
ALL OF ITS RESOURCES- WHILE
EACH D. A. CAN ONLY REPRESENT
THOSE IN HIS- COUNTY. CAT AND
SO THAT WOULD BE AN
INCONSISTENCY AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS AVOID. THE LAW
HAVING THESE INCONSISTENCIES
BECAUSE A CASE WAS PRODUCT
WHERE THERE WAS NOT A AN ISSUE
BECAUSE WE REPRESENTED. THE
DEPARTMENT- AND THERE WAS NO
CONFLICT BUT THE QUESTION
AROSE. HOW IS IT THAT DJS CAN
GO AHEAD AND ACT INDEPENDENTLY
BUT THE SUPERVISOR. OF THE
STATE'S PROSECUTOR CAN'T DO
WITH FIFTY PROSECUTORS CAN DO
UNDER THE SAME LAW AND SO WE'RE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
AVOID THERE BEING. A AN
INCONSISTENCY AND THAT'S WHY AS
I SAID IT'S REALLY A CLEAN UP
LIKE WE BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS- BUT WHY
HAVE IT BE CLOUDED BY. THIS
SENSE THAT IT'S NOT QUITE CLEAR
AND ONE FINAL CLARIFICATION
CENTER BOB THIS. A LIFE AB SIX
FOR RELATE OPIOIDS IS NOT A
SETTLEMENT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
IT'S CLEAR WE DON'T YET HAVE A
DEAL. WHAT WE HAVE IS
NEGOTIATIONS WHERE WE MADE IT
DEMAND AS THE PLAINTIFF
GOVERNMENTS. ARE TO THE
DEFENDANT- MANUFACTURERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS. AND WE BELIEVE
WE'RE NOW ON THE CUSP OF
GETTING A SETTLEMENT. AND THIS
ALLOWS US TO TRY TO MOVE THAT
DEAL FORTY IN A WAY THAT LETS
CALIFORNIA START TO CLAIM. THE
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE PART OF
THAT SETTLEMENT THAT WOULD BE
ENTITLED. TO OUR STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WELL I'M
HAVING HEARD THAT I DO
APPRECIATE THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN HAVING UP A SETTLEMENT
AND WORKING TOWARDS IT WHY DO
YOU NEED TO THIRTY AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT TO DO IT.
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IS-
THE LETTERS THAT I RECEIVED IN
OPPOSITION FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ARE CONCERNED THAT.
THAT THEY WILL NOT RECEIVE
COMPENSATION FOR THEIR
ATTORNEYS FEES IT THEY'VE
EXPANDED UP TO THIS POINT- MY
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING FROM WHAT
YOU SAID IS IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT
THERE WOULD THAT THERE WOULD BE
A PER. FOR EXPENSES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN PAID BUT IF YOU
COULD ANSWER THAT FOR ME PLEASE
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL. YES
THE- THE NEED IS BASED ON THE
FACT THAT. THE DEFENDANTS HAVE
THE WAY THIS WILL WORK IS THAT.
THE MORE THE DEFENDANTS HAVE
ASSURANCE THAT THEY WILL NOT
FACE LAWSUIT IN THE FUTURE.
FROM THESE PLAINTIFF GOVERNMENT
SINCE. WHETHER IT'S THE
STATE'S. THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COUNTIES CITIES WHETHER IT'S
THE- TERRITORY GOVERNMENT'S OR
WHETHER IT'S THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE MORE THAT THEY
HAVE THAT ASSURANCE THAT THERE
WILL NOT WILL NOT BE A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THEM B. AS A RESULT OF
THE SENATE THE MORE THEY WILL
LET GO THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
ARE OFFERING TO SETTLE THE
CASE. BUT LESS. ASSURANCE THEY
HAVE. BECAUSE ARE NOW RELEASE
FOR THEIR NOT X. BY DIFFERENT
GOVERNMENTS. THE LESS MONEY
THAT. THE STATE AND ITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL RECEIVE FROM
THE POT SO ESSENTIALLY. OUR OUR
STATE OUR CITIES ARE COUNTIES
AND THE STATE. WILL BE HELD
HOSTAGE. BY ANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE NOT YET
SUIT. BUT WHO MAY WANT US TO
INTO THE FUTURE AND THE
DEFENDANTS WILL SAY. WE HAVE TO
FACE THE PROSPECT OF NEW
COUNTIES AND CITIES TRYING TO
SUE IN CALIFORNIA AND THEREFORE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HOLD
BACK SOME OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY MONEY AND THE STATE
MONEY. BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN AND WE DON'T
WANT TO TAKE THAT RISK THAT WE
LAID OUT ALL THIS MONEY AND WE
STILL END UP WITH LAWSUITS
AGAINST US SO WE HAVE TO TRY TO
EQUAL LIBERALIZED EQ. GET IN A
GLITTERING HERE WHERE. ARE THE
DEFENDANTS YET THE ISSUE OF.
SIXTEEN DISTINGUISHING AGAINST
THEM AND WE EVEN GET THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING
COMMITTED IN THE SUMMIT SO WE
CAN ADDRESS THE OPIOID CRISIS
AND SO THIS LEGISLATION IS
SOMETHING SUPPOSED JUST FOUR
PARAGRAPHS AND YOU CAN I CAN
REDO THE PARAGRAPH THAT SPEAKS
TO IT. IT'S VERY SIMPLE JUST AS
THIS. AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY. IF YOU HAVE
FILED. A LAWSUIT ALREADY. YEAH
COUNTY OR CITY OR STATE. YOU
CAN DECIDE. IF YOU WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SETTLEMENT
OR NOT AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
YOU CAN CONTINUE WITH YOUR
LAWSUIT MOM FOR WE CAN'T STOP
THAT THIS BUDGET LEGISLATION
DOESN'T BOB BUT IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY FILED A LAWSUIT HAVING
MADE A CLAIM OF LEGAL CLAIMS
AGAINST. THESE PARTICULAR
DEFENDANTS. YOU CAN'T. IF THIS
BILL PASSES AND THERE'S A
SETTLEMENT THAT'S RICH AND THE
SETTLEMENT HAS TO BE REACHED
JUST JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE THE
BILL DOESN'T WORK AT THE AT TO
GET THE SETTLEMENT IN PLACE.
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO FILE A NEW
LAWSUIT. BECAUSE THAT WOULD
CREATE THE UNCERTAINTY FOR THE
DEFENDANTS THAT WOULD HOLE
CAUSED THEM TO HOLD BACK THE
MONEY. AND SO THIS LEGISLATION
IF IT BECOMES LAW LET'S JUST
QUICKLY RESOLVE CASES THAT ARE
OUT THERE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
LAWSUITS ALREADY. FILED MANY
MORE THAT COULD BE FILED BY
OTHER COUNTIES AND CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. AND SO
WHAT THIS DOES IS FOR THOSE WHO
HAVEN'T ALREADY FILED IT SAYS.
YOU WON'T BE ARE FOUND THE
FUTURE YOU DIDN'T TAKE THE TIME
TO DO IT. BUT YOU WILL GET TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE
SETTLEMENT AND GET YOUR FAIR
SHARE. OUT OF. THE SETTLEMENT
POT IN YOUR JURISDICTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO NEXT TO
A SENATOR BELL FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR MORLOCK. I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'VE BEEN HARMED
DIRECTLY. BY THE OPIOID AND
DRUG ABUSE CRISIS AND AS- MOST
OF YOU KNOW AND- MY CAREER IN
THE LEGISLATURE. HAVE BEEN THE
ONE TO FORM THE ALCOHOL AND
DRUG ABUSE- SELECT COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AND THEN- THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE- WE'VE BEEN. WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE- FOR SOME TIME SO MY
PERSPECTIVE IS. THAT DOES IT
HAVE BEEN HARMED IN CALIFORNIA
ONLY 10% OF THEM ACTUALLY
RECEIVE. SERVICES NECESSARY
THAT MEANS AND 90% DO NOT
RECEIVE SERVICES SO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
SETTLEMENT. IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL I THINK TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE IF IT WAS DONE
RIGHT THAT'S THE POINT I'M
GOING TO MAKE SURE. FOR MANY.
DECADES ACTUALLY. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE REALIGNMENT.
THROUGH ELIMINATING THEIR
ALCOHOL AND DRUG ABUSE
DEPARTMENT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN-
THROUGH- LEGISLATION. HAS
BASICALLY SAID THAT THE
COUNTIES NOT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. ARE THE MAIN
RESPONSIBLE PARTY FOR PROVIDING
SERVICES. TO PEOPLE AFFLICTED
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
NEEDHAM'S NEED OF SERVICES SO
THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
EMERGENCY ROOM WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE CLINICS WE TALK ABOUT
THE DRUG ABUSE PROGRAMS. DO WE
TALK ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS A LOT OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. OUR FUNDED
COORDINATED BY THE COUNTIES SO
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THE COUNTIES
HAVE. A MUCH GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE AFFLICTION.
THAT THIS SETTLEMENT ENTAILS SO
MY QUESTION TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
STATE HAS. IN SOME CASES NOT.
BEEN VERY ASSERTIVE AND DEALING
WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS. WHY
SHOULD THE COUNTY SB. NOT
CONSIDERED EQUAL PARTNERS AT
LEAST AND DEVELOPMENT OF A
SETTLEMENT. AND WHEN I HEARD
THE SETTLEMENT SPLIT I WAS
SURPRISED BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THE COUNTIES. ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE PROVIDING. THE ACTUAL
SERVICE TO PEOPLE I REMEMBER
MYSELF AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
FOR TWELVE YEARS BEEN
THREATENED WITH BEING ARRESTED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
WE ESTABLISH A NEEDLE EXCHANGE
PROGRAM. THEY THREATENED TO
ARREST US IMPORTANCE IS JAIL.
AND WE SAID WELL WE HAVE THE
JAIL IF THE COUNTY SO YOU'RE
NOT TO BE PUT IN US IN OUR
JAILS SO. THEY WEREN'T ALLOWED
TO DO THAT BUT I LIKE TO KNOW
WHY THE COUNTY'S. CARE BE EQUAL
PARTNERS. WITNESSES TURNING
GENERAL AND DISCUSSION OF THE
SETTLEMENT. AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FINDING IT AS
POINTED OUT. IS VERY IMPORTANT
WHY CAN'T THE COUNTIES HAVE
DIRECT. DIRECT SOURCES OF
FUNDING COMING FROM THE
SETTLEMENT RATHER THAN HAVE TO
GO THROUGH SOME STATE
GOVERNMENT PROCESS. AND THOSE
ARE MY QUESTIONS OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THANK VERY
MUCH CENTER BELL MISTER TURNER
GENERAL. SKINNER SEVERAL THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS- SO YOU
WERE OR WHERE THOSE QUESTIONS
HAVE BEEN RAISED DURING THE
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS AND
THAT'S WHY THE SETTLEMENT IT'S-
WILL BE BASED ON THE ACTIONS BY
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO PLAY
GOVERNMENT'S. WHO ARE PART OF
THE SETTLEMENT IF YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF THE SETTLEMENT CLASS
YOU GET TO PARTICIPATE AND EACH
STATE WITH ITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES HOW THEY WISH TO
HAVE THOSE ALLOCATIONS MADE FOR
THE MITIGATION AND ABATEMENT
PROGRAMS. TO ADDRESS- THE
OPIOID ADDICTION AND THE AT THE
CRISIS AND SO IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS WHAT I MENTIONED TO THE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES THAT I
WAS ON THE PHONE WITH A RIGHT
BEFORE WE GOT ON FOR THIS.
BUDGET SESSION- AS I MENTIONED
WE'RE GONNA BE SITTING DOWN
WITH THEM THEY ARE ALL
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL AND WILL
BE SITTING DOWN WITH THEM
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
A WEIGHT OF METHODOLOGY FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE DOLLARS
THAT EVERYONE AGREES TO. IF WE
CANNOT SO ESSENTIALLY EVERYONE
HAS A VETO POWER IF WE CAN'T
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION THE
STATE CAN'T JUST IMPOSE ONE THE%
MONEY IS HELD BY THE SETTLEMENT
ADMINISTRATOR IN A POT NOT THE
GENERAL FUND OF THE STATE IN A
SETTLEMENT POT. AND UNTIL THE
PLAYERS IN THAT STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE COME
TO TERMS THAT MONEY IS HELD IN
THAT POT THE 70% THE 15% THAT
THE. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GET THEY
WILL GET DIRECTLY. IT DECIDE
HOW DO YOU THE STATE WILL GET
THE 50% SHARE AND IT WILL
DECIDE WHAT IT WISHES TO DO. BY
THE WAY AND ALL OF THAT 15% 50%
SURE THAT EACH OF THE- LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AT THE GOVERNMENTAL
AND- ENTITIES GET. WILL BE
DETERMINED BY HOW MUCH
PARTICIPATION THE REASON THE
SETTLEMENT THE MORE THAT THEIR
OUTSTANDING- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT DON'T PARTICIPATE. THE
LAST OF THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE
50% 50% THAT- THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE WE GET
AND SO THAT'S WHY UNITS
IMPORTANT HAVE THIS BILL. SO WE
GET MOVING IN GET EVERY ON
BOARD THAT WATCHED. THOSE THAT
DON'T WANT TO AS I SAY WHO
FORTY FATHER COMES IN COULD
MOVE FORWARD BUT IF YOU'LL
NOTICE TO YOUR POINT BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT- OFTENTIMES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS FELT LIKE IT'S
BEEN. SHORT CHANGED BY THE
STATE. THE MONEY. ARE ABATEMENT
PROGRAMS. MOST OF THOSE
MITIGATION PROGRAMS ON OPIOIDS
ARE RUN BY COUNTY HEALTH
FACILITIES. NOT THE STATE AND
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
BECAUSE OUR SETTLEMENT IS
DICTATING THAT THE MONEY MUST
BE SPENT ON OPIOID SERVICES
ABATEMENT PREVENTION.
MITIGATION SERVICES THOSE MY
WILL HAVE TO END P IN THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHO DO THOSE
SERVICES AND THE STATE IS NOT
IN THE BUSINESS OF DOING DAY TO
DAY OPIOID WORK. COUNTY ARE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS THAT DO IT
EARLIER THIS THAT DOES THE
STATE. BECAUSE OF ITS- NOT
DIRECT ENGAGEMENT ON THE OPIOID.
CRISIS IS GOING TO UNDER
ESTIMATE THE COST. AND THIS IS
CONCERNING ME REGARDING THE
SETTLEMENT BECAUSE I THINK IF
WE LOOK AT IT FROM A STANDPOINT
OF WHAT KIND OF IMPACTS THEIR
DIRECT AND INDIRECT IMPACTS. R.
THE SETTLEMENT DOLLAR AMOUNTS-
WE DON'T WANT TO BE TOO LOW.
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HARMED
IN MANY LIFELONG MULTI
GENERATIONAL WAYS. BECAUSE OF
THIS- FOR EXAMPLE. WHEN YOU GO
AYE AYE VISIT MIKE TWENTY SIX
PRISONS. EVERY TIME I GO ASKED
WARDENS HOW MANY OF PEOPLE ARE
HERE BECAUSE OF MENTAL HEALTH
OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE. AND HE SAID
YOU KIDDING ALMOST ALL OF THEM.
AND ALMOST EVERY WORD SAYS
7590% YOU YOU YOU ARE AWARE AS
YOU TURN GENERAL OF THIS. SO
THE COST TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN TERMS OF OUR
PRISONS AND THE COUNTIES IN
TERMS OF THE JAILS. IS
SOMETHING IF WE HAD A FULL
SERVICE DRUG TREATMENT FREE
AVAILABLE DRUG TREATMENT. WOULD
BE TREMENDOUSLY IMPACTED IN A
POSITIVE WAY. SO I TAKE THE
COUNTIES CAN ADMINISTER AND
OPERATE SUCH A PROGRAM. AND MY
URGING IS TO USE THE MODEL WHEN
WE CREATED THE CHILDREN'S
HEALTH CARE WITH THE CIGARETTE.
SETTLEMENT WHEN WE HAD THAT WE
ENDED UP HAVING ALL THE KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA WHETHER UNDOCUMENTED
OR OR UNINSURED BY OTHER MEANS
COVERED. WHERE THE CHILDREN'S
HEALTH CARE. FUNDS COMING FROM
THE TOBACCO LAWSUIT SETTLEMENT.
AND THAT'S HOW THOSE PROGRAMS
WERE FUNDED WE CAN DO THE
SIMILAR THING WORKING WITH
COUNTIES FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE IN
CALIFORNIA SO. I URGE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK. AT THE AT
THE ATATURK ISSUE AND HAVE IT
AS PART OF THE GOALS OF A
SETTLEMENT TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE DRUG TREATMENT
PROGRAM. FOR EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO NEEDS IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BEFORE I GO TO A
US SENATOR MORE LOCKED UP
QUICKLY- MISTER TWENTY GENERAL
YOU MENTIONED THE COUNTIES AND
MEETING WITH C. SECOND COUPLE
TIMES WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM OUR
CITY ATTORNEYS WILL ARE THEY
BEING INCLUDED IN THE
CONVERSATION. YES THEY ARE AND
SOME OF THE CITIES ARE
REPRESENTED BY OUTSIDE COUNSEL
VERSES ARE CITY ATTORNEYS SO
WHOEVER THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE OPIOID
CASE ARE THE FOLKS THAT WE'VE
BEEN NEGOTIATING AND TALKING
TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
MORE LOT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IN THANK YOU ATTORNEY GENERAL
BECERRA- CENTER BELL JUST. YEAH
IN THE CONCLUDING REMARKS.
STARTED TO ADDRESS- SOME WHERE
WHERE I'VE ALREADY BEEN BEFORE
WERE BOTH A LITTLE OLDER BUT
IN. NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE STATE
OF MISSISSIPPI MISTER MICHAEL
MOORE WAS SUCCESSFUL IN.
FURTHERING THE NATIONAL TOBACCO
SETTLEMENT IN A ATTORNEY
GENERAL DAN LUNGREN WAS
INVOLVED AT THAT TIME A BIT IT
CREATED A REVENUE STREAM SORT
OF AN ANNUITY- SO ALL THOSE
THAT WERE BENEFITING FROM THE
SETTLEMENT AND SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I'D LIKE
TO JUST PUT BEFORE YOUR JUST.
LAY ON THE TABLE YOU CAN. TECH
ONE AT A TIME OR HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THEM BUT I WANT
TO KNOW IF YOU'RE WORKING ON A
SETTLEMENT THAT TO LUNCHTIME.
OR IF IT IS AN ANNUITY. AND
THEN YOU'VE ALREADY KIND OF
ADDRESS HOW WILL BE APPROPRIATE
WITH THE FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FIFTEEN PLAN BUT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT MISAPPROPRIATION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVED.
ITS SHARE OF THE SETTLEMENT SO
DID ALL THE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE STATE-
THROUGH GOVERNOR THEN GOVERNOR
DAVIS TOOK THAT REVENUE STREAM
SECURITIZED DEBT AND ISSUED A
BOND TO. BALANCE THE BUDGET AND
SO THAT MONEY DIDN'T GO TO
PROGRAMS LIKE SENATOR BILL WAS
REFERRING TO MOST OF IT WAS
EATEN UP AND PRINCIPAL AND
INTEREST- SO IT WAS. I THINK
MISAPPROPRIATED IT WAS NOT USED
FOR WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO START
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT KIND OF
PROTECTIONS YOU'RE PUTTING INTO
THIS EEMENT SO THAT IT DOES GO
WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO GO. AND
THEN- SINCE WE'RE USING A BETA
PROGRAMS- WEEK WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE USE IT FOR
ABATEMENT PROGRAMS AND THEN MY
LAST QUESTION MIGHT BE IT IS A
QUESTION FOR THE CHAIR- WE HAVE
TWO SEPARATE VERY DISTINCT
SUBJECTS IN THIS BILL. AND I'M
JUST WONDERING WHY. SHOULD THE
BILL CAN BE SINGLE SUBJECT AS
OPPOSED TO SETTLEMENT TEAM
BUILDING VERSUS FISHING GAME
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO MAYBE
GET AN EXPLANATION. ON THAT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER GENERAL. THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY FIRST THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION HAD IT I ALMOST
GET THE IMPRESSION THAT YOU'VE
BEEN INSIDE OR NEGOTIATIONS
BECAUSE YOU'VE SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT WERE RAISED VERY
EARLY ON BY A LOT OF OLKS WHO
WERE IS. TO SOME DEGREE
DISSATISFIED WITH THE WAY THE
TOBACCO SETTLEMENT ROLLED OUT
AND LESSONS LEARNT A LOT OF
FOLKS SAID THEY LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH MASSIVE
SETTLEMENTS THAT WAY THAT
BROUGHT LARGE PARTS OF MANY TO
EACH JURISDICTION AND HOW TO
MAKE SURE IT ACTUALLY GOT USED
THAT'S WHY WE STARTED FROM THE
PREMISE THAT A 100% OF THE
FUNDS. MUST GO INTO OPIOIDS
SOME OF THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND STATES THAT WHAT WE GOT TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE OPIOIDS MAY
HAVE CAUSED A LACK OF.
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY FOR KIDS
AND WE'D LIKE TO GET THE FAT
THE KIDS OR THE- PARENTS WHO
DIED FROM OPIOIDS. TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE A
CHANCE FOR GOOD EDUCATION FOR.
OPIOID JUST BECAUSE INCREASED
CRIME IN SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND A LOT OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE BEEN TAX
DEALING WITH. THAT DRUG
ADDICTION AND WE SHOULD
COMPENSATE THOSE WHO PROTECTED
PEOPLE DURING THIS CRISIS. AND
SO THAT'S WHY YOU YOU SAW THE
15% AND 15% SHARE FOR THE
LOCALS. AND THE STATE'S THIS
STILL HAS TO BE USED FOR
OPIATES IT HAS TO BE RELATED TO
OPIATES BUT IT HAS A LITTLE BIT
MORE DISCRETION. ON WHAT WE
WOULD DEFINE IS STILL TACKLING
THE CONSEQUENCES OF OPIOID
ADDICTION. BUT 70% OF THE FUNDS.
OPIOIDS AND WHO DECIDES IT'S
NOT THIS. IT WILL BE THE ALL
THOSE PLAYERS THE STAKEHOLDERS
THIS DOES THE PLAINTIFFS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COUNTY CITIES AND
THE STATE COMING TOGETHER AND-
WORKING OUT THE ARRANGEMENTS
AND SO WHAT WILL BE A LUMP SUM
WILL BE ANYBODY WITH WILL BE
ONLY DIRECTED. TO PROGRAM
SPECIFIED PROGRAM THAT WILL BE
UP TO THOSE IN THE. SITTING
DOWN JUST HOW. WILL ALLOCATE
THAT SAID PERCENT SHARE AND
ONLY THAT WAY AND IN TERMS OF
ANY MISAPPROPRIATION AND AGAIN
I THINK HERE'S WHERE THE
CONCERN IS BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT THE STATE MAY.
USE THAT MONEY IN WAYS THAT
WERE NOT EXPECTED UP. THERE AT
THE TABLE. THIS IN THIS A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IT WAS
CLEAR FROM THE VERY GET GO.
THEY WILL BE AT THE TABLE MOST
OF THOSE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
LAWSUITS CLEARLY ARE NOT THE
STATE'S THERE ONLY FIFTY STATES.
IT'S MOSTLY CITIES AND COUNTIES
AND QUITE HONESTLY IT'S THE
COUNTIES THAT COUNT THE MOST
BECAUSE IN MOST PLACES
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA. IF THE
COUNTIES WILL PROVIDE. PUBLIC
HEALTH. MENTAL HEALTH ALL THE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND SO THEY
WILL BE AT THE TABLE AND THIS
BILL. AB SIX DOES NOT DETERMINEOR DIRECT HOW THOSE DOLLARS
WILL BE ALLOCATED. THAT IS ONLY
THROUGH THE SETTLEMENT AND SO
THIS BILL ALL IT DOES IS TRY TO
GET US TO MOVE TO GET THOSE
DOLLARS BECAUSE WILL FALL WAY
BEHIND. IF WE CAN'T GUARANTEE
THAT IN CALIFORNIA. THOSE
DEFENDANTS CAN LET GO OF THOSE
DOLLARS HE COMMITTED FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THE LESS THAT THEY
CAN CLICK GOAL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE. THE LIABILITY
RELIEF THAT THEY NEED. THE LESS
WILL BE ABLE TO DO WITH THE
FUNDS THAT ARE THERE. THANK YOU
TAMBIéN I'M SURE WHAT ABOUT
THE QUESTION OF SINGLE SUBJECT.
ALL L. A. O. OR FINANCES EITHER
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SURE I CAN HEAR
MY- WE CAN GIVE US YOUR NAME SO
THEY CAN FINALLY GET YOU ON THE
SCREEN THIS IS OUR NUMBERS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BY
TERMS OF CIVIL CIVIL- SORRY
SINGLE SUBJECT ISSUE- I DON'T
HAVE ANY. COMMENTS ON THAT EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A LIFE PROPOSAL
I WOULD DIE. FOR TO ALLEN IF
THEY HAVE LOTS. ANYONE FAMILIAR.
THIS IS A NEED ONLY WHAT THE L.
A. L. I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
LOT OF TROUBLES ON AND WE WOULD
DEFER TO THE LEGISLATURE- IN
TERMS OF THE CHOICE IN TERMS OF
WHAT TO INCLUDE SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD. A MINUTE
SURE WE'RE GETTING YOU KNOW
PULLED FROM A LOT OF SITES
ACTED TOWNIES THAT ARE OPPOSED
THIS BILL I'VE GOT. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SAID THAT SUPPORT IT
SO I'M- BOTH A LITTLE CONCERNED
OBVIOUSLY YOU SIR SHORT NOTICE
AND GETTING INUNDATED- BUT IT'S
IT WOULD SEEM THAT IF THIS.
WOULD HAVE BEEN TWO BILLS THAT
WOULD HAVE RELEASED RESOLVE
ONE. PART OF THE EQUATION. ALL
I KEEP LISTENING TO THE OTHER
QUESTIONS IN IN TESTIMONY IN IT
TO WITNESSES THAT CALL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR LETTING ME
PARTICIPATE. I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK THE ONE THING I
WOULD SAY IN RESPONSE IN TWO
MORE LIKE THAT BECAUSE IT ALL
INVOLVES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THAT DOES TECHNICALLY-
FIT WITHIN OUR SINGLE SUBJECT
RULE. BECAUSE IT ALL HITS THE
SAME DEPARTMENT BUT I CAN UNDER.
WHAT YOU'RE CHALLENGE OF HAVING
PEOPLE WANTING TO SUPPORT SOME
ASPECTS OF IT AND OTHERS WANTED
TO SUPPORT A DIFFERENT ASPECT
SO THANK YOU. I HAVE. SENATOR
HER TOP. WHO WILL BE FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR DOLLY AND THEN
SENATOR SKINNER FILTER HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- YOU KNOW
I JUST WANTED TO RIGHTS AND
EXPRESS MY CONCERN ON THIS.
BUDGET ITEM UP VERTICALLY
AROUND A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT
FIGHT GOOD FOR A FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FROM A SALINAS
MENTIONED. EARLIER TODAY- BUT
MORE THAN ANYTHING I WILL
SUPPORT IT IN COMMITTEE I JUST.
WANT X. MY CONCERNS THAT- AND
MAY NOT ABOUT FRED ON THE FLOOR.
THAT IS IT. THANK YOU US
SENATOR DOLLY. GOOD EVENING. I
WANTED TO- FIRST OFF JUST TO
SAY THAT. I LISTEN TO THE
COMMENTS VERY CLOSELY OF- GOOD
SENATOR SENATOR BELL WHO SERVED
START TO AT TWELVE YEARS. ON
THE UP OR SUPERVISORS AND I
HAPPEN TO EXCEED HIM BY SIX FOR
YEARS I HAVE SIXTEEN YEARS
HAPPENED TO BE AROUND WHEN WE
DID THAT. BACK OF SETTLEMENT.
AND SO ONE OF MY GET MAKE GUESS
MY QUESTIONS ARE I MEAN THERE
WAS A LOT OF THINGS THAT WENT
WRONG WITH THE THAT I THINK IN
AND AS WE ALL HEARD TODAY. ALL
OF THE SUPPORT I'VE ELEVEN
COUNTIES- IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THE LAST HOUR HOUR AND A HALF
MY PHONE HAS BEEN BLOWING UP IN
MY EMAILS HAVE BEEN BLOWING UP
AND- THEN JUST QUITE QUITE
FRANKLY MY OWN EXPERIENCE WITH
THE TOBACCO. WHAT WHAT WE WANT
IT'S BACK I WANT TO STAY
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN
SAID. THAT IS YOU KNOW THESE
PHARMACEUTICALS THAT MADE
THESE. VERY DICKEY DRUGS IN NEW
THEIR ADDICTIVE AND PLAYED OFF
ON OUR CITIZENS NUMBER ONE I
THINK THEY NEED TO BUILD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AND JUST LIKE
JUST LIKE TOBACCO COMPANIES
WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND IT
WASN'T UNTIL WE DID PROP. GEN
THE FIRST FIVE COMMISSIONS IN
THOSE WHO REALLY STARTED SEEING
THE TOBACCO MONIES ACTUALLY GET
DOWN TO WHERE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY HELPING THE PEOPLE.
THAT WERE AFFECTED BY HEALTH.
AND SO. I MY QUESTION IS FOR
THE FOR THE- ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU ON THE ZOOM BY
THE WAY SIR. AND WHAT IS THE
URGENCY HERE THERE'S A LITTLE
LACKING A LOT OF DETAIL. ON HOW
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO PLAY
OUT OBVIOUSLY YOU STATED. QUITE
CLEARLY HOW THE- YOU KNOW
PERCENTAGES ARE SET FORTH BUT-
THE DEVIL IS ALWAYS IN THE
DETAILS AND THE COUNTIES ARE
THE ONES THAT REALLY GET THE
SERVICES OUT AND I'M CONCERNED-
THAT. THIS MAY NOT PLAY OUT IN
THE OR COULD BE IN THE SUN SAME
MANNER. AS A TOBACCO SETTLEMENT
SUBCOMMITTEE COULD YOU GIVE ME
A REASON WHY WE HAVE TO DO
THIS. TODAY NUMBER ONE. AND WHY
CAN'T WAIT FOR I KNOW THAT I
HEARD THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY OTHER PEOPLE
THE TABLE BUT UP. THERE THEY'RE
GONNA BE HED ACCOUNTABLE THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC KNOWS. THAT
THEY KNEW. AND THEY HAVE DEEP
POCKETS TRUST ME THERE'S
ANYBODY HAS DEEP POCKETS THEY
HAPPEN. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. SO THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION. AFTER A GREAT ANSWER
OF COURSE SIR. THANK YOU SENATE
ALL YES GOOD TO SEE YOU AND A
GOOD QUESTION AND I'LL TRY
ANNALISE'S DIPLOMATICALLY AS I
CAN. MOST OF THESE CASES AB I
KNOW THEIR CASES HAVE BEEN OUT
FOR SIX SEVEN YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN AROUND- AS I SAID THERE'S
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED RIGHT
NOW LAWSUIT FILED THROUGHOUT
THIS. COUNTRY. HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENS AND I THINK YOU'LL GET
THIS ALL. AND YOUR NUMBER OF
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE FOR
WHATEVER REASON DID NOT FILE
MANY CASES BECAUSE LIKE
PROBABLY MANY COUNTIES IN YOUR
DISTRICT THEY'RE SMALL AND THEY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES.
IF THEY PARTICIPATE IN THE
SENATE THERE GONNA GET THEIR
SHARE OF WHAT WOULD COME TO
THEM EVEN IF THEY NEVER. PUT A
FOOT IN THE DOOR TO FILE A
LAWSUIT. BUT HERE'S WHAT THE
MOSTLY THE DEFENDANT'S FEAR BUT
I THINK THEY'RE RIGHT. THE
MOMENT THIS IS ANNOUNCED AS A
SETTLEMENT DEAL. SOME BRIGHT
ATTORNEY IS GONNA GO RENT TO
WHEN YOU'RE COUNTIES AND SAY
YOU HAVEN'T FILED YET. YOU KNOW
IF YOU FILE YOU MIGHT BE TO
EXTRACT A LITTLE BIT MORE OUT
OF THESE COMPANIES. BY SAYING
THAT YOU NOW I FILE YOUR OWN
LAWSUIT SO NOW IT'S NOT JUST
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED LAWSUITS
AGAINST IS TO DEFEND IT NOW
STREET FIVE HUNDRED AND ONE AND
SO THEY SHOULD UP THEIR DEAL A
LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE IN MORTGAGE. YOU'RE
PRETTY LEGALLY. AND WHAT IT
DOES. AND BY THE WAY THE-PROBABLY DO THAT FOR. HANDS AND
FEET. THAT BRIDGE EVEN THOUGH
THEY PROBABLY NEVER TAKE THAT
ALL THE WAY TO COURT. RIGHT AND-
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS AVOID THE
GAMING OF THE SYSTEM WE'RE
CLOSE. BUT SOMEONE'S GOING TO
FEEL LIKE THEY CAN GET PRETTY
SMART AND TRY TO GAME THE
SYSTEM AND SEE IF THEY CAN
EXTRACT A LITTLE BIT MORE. AND
WHAT THAT DOES IS IT IT WILL
MAKE. IF AND IT'S A COOK THIS
IS WHAT WE TOLD YOU GUYS ABOUT.
CERTAINTY THIS IS. AND THAT'S
WHY IN THE SENATE YOU WILL FIND
LANGUAGE AS- THE MORE
UNCERTAINTY THERE IS- IN TERMS
OF OUR BEING SUED OR THE
CAPABILITY OF OTHER GOVERNMENTS
TO SUE US. THE LAST WEEK AND
LET GO OF BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
WATCH OUT. WE HAVE TO KEEP
MONEY IN OUR POCKETS TO FIGHT
OFF ANY POTENTIAL RISK. AND SO
IT DEPRIVES THOSE COUNTIES IN
YOUR DISTRICT ARE SAYING WE
COULD'VE FOUGHT TO SEE ANY OUT.
WE'RE WILLING TO TAKE OUR
SHARE. OF THE SETTLEMENT AND
YOUR- WILL BE DIPPED OF MONEY.
BECAUSE THE DEFENDANTS WILL
HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY WE CAN'T
LET IT ALL GO. AND WHILE THIS
DEAL WILL BE IN THE END INTHE
BILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE GETTING IN THE BILLIONS.
THERE'S A VERY STRONG CHANCE IF
WE HAVE A LOT OF THIS GAMING
GOING ON THAT WE MAY FIND THAT
WE ARE. PRECLUDED FROM GETTING.
AND FOR MAYBE A LONG TIME. ALL
OF OUR FAIR SHARE WHICH COULD
BE WORK LEAVING AT LEAST
MILLIONS PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF
NO AND POSSIBLY BILLIONS ON THE
TABLE AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WANTS. TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER AND I THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS A LOT OF WRANGLINGS
GOING ON WHEN YOU HAVE- YOUR
THERE'S RISK I HEAR YOU. AND AS
SOMEBODY WHO SAT IN MANY OF
THOSE BOARD MEANS. MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS AS WE HAD TRIAL
ATTORNEYS SUING US FOR
EVERYTHING IN THE COUNTY OVER
AT ACCESS AND- KNOW THAT THE
DESK WAS A QUARTER OF AN INCH
TOO TALL. OR TOO LOW OR
WHATEVER YOU NAME IT. LOOK
THERE'S ALWAYS AN ATTORNEY OUT
THERE THAT WILL- TAKE A CASE
OUT ON THE- ON THE ABILITY BILL
SETTLED OUT NOT EVER TAKE IT TO
COURT WE GET THAT- SO I GUESS
MY I JUST WANT TO MAKE A LOT
COMMON I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- DELETED. THE URGENCY
OF IT I KNOW THAT THERE'S
EVERYBODY OUT THERE. TALKING.
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S A BIG STAKE
IN THIS GAME I THERE'S COUNTY
IN A PARTY. TOGETHER INCLUDING
SOME THAT I REPRESENT. THEY ARE
VERY NERVOUS- AND EDUCATION BUT
REASON I RAN FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATORS BECAUSE I DON'T
TRUST THE STATE LEGISLATURE
THEY'VE BEEN. TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF MY OPINION OF COUNTIES FOR
EVER- PASSING UNFUNDED MANDATES
AND THE LIKE AND I WAS THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS I RAN FOR
THIS JOB WAS TO. BUT SOME. YOU
KNOW STOPPING IT BECAUSE IT
THEY REALLY THE ONES THAT THEY
DO GET THE SERVICES AND THEY'RE
HAMSTRUNG AND THEY HAVE NO
ABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO RAISE
REVENUES- AND I AND AS I STATED
EARLIER. YOU KNOW WE SAW THE
PRODUCT DIDN'T TAKE HIM OUT OF
THAT WAS AS YOU CAN GET FIFTY
CENTS A PACK WENT TO THE
COUNTIES DIRECTLY AND THEY- WE
USED IT TO. FIND OUR UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITY WAS AWESOME-
WAS IT ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF HEALTH ISSUES. IN
OUR COUNTIES AND WE WERE ABLE
TO FIND IT SO. I'M NOT GOING TO
BE A BUT I'M GONNA BE OPPOSING
THIS BILL TODAY JUST TO JERRY I
THINK WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
TIME A LOT MORE DETAIL. NOTHING
AGAINST THE THAT YOUR OFFICE OR
WHAT YOU'RE DOING THERE BUT I
THINK IT IF WE DO A LOT MORE
WORK. APPRECIATE YOUR- ANSWERS
IN THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR FOR
THE. THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLAR
FINISHES. YOU MADAM CHAIR SO TO
THE AG ARE PRE IS TO OF THE
GAMING THAT COULD OCCUR HOWEVER
I THINK THE- WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT. THE DAMAGE THAT THOSE
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES WHO
KNOWINGLY ANDREA TOBACCO AND
ALLERGIES ARE QUITE ACCURATE TO
MAKE YOUR KNOWINGLY. DEVELOPED
A PRODUCT. THAT THE NEWS WAS
HIGHLY ADDICTIVE AND
PURPOSEFULLY PUSHED IT AND
PUSHED THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY WE
DID NOT REVEAL THE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW HOW MUCH THEY KNEW
ABOUT ITS ADDICTION. OUR
CAPABILITIES BUT THEN PUSH THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO UTILIZE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND TO UTILIZE
IT FOR SO MANY MORE. TYPES OF
TREATMENTS THEN REALLY WOULD
EVER BE JUSTIFIED AND WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE DAMAGE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES TO FAMILIES TO
INDIVIDUALS TO OUR COUNTIES TO
OUR CITIES. IT IS SO SEVERE
THAT I HESITATE TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE WOULD NOW
PREVENT ANY FUTURE LAWSUITS
BECAUSE I THINK THERE COULD BE
MORE THE COULD BE UNCOVERED
FIRST. SO I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT NOW BUT I
THINK THE MOST SERIOUS CONCERN
IS THAT. WE ARE RECEIVING
COMMUNICATIONS FROM OUR CITIES
AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN.
THAT HAVE BEEN PARTY'S THESE
LAWSUITS WHO INDICATED THAT
THEY HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE
AG'S OFFICE THAT JUST AS THE AG
DESCRIBED THIS TYPE OF. GLOBAL
SETTLEMENT IS NOT UNCOMMON AND
SO WHAT I'M GETTING FROM THE
CITIES AND THE COUNTIES IS NOT
SO MUCH THAT THEY ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS. POTENTIAL CONCEPT BUT
RATHER THE ONCE MORE THE
DETAILS WORKED OUT AND OUT WHEN
THEY LOOK AT WHAT THE DETAILS
SO FAR THE OTHER STATES. THE
LEGISLATION THAT OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE THAT WOULD
INCORPORATE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THERE'S MORE OF THE DETAIL HAS
BEEN SPELLED OUT AND THAT THEY
ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT WITHOUT
THAT SPELLED OUT DETAIL. WE ARE
REALLY TOO MUCH WASHING YOUR
HANDS OF. OF HOW- HOW THESE
FUNDS MIGHT BE DISPERSED AND-
HI I THINK THE AG IF YOU WANT
TO RESPOND TO THAT I KNOW YOU
TO SORT OF ADDRESS THIS BUT
THAT IS THE CLEAR
COMMUNICATION. THAT WE ARE
GETTING FROM OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES. AND MANAGER IF I
COULD RESPOND YES PLEASE.
SERVICE CENTER SKINNER OF AND
GOOD POINT AND- HERE'S WHAT
CONFUSES ME ABOUT WHAT SOME OF
THE- THE ATTORNEYS FOR THESE-
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SAYING-
THIS BILL IN NO WAY CAN DRIVE
ANY PART OF THE SETTLEMENT
DISCUSSION. THE REALITY IS THAT
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS. TWO
THINGS. FIRST IT SAYS. IF YOU
HAVEN'T ALREADY FILED A CLAIM
AGAINST THESE DEFENDANTS. THEN
YOU CAN'T RUSH TO THE
COURTHOUSE TO TRY TO DO IT NOW
WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY MAKE
THE DEFENDANTS BACK OFF OF
PROVIDING THE FULL RESOURCES IN
THE SECOND. AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO SAY. THE GAME HAS CONCLUDED
LET'S TALLY UP THE SCORE SO WE
CAN MOVE AND DETERMINE HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE IT TO DEAL WITH THE HARM
CAUSED BY THE OPIOID CRISIS.
IT'S AND IT'S VERY CLEAR MOST
OF THE PEOPLE YOU'RE HEARING
FROM. ARE THE FOLKS WHO HAVEN'T
SUIT. IT'S THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
TO. AND CRAPPIE HONEST WITH YOU
AND FORGIVE ME AGAIN I'M GONNA
TRY TO BE DIPLOMATIC YOU'RE NOT
HEARING SO MUCH FROM THE
SUPERVISORS FROM THEIR
ATTORNEYS. AND BY THE WAY. GO
DEEPER YOU'RE NOT REALLY
HEARING FROM THE COUNTY
COUNCIL'S. YOU'RE HERE FOR THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS THAT THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE HIGHER.
THE FOLLOWING THIS BUILT IN A
DAY. WILL END UP PROVIDING FOR
ATTORNEYS FEES. SUBSTANTIALLY
IN THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS- I
UNITED I'M I WILL TELL YOU I AM
UP TO HEAR. WITH THESE
ARGUMENTS THAT I'M HEARING
BECAUSE- THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE THIS
BILL CANNOT CLOSE THAT DOOR.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS NO MORE
NEW LAWSUITS AGAINST THESE
DEFENDANTS SINCE YOU KNEW THIS
THIS WORK ON THE SETTLEMENT HAS
BEEN UNDER WAY FOR MORE THAN
TWO YEARS. AND SO TO RUSH TO
THE COURTHOUSE DOOR TO FILE A
CLAIM WHEN WE GOT THE
SETTLEMENT IN PLACE IS SIMPLY
TO REALLY. GET IN THE WAY OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE READY TO
MOVE FORWARD DOING SO AND THE
FINAL THING I MENTIONED IS THE
OTHER IMPORTANT PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL THAT SPEAKS TO THIS.
OPIOID IT SAYS WHAT THE SET UP
WITH A STATEWIDE OPIATE OPIOID
SIX SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS. IT
SAYS IT MEANS ANY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS. ARE CONSENT PER
STIPULATED JUDGMENT AND RELATED
DOCUMENTS. CONCERNING OPIOIDS
DETECTOR BOB THE FUNDS OBTAINED
THIS IS ELEVEN NINE NINE NINE
POINT THREE TO THE FUNDS
OBTAINED BY THE STATE. PURSUANT
TO A STATEWIDE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PURSUANT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT SHALL BE
DISTRIBUTED NOT PURSUANT THIS
IS BILL BUT SHALL BE
DISTRIBUTED IN A MANNER.
CONSISTENT WITH THAT AGREEMENT.
IN A MANNER CONSISTENT WITH
THAT AGREEMENT THAT MEANS THIS
BILL DOESN'T DRIVE ANYTHING
WITH REGARD TO THE SETTLEMENT.
IT SIMPLY SAYS NO MORE RUSHING
TO THE COURTHOUSE DOOR TO FILE
CLAIMS THAT YOU COULD HAVE
FILED A TIME TO AND YOU MUST
ABIDE BY THE TERMS OF THAT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WHICH AS
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSED ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY WITH OTHER SENATORS.
MUST INCLUDE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE STATE GOVERNMENT
DETERMINING HOW THOSE MONIES
WILL BE JUST DISPERSED IN THAT
STATE JURISDICTION. YES SO
IT'S- BACK IF YOU SENSE OF
FRUSTRATION IS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHY IT'S TAKEN SO LONG TO GET
TO THIS POINT. BECAUSE WE'VE
ALWAYS GOT SOMEBODY WHO WANTS
TO KNOCK ON THE DOOR. AND I
WILL TELL YOU THERE ARE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN WAITING TO GET RELIEF IF
THESE FOLKS ARE REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT NEEDING TO FILE A CLAIM.
THEN WHY HAVEN'T THEY DONE IT
BACK TO PROTECT THE INTERESTS
OF THE FOLKS AND THEY SAY THEY
REPRESENT. IT IS KIND OF
INTERESTING THAT ONLY NOW THAT
WE SEEM TO HAVE A SETTLEMENT AT
HAND. ONLY NOW TO HEAR PEOPLE
SAY OH MY GOSH MY CHANCE TO SUE
IS GOING TO BE LIMITED. YOU HAD
YEARS YOU'VE KNOWN ABOUT THE
OPIOID CRISIS FOR YEARS WHY DID
YOU FINALLY GET TO PROTECT YOUR
PEOPLE BACK THEN. YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THIS TO COME LAST
MINUTE WE DID NOT EXPECT THE
DEFENDANT TO GIVE US A SOLID
RESPONSE TO WORK TO OUR DEMAND.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO BRING THIS YEAR THE
TIPPING POINT TO A GOOD END.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET THIS
BE ABUSED BY BY INDIVIDUALS WHO
JUST WANT TO. REALLY GET IN THE
SYSTEM. IF I CAN JUST FOLLOW UP
ABSOLUTELY SAID THANK YOU
CHAIR. SO I AM HEARING FROM
MAYORS I AM NOT ONLY HEARING
FROM CITY ATTORNEYS I'M ALSO
HEARING FROM MEMBERS OF PORTS
OF SOUPS. NOW YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THEY COULD HAVE USED AN
EXTERNAL COUNSEL. BUT THE ONES
I AM HEARING FROM MARK ACTUALLY
FILED LAWSUITS SO THEY'RE NOT
PARTY THEY'RE NOT ENTITIES THAT
DID NOT FILE A LAWSUIT. SO THAT
THEIR OBJECTION IS NOT THAT DAY
WOULD. LATER BE PRECLUDED
THOUGH I THINK THERE IS A
LEGITIMATE ISSUE AROUND OUT BUT
LET IT GO LET THAT DECIDE I
THINK THERE'S- A- IF THE BILL
IS AS SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD THEN IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND WHY THOSE
CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN'T READ
IT IN THE SAME WAY THAT YOU ARE
DESCRIBING AND I THINK. THAT
ALONE THERE IS EITHER A SERIOUS
LACK OF COMMUNICATION OR DAY
THEIR READ IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN THE ARE AT DOJ'S READ- AND
IT'S HARD FOR US TO DISCERN
RIGHT NOW WHICH WHICH IS THE
CASE. I'M SURE IF I COULD JUST
ADD TO THE CENTERS QUESTION
GIVE YOU EITHER GIVE A CLEAR
RESPONSE. MAY I RESPOND AS
MANAGER OF COURSE YES PLEASE.
SO CENTERS HERE LET ME JUST
REPEAT TO YOU FROM SECTION
ELEVEN NINE NINE NINE POINT
THREE THREE I'M NOT GOING TO
TRY TO. GET A TO REALIZE HERE
I'LL JUST READ IT STRAIGHT FROM
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL. IN A
STATEWIDE OPIOID SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MAY RELEASE ANY CLAIM RELATED
TO THE SUBJECT MATTER OF THE
SETTLEMENT. THAT MAY BE BROUGHT
BY A GOVERNMENT ENTITY AGAINST
A SETTLING DEFENDANTS. EXCEPT
THOSE CLAIMS FILED BY A
GOVERNMENT ENTITY BEFORE AUGUST
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY.
AND JUST TO PUT IT MORE
LAYMAN'S TERMS. AS I SAID IF
YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY FILED YOUR
SUIT. THEN WE WILL LIMIT YOUR
ABILITY GOING NOW THAT WE GOT
TO SELL BUT IF YOU LIKE THOSE
CITY. A CITY THAT YOU MENTION
THOSE MAYORS IMAGINE HOW FILE
SUIT. THEY'RE NOT IMPLICATED AB
SIX DOESN'T AFFECT THEM. THEY
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR
LOSS IT'S ALL THE WAY TO CORDON
THROUGH A JURY TRIAL IF THEY
WISH. AB SIXTY DOESN'T STOP AT.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE HOW
AT FIVE HUNDRED JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE ALREADY SUED. KEEP
GOING. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SETTLEMENT.
THEY CAN STRUGGLE ALL THE WAY.
AB SIX SIMPLY SAYS MOVING
FORWARD SO ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO'VE ALREADY FILED THEIR
CLAIMS ARE PROTECTED AND WE
DON'T INTEND TO GET IN THE WAY
IF THEY DON'T WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN SO THEY'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO AND SO IF THERE'S
NO AMBIGUITY HERE. I THAT'S WHY
I DON'T GET WHY SO MANY THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE CONCERNED
EXCEPT THAT THEY'RE HEARING
FROM THEIR ATTORNEYS THAT THEY
SHOULD BE CONCERNED. AND SO I
AM ONE OF THESE I DO INTEND TO
DO AS I CAN TO REACH OUT TO A
BUNCH OF GUYS SUPERVISORS. AND
MAYORS BECAUSE I WE GET INTO
THE TERMS OF THE PAYMENT OF
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND THE TERMS
OF THE POT THAT WOULD
DISTRIBUTED. BECAUSE IN THAT
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FIFTEEN POT.
FIFTEEN JERK ST FIFTEEN TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS 70% FOR
ABATEMENT. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I DETERMINE HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE THE 15% AMONG THE
FIFTY STATES AND FOR THOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE FIFTY
STATES THE STATE AG'S DETERMINE
HOW TO DETERMINE THE 50% PART
AMONGST FIFTY STATES I WOULD
ENCOURAGE EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MAYOR AND COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WHO'S LISTENING TO
BE RIGHT NOW TO ASK. HOW MUCH
ARE THEY GOING TO GET IN
CALIFORNIA OF THAT 15% PORTION
THAT'S ALLOCATED TO ALL THE
CITY AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS IN
THE NATION. AND I CAN TELL YOU
THE ANSWER. AND IT'S GOING TO
BE LESS THAN THEIR
PROPORTIONATE SHARE THEIR WE'RE
GOING TO GET FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN OUT OF THE FIFTY
STATES OUT OF THAT 50% SURE
THAT. OKAY FOR THE STATE'S. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WE WERE
UNWILLING. TO GO WITH ANY
ALLOCATION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT UNDER
REPRESENTED OUR POPULATION. AND
SO WE'RE GETTING MORE THAN 10%
OF ANY POT OF MONEY AND THAT
50% AND THEN THAT 70% ASK THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOW MUCH
THEY'RE GETTING. OUT OF THAT
50% DR I ASKED THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOW MUCH OF THAT 50%
PART. IN THE NATION THAT'S
RESERVE TO THE CITY ACCOUNTS
THEY'RE GETTING. ALMOST TWO
PERCENTAGE POINTS LAST. THAT'S
A DEAL THAT THEIR ATTORNEYS
NEGOTIATED FOR THEM. AND SO I
JUST. FOLKS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS CONCERN HERE ABOUT
THIS BILL NOT BECAUSE IT'S SO-
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND IT'S
HARD NOT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SENSE AT THREE OR FOUR
PARAGRAPHS AND THE WORDS ARE
NOT AMBIGUOUS. BUT THERE IS A
LOT OF GAME GOING ON BUT I GET
IT IS LAST MOMENT I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT WE DID NOT EXPECT THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
QUICKLY TOWARDS A RESOLUTION OF
A GLOBAL DEAL ON ON TRACK I
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE EXPRESSING
ON BEHALF OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU AND-
PRECIADO EXPLANATIONS OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HIGH AFTER
THAT I'VE NEVER HAD NOT SERVED
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M
NOT ATTORNEY AND JUST THE DOCK-
BUT- I ALSO POINT OUT THAT IS A
POSITION THAT I WORK IN THE ER
I TAKE CARE OF PATIENTS FIRST
AND THEN I FIGURE OUT WHETHER
YOU GET PAID OR NOT LATER- AND-
IN THE CLINIC AND I TAKE A
MEDIC CAL WE CAN TALK ABOUT
MEDICAL RATES AND OTHER FACTORS
STILL TAKE CARE OF THEM- SO
LET'S TALK ABOUT TOURNEY'S NOW.
SO FIRST COMMENT FIRST I DO
HAVE A BRIEF COMMENTS ABOUT. I
KNOW THAT SOME MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE- SORTIE-
REGARDING FISHING GAME AND- I
GUESS THE MAIN ISSUE THERE-
WHICH- I. AND I APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION AGES GIVEN ON THAT
IS JUST THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T.
PUT PEOPLE IN DOUBLE TRIPLE
JEOPARDY IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE COME AFTER
THEM SO THAT THEY KNOW
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF RULES
THAT FILE I THINK THAT. PERHAPS
IS THE MAIN PRINCIPLE I
UNDERSTAND WHAT. THE AGS SAID
ABOUT- HIS. NEED FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO BE
ABLE TO ACT- SOMEWHAT
INDEPENDENTLY BUT I THINK
AGAIN- YELLED THERE MAYBE FIFTY
EIGHTY AS BUT THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER THE
STATUS. THE WHOLE STATE SO YOU
PRIMARILY ONLY FACING ONE OR
TWO DAYS OF HIM ACCOUNT
COUNTIES OR JURISDICTIONS OR
BOB THAT BUT- SIDE FROM THAT
JUST ON THE OPIOID SETTLEMENT.
ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
EXPLANATIONS I GUESS THE ONE
QUESTION I DO HAVE. ON. THAT IS
THAT. ON 15% SO YOU TALK ABOUT
SEVENTY PERCENT- FOR- TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND SO FORTH WHICH I
THINK IS GOOD YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO HAVE ACTUALLY MOST OF MONEY
GOES THERE. AN EXISTING PERCENT
FOR THE STATE 15% FOR-
LOCALITIES. CAN YOU PERHAPS
ADDRESS- HOW THAT 15%
LOCALITIES WILL BE DIVVIED UP
AMONG THE LOCALITIES BECAUSE WE
HAVE LOCLITIES THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATED HAVE
SUITS. SOME OF THEM MAY DECIDE
NOT TO BE PART OF SETTLEMENT
CONTINUE ON THEIR SUITS AS YOU
MENTIONED. YOU THEN YOU HAVE
YOUR CALORIES THAT HAVEN'T
WE'RE GONNA FORBID THEM FROM
BEING ABLE TO WEIGH IN IN THE
FUTURE- DO THEY HAVE ANY PIECE
OF THAT HOW'S THAT GOING TO BE
DECIDED AMONGST ALL THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES AND LOCALITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT PORTION THAT
15% THAT GOES TO THEM- HOW'S
THAT GOING TO BE DIVVIED UP-
AND I THINK THAT SOME OF THE-
THINGS THAT COME BACK AS YOU
KNOW PEOPLE SAID WELL WHAT
ABOUT THE MONEY WE VERY PUT IN
TO PURSUE THIS LAWSUIT WILL
TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE READY
FILED SUITS- THAT THE
LOCALITIES- AND DECIDE SO CAN
YOU PERHAPS ADDRESS. THAT ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY. ENTER. PLEASE SIR
GO AHEAD. A SURVEY GREAT
QUESTIONS UP BY THE WAY FIRST.
UNDER THE- ON THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE DIVISION THAT THERE
COULD BE NO DOUBLE JEOPARDY
PLEASE UP LET ME MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S CLEARLY WE YOU CAN GO TO
KEEP GOING AFTER A PARTICULAR-
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WAY SO. YOU
SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THAT- BUT ON THE OPIOIDS DEAL-
ON THE 50% OF FIRST. EVERY
JURISDICTION AS I MENTIONED
THERE WILL BE. BILLIONS IN THE
POT FOR ATTORNEYS FEES AND
COSTS. EVERY JURISDICTION WILL
BE ABLE TO RECOUP A FILE TO
RECOUP ITS ATTORNEYS FEES AND
COSTS EVERY JURISDICTION- AS I
SAID. THERE'S A BILLIONS THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS I WILL TELL YOU
THAT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I
WOULD PUT MORE THAT MONEY INTO
A BASEMENT. WE DIDN'T- YOUR SO
IF I CAN SAY TO YOU M. AND I
MEAN IT. SINCERELY THE STATE
CALIFORNIA PRETTY DEAL BECAUSE
THE RATE THAT WE PAY OUR
ATTORNEYS IS. A FRACTION OF.
WHAT SOME OF THESE FULL
CHARGING LOCAL CAN DO THE SOME
GONNA PUT YOU A LITTLE BIT.
THIRTY APPRECIATE SO I LIKE TO
HEAR A LITTLE MORE ABOUT HOW.
YOU SAID THERE'LL BE PLENTY OF
MONEY IN THE 15% I AGREE WITH
YOU WE CAN PUT MORE OF IT IN
THE BASEMENT THAT'S- WHAT THEY
LIKE TO SEE BUT YOU HAVEN'T
REALLY ANSWERED THE QUESTION
ABOUT SO WHAT PROCESS- WHAT.
MECHANISM DO YOU SEE BEING
EMPLOYED TO DECIDE HOW TO DIVVY
UP THAT 15% THAT GOES TO
LOCALITIES IS IT- EACH LOCALITY
WHO PARTICIPATES IN THE
SETTLEMENT. SINISTER ATTORNEY
FEES AND HE GET ALL OF IT
ASSUMING THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY
FOR THAT WHICH YOU SEEN THE
CRUSADER PROBABLY WILL. IS IT
NOTE THIS THAT THE LOCALITIES
HAVE DECIDED TO NOT BE PART OF
SETTLEMENT AND CONTINUE TO
PURSUE THEIR OWN CASES. VERY
FILE. ID DO THEY GET ANY OF
THIS OR NOT BUT SINCE ARE.
GOING THEIR OWN PATH TODAY.
PLACE THAT HAVE NOT FILED. DO
THEY GET A PORTION OF THAT AT
ALL. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO
BAN THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO
FILE ANYTHING PASSED THE TWENTY
FOURTH OKAY NEED PERHAPS. IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT. WHO'S
GONNA BE AT THE TABLE TO DECIDE
HOW THAT 50% GETS DIVVIED UP.
SO YOU YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO KNOW
THAT. TO PAY ATTORNEYS FEES AND
COSTS YOU ARE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL NOT HAVE TO DO
IT INTO THE 50% POT THAT IT
WILL GET. THERE IS A SEPARATE
POT. A CIVICALLY FOR ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS THAT HAS AND
THAT WILL HAVE NO IMPACT OR
WILL NOT DIP INTO THE FIFTEEN
PERCENT. OKAY 70% OR THE OTHER
50% FOR THE STATE'S. THOSE
157050% POTS WILL ARE
STANDALONE THERE WILL BE A
STANDALONE PRODUCT. CARE PAY
FOR ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS
THAT WILL NOT IMPACT THOSE.
DOLLARS THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR.
EACH IN TERMS OF WHO GETS WHO
CAN DEPEND. IF YOU HAVE FILED A
CLAIM. AND YOU DECIDE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SETTLEMENT
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO CONTINUE
FORWARD WITH YOUR LAWSUIT RIGHT
THEN OBVIOUSLY YOU CANNOT. GET
MONEY FROM THE POT BECAUSE
YOU'VE DECIDED YOU WANT TO GO
YOUR OWN WAY AND- MOVE YOUR
MOVE YOUR LAWSUIT- AND SO YOU
WILL NOT PARTICIPATE. BUT BE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T PARTICIPATE.
YOU REDUCE THE AMOUNT IN THE
POT. THAT EVERY OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND STATE OKAY. YES
THEIR SHARE BECAUSE THE
DEFENDANTS WILL REQUIRE THAT A
RESERVE BE CAPPED. TO COVER
THEIR RISK OF THE LITIGATION
THAT CONTINUES FORWARD BY OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. AND THAT'S WHY
EIGHTY SIX IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO GET
EVERYONE TO COME TO TERMS NOW
WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH THIS
WITH THE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS AT
ISSUE WITH THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
ENSUED. AND SAYING OKAY WE GOT
A DEAL BY THE WAY ALL THESE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT WERE
PART OF THIS FINAL NUMBER THAT
WE'RE COMING TO. IT'S NOT AS IF
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHERE WE WERE
ON THE NUMBER OKAY AND SO FOR
THEM TO SAY WOW YOU'RE GONNA
FOR CLOSE OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
SUE. IT'S VERY DISINGENUOUS
OKAY. PART OF THIS OKAY I'VE-
ALL ALONG AND IT'S ESPECIALLY
HARD FOR ME TO. SWALLOW IF.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO HAVE
ATTORNEYS WHO'VE BEEN PART OF
THIS ARE SAYING WELL WAIT A
MINUTE WE DON'T GET WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO OF COURSE YOU KNOW
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS. THAT
THE DEFENDANTS OUT OF GETTING
CERTAINTY THAT THEY WON'T BE
SUED. AND SO TO GET THAT WE
GOTTA GET CLAIMS RELEASED. BY
ALL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
THE STATE AND THAT'S ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO DO TOO EVEN- SIX AND
WE DON'T LIMIT ANYONE WHO'S
ALREADY SUIT. AND WE ONLY LIMIT
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T SEEN. BY
AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY. IT'S VERY SIMPLE THE
END OF THE PLAN YOU HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION YES THANK
YOU I GET THAT MAIN POINT I WAS
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
MORE SPECIFICS ABOUT THE 15%
APPRECIATE KNOWING THERE'S A
SEPARATE POT TO ADDRESS THE
TOURNEY FEES THAT FOR THOSE WHO
DECIDE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
SETTLEMENT THANK YOU. YEAH AND
BY THE WAY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DECIDE HOW THEY
WILL SPEND THAT 50% THE STATE
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
JUST ASA SPOKE WITH GOVERNMENT
WON'T HELP WON'T BE A HAVE A
VOICE IN HOW THE STATE. USES
ITS 50% THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS ARE. IN
THE CHAMBERS. FOR OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY I DON'T
SEE ANY RAISED HANDS FROM A
REMOTE MEMBERS. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. IN THE
CHAMBERS. MISTER ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO JUST
PROVIDES A VERY BRIEF KIND OF
WRAP UP REMARKS- I APPRECIATE
YOU SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
ASKING ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. BENCHER LISTEN YOU
ALL BEEN GREAT AT ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS WERE SPOT ON
EXPRESSED REAL CONCERN I
APPRECIATE THAT I WISH I COULD
COME TO YOU ALWAYS SOMETHING
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WE WEREN'T
ANYWHERE NEAR THIS SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO AND NOW THAT WE ARE
WE'VE GOT A WE'VE GOT A JUMP IF
WE CAN GET THERE BECAUSE IT'S
TAKING YEARS OF LITIGATION MANY
OF YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE
PRODUCE EDUCATION- THAT'S NOW
STUCK IN BANKRUPTCY COURT- THE
LAST THING WE NEED IS TO HAVE
THESE COMPANIES USE A
BANKRUPTCY COURTS TO TRY TO
KEEP US FROM BEING ABLE TO GET
FARE PAYMENT- AND ROOM.
REIMBURSEMENT. FOR ALL OUR LOW
CALORIES AND SO WE THINK WE
HAVE IN OUR WE WE'RE NOT THERE-
I DON'T WANT TO FOOL YOU INTO
THINKING WHERE THERE WERE NOT
THERE BUT WE'RE GETTING CLOSE
AND WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE BEHIND- IN IN
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
GETS ITS FAIR SHARE SO YOU'VE
BEEN GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU TO ALL THE
CENTERS FOR GIVE ME A CHANCE TO
TRY TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS THE
PRECIADO. THANK YOU SIR ALL
WILL HAVE ALL HAVE STAFF FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU BECAUSE I THINK I'M
JUST HEARING THE 15% IT'S
PROBABLY RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME I
DIDN'T SEE IT BUT HEARING YOU
SAY THE 15% I'LL HAVE STAFF
FALL WITH YOUR STAFF TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW YOU ARRIVED 15%
WHERE THAT NUMBER CAME FROM NOT
NOW WILL FOLLOW UP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR FOR GIVING US
YOUR TIME THIS EVENING- MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING
TO- USE THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR A
BI SIX TO BE TESTIMONY ONLY
TODAY AND SO I'M GLAD THAT THE-
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH HERE WAS
ABLE TO ANSWER ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SIR.
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE ON TO A.
B. EIGHTY SIX- COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND WE WILL HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FIRST
FINANCE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
VICE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COULD AFTER GOOD
EVENING LISA PRESENTS YOU WITH
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WILL BE
PROVIDING YOU WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF AB. EIGHTY SIX
WHICH IS A BUDGET BELT LOOKING
HERE HOWEVER MY COLLEAGUES LIKE
FINANCE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. AND CAN SPEAK IN MORE
DETAIL ON ANY OF THE ISSUES
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL. AB
EIGHTY SIX IS THE SECOND BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR AND CONTAINS
AMENDMENTS TO THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. AS WELL AS
VARIOUS AMENDMENTS AND
ADDITIONS TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. AND THE FIRST
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR BOTH OF
WHICH WERE PASSED IN LATE JUNE.
WELL THE MAJORITY OF THE
MINUTES IN THIS BILL REFLECT
TECHNICAL CLEANUP AND
CONFORMING ADJUSTMENTS. THIS
BILL DOES CONTAIN
APPROPRIATIONS TOTALING OVER
SIX MILLION. DOLLARS AND ALSO
INCLUDES VARIOUS TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WHICH MAY. WHICH
MANY OF WHICH ARE INTENDED TO
ASSIST IN THE STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND IMPACT OF THE CO
THAT NINETEEN. SPECIFICALLY IN
ADDITION TO THE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING ADJUSTMENTS
MENTIONED THIS BILL INCLUDES
THE FOLLOWING SIGNIFICANT
APPROPRIATIONS AN ADJUSTMENT.
IT PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION AN ADDITIONAL
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM FUNDS. WHICH IS
PROVIDED S A LOAN FOM THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUN. AND XCELERATED ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE MILLION OF
ADDITIONAL REGIONAL PLANNING
HOUSING AN INFILL INCENTIVE
ACCOUNT FUNDING. WHICH IS FROM
THE HOUSING AND EMERGENCY
SHELTER TRUST FUND. THIS
FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO
BETTER ALIGN INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM WITH THE NEEDS OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
APPLYING FOR MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAMS. THIS BILL
TRANSFERS ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. THE SMALL
BUSINESS HIRING CREDIT FUND.
WHICH WILL ALSO QUALIFY SMALL
BUSINESSES. TO USE SMALL
BUSINESS. I'M SORRY WHICH WILL
ALLOW. SMALL BUSINESS TO USE
THE SMALL BIT. HIRING CREDIT TO
IT'S TAX LIABILITY.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
FIFTY ONE MILLION ALTERNATIVE
RENEWABLE FUEL VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY FUND TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ADDITIONAL
ELECTRONIC VEHICLE CHARGERS IN
THE STATE. THERE'S A THIRTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR A
PROBE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION IN THIS BILL THE
SECRETARY OF LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO
PROTECT ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND ULTIMATELY
SLOW THE SPREAD OF CODE
NINETEEN TO EMPLOYER EDUCATION
WORKER EDUCATION ENGAGEMENT.
AND ENFORCEMENT. ALSO THE BILL
INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR KOBE NINETEEN
PUBLIC AWARENESS AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH EFFORTS PRIORITIZING
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMIC
SECTORS WHICH HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. ADDITIONALLY THE
SIMPLE THIS BILL INCLUDES
SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FUNDS. TO
SUPPORT THE PRELIMINARY PLANS
AND WORKING DRAW FOR A
COMMUNITY CAP OUT LATE THIS.
AUTHORIZES FORTINO LEFT OVER ON
LEFT BOND NEED TO THE- PAL
SEISMIC RIGHT PROJECT AND
PROVIDES ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDINGS CNSTRUCTION FUND FOR
JUDICIAL COUNCIL GLENN WILLIS
COURTHOUSE RENOVATION AND
ADDITION PROJECT. ALSO INCLUDED
BILL IS APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDED JASMINE'S THE VARIOUS
FEDERAL PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
FINALLY IN AN EFFORT TO AID AND
PROMOTE ECONOMIC STIMULUS THIS
BILL CONTAINS A PACKAGE OF
AMENDMENTS THAT MAKES AVAILABLE
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION IN VARIOUS BOND FUNDS
WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR
ACCELERATION OF SPECIFIC BOND
FUNDED PROJECTS. WITHOUT MY
COLLEAGUES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LMAO. WELL
THAT'S FOR L. L. ONLY HERE IF
WE TECH IF WE NEED THEM RIGHT
IF THERE ARE ANY PARTICULAR
QUESTIONS- TO BE DIRECTED TO
THEM SO WE'LL LEAVE IT THERE
THANK YOU FINANCE ALL OPEN UP
TO THE FLOOR FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. AGAIN ON BUDGET
ACTIVE. TWENTY ANY OF OUR
REMOTE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
SENATOR MORE LAW. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST AT A
QUESTION ABOUT THE
NONCOMPLIANCE PROVISION FOR
CALORIES AB COULD YOU EXPLAIN
THAT A LITTLE BIT. FINANCE.
SENATOR MORE LOCK AT THIS ADAM
DORSEY DEPARTMENT FINANCE I'M
ASSUMING- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT ITEM- IN
THE REDIRECTION OF REALIGNMENT
FUNDS FOR COUNTIES THAT I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO BE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS CORRECT THANK YOU MISTER
DORSEY FOR SPELLING IT OUT REAL
NICELY YEAH SO THE IDEA HERE IS
THAT- THIS IS GOING TO ENABLE
US TO PROVIDE AT FUNDS UP FRONT
TO COUNTIES AND SO- WE'RE GONNA
PROVIDE A LUMP SUM FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR FOR- THE
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACT
IN JUNE- FOR COUNTIES THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO SORT OF BACK FEELS
LOST REVENUE THAT WAS
PROJECTED- AT THAT TIME AND-
WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE THAT MONEY
IN A LUMP SUM. TO COUNTIES AND-
AND BASICALLY THIS PROVISION
ALLOWS FOR THAT AND THEN IF
THERE ARE COUNTIES THAT ARE ARE
NOT COMPLYING WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE- THERE'S A
MECHANISM THEN TO RE DIRECT
REALIGNMENT FUNDS- IT FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY AND THAT'S
THAT'S THE BASIC PRINCIPLE AND
THE RATIONALE BHIND THE
PROPOSAL SO MAYBE THERE PUT IT
IN MORE STARKER. TERMS IS SORT
OF A STICK. IT'S IT IF THEY CAN
ISN'T COMPLY OR- MISS IT'S
MISSING THE MARK YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO WITHHOLD FUNDS. WHAT
ARE THEY ARE THEY BEING ASKED
TO REIMBURSE THOSE. THAT'S
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT AN UNFAIR I
MEAN THERE THERE'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT CARROT- IF YOU WILL
AND IN THAT- YOU KNOW WE'RE
FRONTING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
DID TO COUNTIES IN YOU KNOW IN
A LUMP SUM- WHICH IS UNUSUAL
AND SO IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CARROTS AND THEN- YEAH THERE'S
SORT OF A PROCEED DEVELOPED- ON
THE BACKSIDE TO SAY. THE PART
OF THE DEAL FOR THAT YOU KNOW
FOR THOSE FUNDS IS THAT- YOU'RE
GONNA COMPLY PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE SO. IT'S SORT OF LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE SAYS A
CERTAIN STATES WILL GET FUNDING
IF THEY DO SOMETHING. SO WE'RE
KIND OF FOLLOWING THAT TREND
IT'S- APPROACH. SORT OF. THANK
YOU MANAGER. YEAR WELCOME
SENATOR MORLOCK. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT SEEN NONE WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE OH SEVEN
GENERAL GOVERNMENT. FINANCE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- CHRIS COOK WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. YES GO
AHEAD. ARE YOU GOING TO
PRESENT. ON THI. AB ONE OH
SEVEN. THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL MAKES VARIOUS
CHANGES AND CLEAN UP THE JANET
DOES A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
OUTLINING THOSE CHANGES SO I'LL
JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THOSE
NOTABLE ITEMS AB ONE OH SEVEN
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT TAX ABOUT
YOUR ACT WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE TREASURE
AND FINANCE TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR A
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT
TAX VOUCHER PROGRAM- IT
CLARIFIES THAT THE EMPLOYER WHO
EMPLOYS MIGRANT FARM WORKERS
CANNOT SELL RENT OR SUBLEASE
THE HOUSING THAT IS SUBSIDIZED
BY THE STATE. AND CLARIFIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IS
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
INSPECTION OF THOSE HOMES THAT
ARE NOT SUBSIDIZED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. IT PROVIDES
AUTHORITY FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO SHARE INCOME DATA FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. AT ITS FEDERAL
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS AND THE
AUTHORITY TO EXCHANGE DATA WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS IN THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AND FOR HOUSEHOLDS WHO
HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED FEDERAL
STIMULUS CHECKS FROM THE CARES
ACT. AB ONE SEVEN ALSO PROVIDES
AN EXTENSION FOR COUNTY
ASSESSORS TO CONDUCT PROPERTY
TAX APPEAL HEARINGS. AND
CLARIFIES THAT REMOTE HEARINGS
CAN BE USED FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
AND FINALLY ROUTE REQUIRES THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
THEIR THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
BEGINNING SEPTEMBER FOURTH.
UNTIL JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO MAKE SPECIFIED
INFORMATION RELATED TO
UNEMPLOYMENT PROGRAM. THE
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM AVAILABLE ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE. WITH
THAT I'M JOIN REMOTELY- BY MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WHO ARE AVAILABLE TO
SPEAK IN FURTHER DETAIL OR
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS. A THIRTY
DORADO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ARE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF OFF FOR
THEIR ORK THIS PAST YEAR ON
THE ENFORCEMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE TO ENSURE QUALITY
FARM WORKER HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA I HAVE A RAISE THIS
ISSUE MULTIPLE TIMES AND IN
MANY WAYS- TO MAKE SURE THAT-
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN HERE. UP TO REALLY
PUSH FOR PEACE AND FARMWORKER
HOUSING FOR FARMWORKERS- MANY
OF OUR FARMWORKERS SISTERS AND
BROTHERS FACE HIGH RENTS AT THE
SAME TIME FOR VERY UNSAFE AND
INADEQUATE LIVING THIS IS BEEN
A BATTLE IN THE FIELDS FOR MANY
YEARS DATING BACK TO THE
BATTLES OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION- AGAINST
PESTICIDES FOR HUMANE HOUSING-
AND HAVING LIVED THROUGH ALL OF
THAT AND NOT HAVING HAD HOUSING
MYSELF FOR OUR FAMILY THIS IS
VERY- IMPORTANT TO ME
PERSONALLY. UP TODAY TENCENT
OVERCROWDED BUNK HOUSES ARE
STILL CONSIDERED BY SOME AS
BEING ADEQUATE FARMWORKER
HOUSING BUT I THINK ALL OF US
BELIEVE THAT WORKERS DESERVE
DIGNIFIED HOUSING NOT JUST TO
BE CROWDED UP. CURRENTLY H. A
EMPLOYERS ARE OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE HOUSING TO WORKERS IN
THAT FEDERAL PROGRAM.
INDIVIDUALS IN THAT PROGRAM
SOMETIMES EXPERIENCED WAGE
THEFT HUMAN TRAFFICKING FORCED
LABOUR. AND ABUSES OF H. TWO A.
WORKERS HAVE INTENSIFIED
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CRISIS.
BUT WE MUST BE DILIGENT TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE DOLLARS
ARE NOT USED TO SUBSIDIZE
HOUSING FOR H. TWO A. WORKERS.
THOSE WORKERS DESERVE THE
HOUSING BUT THAT'S THE
EXCLUSIVE DUTY AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE EMPLOYERS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE H. TWO
A. PROGRAM. SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THOSE FEW WORDS BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO KEEP POPPING UP HERE
OR THERE AND I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE WERE. CONTINUE TO BE
VIGILANT OVER HOW OUR STATE
DOLLARS ARE SPENT THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE- TAX VOUCHER
ACT HAS ME VERY CURIOUS. WHEN
YOU HAVE SOMEONE PREPAY TAXES
THAT SAID DEBORAH TO CASH
CREDIT TO LIABILITY. AND THAT'S
A DEAD END SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
IF WE'RE CREATING A DAD WITH
THIS. SCHEME WOULD REQUIRE THAT
A GO BEFORE THE VOTERS IN A
BALLOT MEASURE IN. SHOULDN'T
THAT BE APPROVED BY A TWO
THIRDS VOTE- IF YOU'RE
BORROWING AND I'M I'M JUST
CURIOUS IF THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN RESEARCHED AS- THIS THIS
DISCUSSION HAS STARTED. FINANCE.
RISCO CLICK FINANCE- I BELIEVE
MY COLLEAGUE J. CHAMBERLAIN IS
ON THE LINE- ARE YOU SENATORS
QUESTION. YES GOOD EVENING ST
TERM DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO-
THIS WAS THIS IS ACTUALLY A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL. AND I
DON'T I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHETHER
WITH THE TWO THIRDS. VOTE A
TEST HAS BEEN HAS BEEN LOOKING
TO. MISTER CHAIRMAN WHAT HAVE
YOU DONE ANY RESEARCH ON THIS
TRIP LIKE I DO WE HAVE ANOTHER
STATE THAT'S ALREADY DONE THIS.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY OF THE
STATE'S DONE THIS. OKAY SO
WHERE WHAT WHAT WHERE WOULD ONE
GO TO. TOOL RESEARCHERS SHOULD
WE JUST WAIT FOR LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL TO FLUSH IT OUT FOR US
AND LET ME CHECK IN WITH L. A.
O. ALSO- SEARCH MORE LIKE TO
SEE IF THERE'S SOMEONE THERE
WHO MAY HAVE A RESPONSE ALEJO.
HI THIS GOOD EVENING THIS IS
CAROLINE CHIU FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- CENTER ROCK
WE HAVE NOT OUR RESEARCH THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION YOU'RE ASKING
IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT- THE
TEXT FILE TO PROPOSAL WOULD
CONSTITUTE DEBT HOWEVER- THE
PER. DAY PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL- ACTUALLY ARE. WOULD BE
FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
CONSULT CONSULTATION WITH THE
TREASURER AND- THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE TO. BRING FORWARD A
PROPOSAL TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR. I TAX FEDERAL PROGRAM AS
YOU OUTLINED- BY THE SPRING OF
NEXT YEAR SO I DO ANTICIPATE
THAT THIS WOULD BE. A QUESTION
THAT. I THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
WOULD FLUSH OUT ININ ITS WORK
ON DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL AND
I THINK IT IS IT IS ONE WHERE.
THEY THEY LIKELY WOULD NEED TO
THINK ABOUT- ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSTRAINTS- SUCH A- AT.
MECHANISM WOULD CREATE. A YOU
SEE HOW HOW IT WOULD RELATE TO
ALL THE OTHER BONDS AND-
TENSION AN OPEB. LIABILITIES WE
HAVE IN IN THE ENTIRE SCHEME
IS- RUTH YESTERDAY IN ANOTHER.
SETTING THAT BOY WE ARE WE ARE
LOOKING AT ADDING SO MUCH DEBT
SO FAST. AND TO THE BALANCE
SHEET AND WE ALREADY HAVE ONE
OF THE LARGEST AND- RESTRICTED
NET DEFICITS IN IN THE NATION
AND IF- MISTER RESPONSE ON
WE'RE HERE I'D ASK HIM WHERE'S
OUR COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT YOU ARE HERE
IT'S ALMOST IN A SESSION WE
STILL HAVEN'T RECEIVED IT THE
ONLY STATE. THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN IN SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ADDING DEBT IT
WOULD BE NICE TO SEE WHERE
BALLOT SHE LOOKS LIKE. THANK
YOU MANAGER. AND ANSWER MORE
LIKE I JUST WANT ALSO REITERATE
AS I. TOOK ANOTHER LOOK AT MY
NOW OFFICE THIS ALSO THE POINT
OF THE TRAILER BILL IS TO. SET
UP THE PLANT NOT THE PROGRAM
ITSELF BUT I THINK THE
EXPECTATION IS TO THIS PLAN
SOME OF THE RESEARCH. AND
CLARIFICATION YOU'RE SEEKING
SHOULD BE IDENTIFIED THROUGH
THE PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MANAGER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL SENATOR
NIELSEN. PART OF THE FINANCE
THE NEPA EXTENSION THE THIRTY
HERE- SEEMS LIKE A- AREAS
TIMING. SEEMS LIKE MORE OF A-
POLICY ISSUE THAN A BUDGET
ISSUE AND I'M GONNA RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SINGLE
SUBJECT ISSUE AS WELL AN
APPROPRIATE POINT IN THE FUTURE.
BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD BE THE
REASON FOR THIS NEPA PROVISION
IN HERE SPECIFICALLY. AND AGAIN
WHAT IS THE URGENCY OF
ACCOMPLISHING THIS IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS. YES THIS IS
MARTIN WROTE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND SO WE NEED TO
DELEGATION CAN HAVE A LONG
HISTORY- WITH THE STATE WHERE
THE- BECAUSE THE STATE HAS THE
STATE'S SEQUEL PROCESS IS SO
ROBUST- THERE'S A LOT OF
DUPLICATION AND WE THE STATE
ITSELF DOES MORE THAN IS
REQUIRED FOR. FOR THE NEED TO
WORK SO- THIS IS BEN- THE NORM
AND FOR- PROBABLY PROJECTS FOR
AT LEAST THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
OR MORE- AND SO IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MADE THIS. AN OPTION
FOR- TRANSIT PROJECTS- A FEW
YEARS AGO AND SO THIS WAS FIRST
PUT INTO A LEGISLATION THAT LED
TO THE INITIAL AUTHORITY IN
STATUTE FOR THIS. EXPIRES
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SO. THIS IS REALLY JUST A AN
EXTRA A WIN YEAR EXTENSION. OF
THAT- TO- TO CONTINUE ALLOWING
A LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCIES AND-
BASICALLY ANYBODY DOING TRANSIT
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT. ACHIEVE
THAT BENEFIT WHEN WE DO THE-
WHEN WE DO THE DELEGATED ME TO
WORK. WE SAVE MONTHS- IF NOT
YEAR SOMETIMES ON PROJECTS AND-
RESULTING IN PROJECTS SAVINGS
SO IT'S JUST IT'S A VERY GOOD
POLICY. THIRTY NIELSEN WELL FOR
FIRST OF ALL YOU DIDN'T EXPLAIN
THE URGENCY AND I'M WONDERING
IF THIS DOESN'T HAVE SOME
APPLICATION TO THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL ISSUE. BECAUSE THERE'S A-
THE END OF THE LINE HANGING OUT
THERE LOOMING OUT THERE AND
THAT COULD BE OF SOME
APPLICATION IN THIS. AND AGAIN
WHY JUST AT THE END OF THE
SESSION KIND OF A RUSH TO DEAL.
COULD NOT THIS BEEN DEALT WITH
OVER A MUCH LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME AND PREPARATION. YES I
MEAN THE REASON FOR THE REASON
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE DONE NOW-
IS AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THAT
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DEADLINE. AND SO- BURKE THE
EXPIRATION OF OUR THIRTY TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT- THERE YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST BUDGET COULD
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IT BURIES
POINTS IN THE PAST BUT WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE EXTENSION
NOW- AS STUDENTS SO THAT. SO
THE LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCIES AS
WELL AS ANY- STATE PROJECTS.
CAN CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE THE
SAVINGS. AB FURTHER QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTION FOR MY REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS SEEN NONE CALLING
FROM GONNA- TAKE US TO THE NEXT
BILL A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR
BUT I'M GOING TO SUGGEST WE
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE FOR DINNER-
FOR MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS DINNER HAS ARRIVED WE
ALSO NEED TO GIVE OUR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT FOLKS A BRIEF BREAK
THEY HAD BEEN WORKING STRAIGHT
THROUGH WHAT THE COMMITTEES
THAT WERE GOING THROUGH- AFTER
FLOOR SESSION ON THE- ALBUM I'M
GOING TO SUGGEST MAYBE TWENTY
MINUTES- IT BUT WE WANT TO TAKE
A BREAK BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND IT MIGHT RUN QUITE.
A BIT OF TIME OKAY SO HOW ABOUT
WE- HERE THE PRESENTATION FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR DEPARTMENT.
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. GOOD EVENING MADAM
START YES GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
SENATOR SO IT IS EVEN NOW I WAS
ABOUT TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M I'M KIMBERLY HARBISON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US. TO DISCUSS THIS
PROPOSAL WITH YOU AGAIN TODAY.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR THEIR
TIME AND FEEDBACK AS THEY'VE
WORKED WITH US TO REFINE AND
IMPROVE THIS PROVOKED PROPOSAL
OVER MANY MONTHS THIS YEAR.
INCLUDING RESOLUTION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
COMPONENTS. WELL THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES CHANGING THE NAME OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. IT IS NOT
REORGANIZING THE DEPARTMENT OR
CREATING A NEW ONE. RATHER IT
IS ENHANCING EXISTING
REGULATORY FUNCTIONS. AND
APPLYING A NAME THAT IS MORE
DESCRIPTIVE OTHER FUNCTION AND
MORE EASILY UNDERSTOOD BY
CONSUMERS AND OTHERS. THE
CENTRAL PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
UNLAWFUL UNFAIR DECEPTIVE OR
ABUSIVE ACTS ORPRACTICES. AND
EXPAND THE DEPARTMENT'S
JURISDICTION TO COVER CURRENTLY
UNLICENSED PERSONS. THAT OFFER
OR PROVIDE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES RESOURCES FOR RESEARCH
GREATER COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH AND OMBUDSPERSON
FUNCTION AND INNOVATION
TECHNOLOGY OFFICE. FOCUSED ON
EMERGING AND CHANGING FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES IN THE
MARKETPLACE. THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT INCLUDES FUNDING IN
A SET ASIDE ITEM THAT IS NOT
YET AVAILABLE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT. IT IS
CONTINGENT UPON THE
LEGISLATURE'S APPROVAL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE OF THIS
BILL WITH SUBSEQUENT
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT-
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THE COST OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
LAW PROGRAM WILL BE FUNDED BY
NEW COVERED PERSON REGISTRATION
FEES. EXISTING IT HUMILIATED
SETTLEMENT REVENUES AND
EVENTUALLY. YOU SETTLEMENT
REVENUES EXISTING LICENSEES ARE
NOT EXPECTED TO PAY ANY OF THE
COST OF THIS PROGRAM. THIS BILL
OUTLINES HOW DEPARTMENTS
EXPANDED OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
WILL FUNCTION CURRENTLY
DANIELLE'S REGULATION IS BASED
IN LICENSING STATUS. WHEN A
CONSUMER HAS A COMPLAINT THE
FIRST QUESTION IS WHETHER THAT
BUSINESS HAS A LICENSE OR IF
THEY SHOULD HAVE A LICENSE. IF
THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL BUSINESS
DOES NOT FALL WITHIN A
PRESCRIPTIVE JUST DEFINITION IN
STATUTE. DVR DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OR ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY OVER THAT AND STATE
AND CANNOT TAKE ACTION EVEN IF
CONSUMERS ARE BEING HARMED.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AUTHORITY
FOR THE COMMISSIONER TO REQUIRE
CURRENTLY UNLICENSED FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES TO
REGISTER WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
EXAMPLES OF THESE CURRENTLY
UNLICENSED PRODUCTS INCLUDE
CREDIT REPAIR AGENCIES THAT
COLLECTORS AND INCOME SHARE
AGREEMENTS. THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE ABLE TO SUPERVISE THESE NEW
COVERED PERSONS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH CONSUMER LAWS.
IT WILL BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
THESE LAWS AND LEARN
INFORMATION ABOUT CURRENTLY
UNREGULATED. AND EMERGENCY AN
EMERGENCY NEW EMERGING NEW
INDUSTRY STANDARD REGISTRATION.
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE GAINED TO
REGISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ON WHETHER TO CREATE
AND HOW BEST TO STRUCTURE NEW
LICENSING PROGRAMS. WE KNOW
THAT IN DIFFICULT ECONOMIC
TIMES SUCH AS THE ONE WE ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING BAD
ACTORS OFTEN PREY ON THOSE IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS. THOSE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
INCLUDE PEOPLE OF COLOR NEW
CALIFORNIANS LOWS IN UNDER
RESOURCED COMMUNITIES STUDENTS
AND SENIORS. I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ
HAS TESTIFIED IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS THIS MONTH. BUT SINCE
THE ONSET OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THIS SPRING DVO HAS
RECEIVED A 40% INCREASE IN
CALLS AND COMPLAINS AND THOSE
ARE JUST THE CONSUMERS. WHO
FIGURED OUT HOW TO FIND THEM OF
THE TOTAL INCREASES PROBABLY
HIGHER. YEAH CHIEF DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER CHRIS SCHULTZ IS
HERE WITH US TODAY AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. I THANK
YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS HARBISON MEMBERS ANY
QUESTION THIRTY NIELSEN. THANK
YOU ABOUT A PRESIDENT OF. TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'M
ALWAYS WARY OF THE CREATION OF
NEW ENTITIES. AND I QUESTION
WHETHER THIS IS APPROPRIATE
INCLUSION IN A- BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. WE HAVE A HISTORY HERE OF
CREATING NEW AGENCIES THAT
DON'T SOLVE PROBLEMS. THE
OFFICE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY WHICH SINGULAR
GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENT OVER
THE YEARS HAS BEEN TO RENAME
ITSELF ABOUT TWO OR THREE TIMES.
BUT I HAVE NOT. STE ANY FEWER
LECH'S IF YOU WILL HONOR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EXPENDED.
THROUGH THIS HI TECH
APPLICATION. IN STATE
GOVERNMENT WE CONTINUE EVEN
RIGHT NOW. TO HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH IT. IT APPEARS MORE TO ME
THAT YOU PICKED A MORE
CONTEMPORARY ISSUE TOO LAFFONT
TO GAIN CEDIT FOR CREATING
THIS. ENTITY THAT'S GOING TO.
TAKE CARE OF ALL THE PROBLEMS.
AND BE THE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CONSUMERS I GATHER. BUT WHAT
WHAT IT IS AGAIN THE URGENCY OF
THIS AND WHY IS IT BEING
PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET.
SENATOR NELSON THANK IF YOUR
QUESTION WE PROPOSE THIS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
AND- IT IS SORT OF AT THE END
OF THE ENTIRE SPRING PROCESS
THAT WE NORMALLY GO THROUGH
WITH YOU. WE DON'T SEE THIS AS
A NEW DEPARTMENT OR EVERY-
RECONSTRUCTION IT'S- WORRY
ENHANCING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT. CAN DO
WERE AIMING TO GET. THOSE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THAT FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS RIGHT NOW SO
IT THERE I CAN TO WHAT DVO DOES
BUT THEY'RE JUST OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDARIES OF WHAT THEY CAN
ENFORCE. SO THIS IS JUST MERELY
ENHANCING WHAT THEY ALREADY DO
IT'S GIVING IT A MORE
DESCRIPTIVE NAME THAT I THINK
IT WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FOLKS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
EXACTLY THEY DO FOR PEOPLE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BECAUSE WE DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE
BEFORE US SENATOR PAN. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I DO WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL- PRECEDED
MINISTRATION ADDRESSING THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE BROUGHT UP AT
A PREVIOUS HEARING AND MAKING
MODIFICATIONS. I'M CERTAINLY
INTERESTED IN HEARING WHAT SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS WILL SAME
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
THE SECTOR MANY. ADJUSTMENTS
AND MODIFICATIONS MADE IN
RESPONSE TO OUR QUESTIONS. I
THINK WHAT ONE OF THINGS THAT'S
HELPFUL IS. WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
US SAID THE CLARITY WHICH I DID
ASK AT THE PREVIOUS HEARING
ABOUT- WHO HAS TO REGISTER AND
STANDARD THERE'S NOW A- MORE
CLARIFIED THRESHOLD SO THAT
WE'RE- TRULY TRYING TO CAPTURE
THOSE WHO ARE. MORE INVOLVED
IN. COMMERCIAL SERVICES- AS I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S PERHAPS SOME
ISSUE ROUND DEBT COLLECTORS
RELATED TO- HELP WHERE THEY ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF POTENTIALLY
BEING LICENSED AND HOW THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN IF YOU HAVE A
GROUP THAT'S- GOING TO BE
LICENSE SHORTLY. DO THEY FALL
OUT ONCE LICENSE KICKS AND- SO
THERE'S A FEW ISSUES ARE
OUTSTANDING DIED. HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN- AND- THAT MIGHT WILL BE
ADDRESSED- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE QUESTIONS QUESTIONS FROM
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS MEMBERS.
CENA COLLEAGUES IT'S SIX FORTY
ONE I'M GONNA SUGGEST THAT WE
TRY OUR BEST TO RETURN BY SEVEN
TEN WITH AN EXPECTATION THAT I
WILL GAVEL DOWN AT SEVEN
FIFTEEN FAIR ENOUGH. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TAKE A BRIEF DINNER
RECESS. THOSE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WILL BE BACK AT SEVEN
TEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL WE
WILL RESUME PROCEEDINGS- WE
WILL NOW HEAR AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE EDUCATION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JESSICA HOME TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- AT THE TWENTY EIGHT
SB EIGHT TWENTY MAKES CHANGES
TO THE TWENTY TWENTY EDUCATION
ON THE TRAILER BILL THEY'RE
BOTH TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
IN NATURE- PACIFIC WE FOR EARLY
EDUCATION CHILD CARE AND K.
TWELVE EDUCATION. EVEN COULD
AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOW FOR
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING BASED ON
PLANT GROWTH IN EIGHTY EIGHT-
CLARIFY ALLOWABLE USES AND
EXTEND THE EXPENDITURES GOING
OFF MEDICATION PLANS INCREASE
FUNDING FOR REIMBURSEMENT
POLITICIAN PROGRAM TO BETTER
TRACK IN THE END. AFTER THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR
INCREASED IN THE OF PAGE NOT ON
DAYS FOR CHILD PROVIDERS THAT
ACCEPT STATE DOCTORS AND
ELIMINATE FAMILY SPEAKER
FAMILIES INVOLVED IN THE
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE PROGRAM
BUT NOT RECEIVING IN PERSON
CARE DUE TO CO THAT NINETEEN.
AND PROVIDE GREATER DETAIL ON
THE MISSION AND COMPETITION AND
YOUNG PEOPLE TASK FORCE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE NUMBERS HOW I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER NOW TO MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS FERGUSON TO
COVER. THE ISSUE BETTER IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY CHRIS FERGUS OF THE
REPORT OF MINING ON THE AB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ALSO INCLUDES
SEVERAL TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS RELATIVE HIGHER
EDUCATION- IT DEMANDS THE
SCHOLAR SHARE KIDS INVESTMENT
IN DEVELOPMENT SAVINGS PROGRAM
TO REQUIRE- WHEN POSSIBLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
SUBMIT SPECIFIED INFORMATION IT
ADDS THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AS
A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- IT EXTENDS
THE DEADLINE FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP ITS
NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT
OF POLICY CHU I JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- IT
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DO YOU
SAVINGS. I'M FROM THE
RETIREMENT A RESTRUCTURING OF
CERTAIN BOND DEBT TO USE THOSE
SAVINGS TO AVOID EMPLOYEE
LAYOFFS YOUR SUPPORT AND
REPRESENT AND STUDENTS ACCESS
AND SUCCESS AT THE UNIVERSITY
FOR BOTH THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEARS- AND IT ALSO
ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY TO- ACCEPT ELECTRONIC
DOCUMENTS- FROM DEPARTMENT
STORES TODAY I'M IN MANY
INSTANCES THOSE DOCUMENTS WOULD
HAVE TO BE. SUBMITTED IN A
PHYSICAL COPY. BUT THE LAST
PROBABLY COMPONENT IN HIGH
RIDGE IS THERE ARE PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL OF RELATIVE TO
UC'S CAPITAL OUTLAY PROCESS OF
REQUIRING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. CHIU SUBMIT CERTAIN
CERTIFICATIONS- AS A
REQUIREMENT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO. APPROVE SOME OF
THEIR CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT IN A POSITION TO SUPPORT
THAT LANGUAGE BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS IN THE BILL AND IT
IT WILL BE MOVING FORWARD. AND
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE EDUCATION
FINANCE. FURTHERMORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MANAGER I'M JUST
CURIOUS. MISTER FERGUSON OF THE
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
HOW MANY ARE GROWING. I WOULD
PREFER THAT TO MY COLLEAGUE.
JESSICA. FOR BY EDITOR MOORLACH
AND JESSICA HOME THEY COVER THE
K. TWELVE AREA FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I CAN'T
PROVIDE YOU WITH AN EXACT
NUMBER OF HOW MANY ARE GOING AT
THIS MOMENT WE ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE GREAT DATA ON THAT-
BECAUSE OF CODE NINETEEN THAT
HAS CREATED FROM PROBABLY
ANTICIPATE TO BE ADDITIONAL
MOVEMENT OF FAMILY- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- HOWEVER GENERALLY
SPEAKING THE MAJORITY OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE IN A
DECLINING ENROLLMENT ADDITION
AND STATEWIDE. ON ABA HAD BEEN
DECLINING. YEAR OVER YEAR FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW. THANK YOU
MISS HOMES I'M- I JUST CURIOUS
BECAUSE- OF THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE THAT HAVE CONTACTED US.
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR SCHOOLS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GROWING IN
ENROLLMENT BUT WE'RE- WE'RE
CAPPING THAT. IN THE END I'M
I'M STILL SORT OF AT A LOSS AS
TO. WHY WE'RE NOT ALLOWING
GROWING SCHOOLS. IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. HE SAID EXCELLENT
QUESTION- AND ONE THAT REALLY
HAD A LOT OF FISCAL DRIVERS
BEHIND IT- THERE'S QUITE A BIT
THAT WE DON'T KNOW RIGHT NOW
ABOUT HOW FAMILIES ARE REACTING
TO EDUCATIONALLY REACTING TO
COPE IT NINETEEN INCH AND THE
REQUIREMENT- THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE- TO HELP
PROTECT CHILDREN AND STAFF AT
SCHOOL- BUT WE DO HAVE. FROM
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION THAT
INDICATES THAT THERE COULD BE
QUITE A BIT OF MOVEMENT-
STATEWIDE- BETWEEN. DIFFERENT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. AT
THE PHYSICAL AND OF BAD DURING
THIS YEAR- IS THAT BECAUSE
WE'RE HOLDING- ALL LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES HARMLESS.
BUT BASICALLY WE ARE ENSURING
THAT IF THEY HAVE A DROP IN
ATTENDANCE. ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THAT THEY WILL
STILL RECEIVE- APPORTIONMENT
FUNDING BASED ON THEIR NINETEEN
TWENTY AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
EIGHTY EIGHT IF THERE IS
MOVEMENT. AMONG STUDENTS
BETWEEN ALLEY EIGHT. THAT WILL
CREATE SIGNIFICANT GROWTH ON
TOP OF THAT HOLD HARMLESS AND
BECAUSE WE ARE IN A POSITION
RIGHT NOW- AND HAVING ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR TECH WORLD FOR
OUR SCHOOLS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH IS JUST AS A
REMINDER- THAT WITH THE MAXIMUM
AND DEFERRAL AMOUNT THAT WE HAD
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION AND
THE ACTUALLY BUILT UP OVER
SEVERAL YEARS THAT WE'RE GOING
STRAIGHT T THAT AMOUNT. ON
ANYTHING HERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL COST OF
MOVEMENT- BETWEEN SCHOOL AND
THAT IT COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
DUE TO COOK AT NINETEEN AND
THEN CREATE THE NEED FOR
SIGNIFICANT INCREASED MOST
VIOLENT. THANK YOU MISS HOME I
CAN TELL YOU ANECDOTALLY THAT
MOTHERS. ARE THAT I HAVE
ENCOUNTERED HAVE BEEN IN TWO
YEARS. ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. ABOUT THEIR- KIDS KIDS
EDUCATION. AND HOW ARE THEY
GONNA DO THEIR JOBS AND SO IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT AND SO WHEN WE
FOR CLOSE ON. ALLOWING CERTAIN
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO GROW A
LITTLE BIT AS AN OPTION FOR OUR
PARENTS BUT IT JUST THE IS
COMES OFF AS VERY INSENSITIVE.
AND SO I JUST PASS THAT ALONG
BASED ON MANY OF THE ENCOUNTERS
I'VE HAD. DEALING WITH
CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER MORALE.
YES THANK YOU. MA'AM HELLO
RIGHT NOW THIS BILL STILL
EXCLUDES AS MY FRIEND- THE
CENTER FROM ORANGE COUNTY IS
THAT EXCLUDES NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND SELF
I WANT TO MOVE TO A MAN A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE AND THE
STRIKE SECTION FOUR THREE FIVE
ZERO FIVE C. ONE. SO THOSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN BE INCLUDED
IN THE FUNDING SIMILAR OTHER
SCHOOLS- THIS BODY OF
LEGISLATORS SHOULD NOT BE
PROMOTING A POLICY THAT SHOWS
FAVORITISM- WHAT IT SHOULD BE
ONE THAT PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
THE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES. WHO
CHOOSE THE SCHOOLS AND SO I
URGE THE REJECTION OF THIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND ASK YOU
TO PLEASE- ADOPT THE MOTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ARE SENATOR DOLLY. EIGHT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. SO I WANT TO
DISTURB I THINK THIS IS FOR-
MISS HOLMES- PERSONAL APOLOGIZE
ARE YOU WE GOT THE STUFF NOT
TOO LONG AGO AND IT'S- SO IT'S-VERY- LITTLE BIT BAY GONE-
DETAIL AT LEAST ON WHAT I'M
PROVIDED WITH SO- BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE FACED WITH
A- WITH EDUCATION IN MY
DISTRICT IS. VERY ROLE AND- SO
I HAVE ELEVEN COUNTY SO I
REPRESENT THE NORTHEASTERN PART
OF THE STATE. AND SOME OF OUR
ABILITY TO DISTANCE LEARNERS
JUST NOT AVAILABLE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR- BROADBAND OR HOT SPOTS OR
ANY OF THOSE TYPES OF. DISTANCE
LEARNING AND WE'VE SEEN YOU
KNOW. A DIFFICULT BUT WE DO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BECAUSE
WHICH YOU STATED EARLIER ABOUT
THE DROP IN ENROLLMENT WE HAVE
PLENTY OF SPACE IN OUR SCHOOLS
WE HAVE THE ABILITY BILL
ACTUALLY. BRING OUR CHILDREN TO
OUR SCHOOLS AND TEACH THEM
THERE BUT THE ONE THING THAT
SETS GUINNESS STIFLE FOR SCHOOL
BOARDS IS THAT OF THE LIABILITY
AND SO THERE WAS SOME
LEGISLATIONPREVIOUSLY THAT WAS
AVAILABLE- THEY DIDN'T COME TO
FRUITION AND I WAS WONDERING IF
THERE'S ANYTHING IN THIS. IN
THIS TRAILER BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THAT- A LIABILITY ISSUE THAT IS
LOOMING AND HOLDING OUR SCHOOL
BOARDS- IT KIND OF THE IT I
GUESS STATE THEY'RE FEARFUL
THAT THEY'RE GONNA GET SUED IF
SOME TEACHER HAS A CODE OR
CHOPPED CHILD BRINGS COBIT IN-
THAT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
WE CAN ACTUALLY BRING THESE
KIDS TO OUR SCHOOLS AND- THE
TEACHER WHERE THEY CAN'T GET
UP. THE SERVICE IS ANY OTHER
WAY. BECAUSE THERE'S NO
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE FOR
THEM. YES AND SENATOR DOLLY WE
HAD HEARD- ABOUT THOSE CONCERNS
AS WELL- I DON'T BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS- A
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT YOUR
YOUR- REFER. BUT THAT DOES
HELP. ON EDUCATION COMMITTEE-
BUT- I BUT I CAN TELL YOU WITH
THAT. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD LIMIT THE LIABILITY-
FOR EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
CHECKUP AT NINETEEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT I
JUST WANT ALSO- MENTION THE
FACT THAT. THE SAME THING MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES IMAGINE IS IT
THERE YOU KNOW THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN DOING
DISTANCE LEARNING AND THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS FOR MANY YEARS
AND THEY'RE VERY. PROFESSIONAL
VERY WELL AND- I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BUILD
TRANSFER MANY MANY MANY. I
WOULD SAY IN THOUSANDS OF. MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO
GET THEIR CHILDREN- EDUCATED
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE TO THAT
PLATFORM BUT DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCING STRUCTURE AND IN THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION SO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INPUT AND FOR MY
COLLEGE AS WELL. I WOULD SECOND
THE MOTION THAT MORALE HAD IF
THAT'S APPROPRIATE MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND WHILE
I APPRECIATE THAT TOWARDS THE
END OF SESSION- IT FEELS LIKE-
ALL OF OUR PROCESS EASIER
RATHER TRUNCATED LET ME JUST
CLARIFY FOR ALL. BUT THIS
TRAILER BILL HAS BEEN IN PRINT
SINCE TUESDAY- MATERIALS WERE
GIVEN. TO THE MINORITY CAUCUS-
I BELIEVE YESTERDAY- AND SO
WHILE I APPRECIATE IT'S NOT
IDEAL. THE MATERIALS WERE GIVEN
IN PROVIDED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU SEEN
NONE LET'S MOVE ON TO AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN PAID SICK
FULLY SICK PLEASE FINANCE. YES
COULD YOU MENTION MADAM CHAIR
OF AYE SURE MEMBERS CHRIS COOK
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SMALL
EMPLOYER FAMILY LEAVE MEDIATION
HANDWASHING AND SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE SO AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN CREATES A SMALL
EMPLOYER FAMILY LEAVE MEDIATION
PILOT PROGRAM. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING THIS PROGRAM WOULD
AUTHORIZES SMALL EMPLOYER OR
THE EMPLOYEE TO REQUEST ALL
PARTIES PARTICIPATE. IN A
DEPARTMENTS MEDIATION PROGRAM.
IT WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT AN
EMPLOYEE FROM PURSUING PURSUING
CIVIL ACTION UNTIL THE
MEDIATION IS COMPLETE. THIS
PILOT PROGRAM WOULD BE REPEALED
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND IS CONTINGENT UPON SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BEING
ENACTED. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN ALSO PROVIDES THAT FOOD
EMPLOYEES WORKING AND ANY FOOD
FACILITY SHALL BE PERMITTED TO
WASH THEIR HANDS EVERY THIRTY
MINUTES AND ADDITIONALLY AS
NEEDED. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
PROVIDES SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE. THE CIVICALLY THE BILL
FILLS THE GAPS IN PAID SICK
LEAVE PROVIDED IN RECENT
FEDERAL LAW AND THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER BY ESTABLISHING
COBIT NINETEEN FOOD SECTOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR FOOD SECTOR WORKERS AS
PRESCRIBED. ESTABLISHES
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR BUSINESSES WITH OVER FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR FIRST RESPONDERS
AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
EXEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW IN THE
RECENT FEDERAL LAW. ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
CONFORMS WITH THE RECENT-
FEDERAL SUNSET DATE DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
DECEMBER YEAH AND- STATES THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER SHALL
ENFORCE THE COSBY NINETEEN FOOD
SECTOR SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE PROVISIONS AS PRESCRIBED.
FINALLY EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN APPROPRIATES A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FUNDS
FOR THE LABOR COMMISSIONER TO
DO THE WORK FOR THE
ENFORCEMENT. WITH THAT I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ON THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. AND
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
SENATOR DORADO MANAGERS THIS I
JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION OF COURSE
IS THE TIME OKAY YEAH I WANTED
TO SPEAK IN IN SUPPORT OF THE
SMALL EMPLOYER FAMILY LEAVE
MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM. IT
SHOULD TAKE AFFECT- ONE SENATOR
JACKSON'S FAMILY. LEAVE BILL
BECOMES LAW THAT'S S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. I DO
BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION- HAS OVERSTATED THE
CONCERNS ABOUT LITIGATION EVERY
TIME WE'VE EXPANDED JOB
PROTECTION UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT. OF THE SORT
OF CLAIMS THAT THE SKY IS
FALLING ABOUT LITIGATION HAVE
NOT BEEN BORN OUT. FAMILIES
WANT TIME TO CARE FOR THE SICK
LOVED ONES. THEY'RE NOT LOOKING
FOR LAWSUITS THIS MEDIATION
PILOT PROGRAM REPRESENTS AN
ATTEMPT TO PROVIDE A FREE AND A
ONE OF A KIND FORM. THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING FOR RESOLVING
DISPUTES AND WHAT COULD BE
INADVERTENT MISUNDERSTANDINGS
WITH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
IT IS A CREATIVE CREATIVE AND
MEANINGFUL OPTION TO PREVENT
DISPUTES FROM ESCALATING- MOST
OF ALL IT REPRESENTS AN ATTEMPT
TO MAKE FAMILY WORK FOR SMALL
EMPLOYERS. I'M FINE I JUST
WANNA ALSO EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR THE SUPPLEMENTAL SICKLY
SICK LEAVE AS DESCRIBED THANK
YOU MANAGER THANK YOU. SENATOR
MORE LAW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WHAT TO WEAR WHEN I GO TO FIND
THE DEFINITION OF WHAT IS A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL IS IT YOU
CAN IT JUST BE FOR A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR. THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IS THAT IS THAT
WHAT MAKES THIS A BUDGET BILL
OR. IS SHOULDN'T THIS BE A
POLICY BILL. THREE TO MORE
LOCK- THE BUDGET BILL ITSELF
WHICH IS ALWAYS HUNDREDS OF
PAGES WHEN YOU OPEN IT IT. IS
FILLED WITH CODE SECTION AND
LOTS OF DOLLAR AMOUNTS UNTIL
THE WAY I'VE OFTEN DESCRIBED IN
UNDERSTOOD IT MYSELF. FOR MANY
YEARS NOW IS THE BUDGET BILL
ITSELF. IS THE WHAT AND THE
TRAILER BILLS ARE THE HOW IS
HOW THE DOLLARS ARE TO BE
APPROPRIATED SO WHAT'S THE
PROGRAMMATIC. EXPLANATION OF
WHY AND HOW WE'RE SPENDING THE
MONEY. AND SO I THINK WE OFTEN
HAVE DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ABOUT PERCEPTION ABOUT WHAT
CONSTITUTES A TRAILER BILL
VERSUS WHAT CONSTITUTES A
POLICY BILL- AND THAT WILL
PROBABLY CONTINUE TO BE UP FOR
DEBATE. WE OFTEN HAVE DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER. SOMETHING IS MET
THE SINGLE SUBJECT RULE IN A
TRAILER BILL I THINK I
REFERENCED EARLIER WHEN THE
QUESTION WAS RAISED BECAUSE THE
TRAILER BILL FOCUSED ON ONE
DEPARTMENT. WE DEEMED IT
APPROPRIATE ABSENT THAT I THINK
THAT'S ABOUT THE BEST. ANSWER I
CAN GIVE YOU THIS EVENING. YEAH
JUST CALLING BALLS SIR. YOU
KNOW HAVING AN UMPIRE OR
REFEREE JUST KIND OF WONDER
WHERE THAT. RULES ARE SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
EXPLANATION MESSENGER HAPPY TO
SENATOR LABEL. BERENBERG
METABOLIC CHARGES ONE TO HELP
OUT A LITTLE BIT AS WELL IF YOU
GOOGLE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TRAILER BUDGET JUST TREAT
GOOGLE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IT
GIVES YOU AN EXPLANATION AND
THE DEFINITION OF WHAT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGES. YOU ACTUALLY
COVER TO PERFECTLY MATCH CHU
THANK YOU GOING TO SAY DON'T
READ IF I WAS CENTER LEYVA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US IDENTIFY THAT. THAT
RESOURCE SENATOR NIELSEN I SEE
YOUR PAL SIR YES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WELL ON THIS
PARTICULAR POINT I RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT IT LITERALLY
EVERY YEAR AND TRAILER BILL
PROCESSES IN MY OPINION GOTTEN
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION
THAT SOME OF THESE TRAILER
BILLS INCLUDING THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH TODAY TONIGHT
TOMORROW. OUR POLICY. NOT
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BUDGET AND
THAT WAS THE OLD TIME.
DEFINITION FOR THE TRAILER BILL.
AND I AM GOING TO OBJECT TO
SOME OF THESE BILLS AT LEAST
FOR THE RECORD FOR THE HOPE OF
SOMEDAY WE WILL HAVE MITIGATION.
THAT PRECLUDES THESE EXCESSES
AT THE INTERSECTION. OF MAJOR
POLICY WE'VE GOT A WHOLE NEW
AGENCY CREATED HERE. AT THE END
OF SESSION. AND THAT THE
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BRIDGE THE BUDGET WELL ONLY IF
YOU SAY WELL IT WAS INTRODUCED
IN JANUARY. WELL THEN LET'S GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND FOR THE
CREATION OF A NEW AGENCY THERE
IS A PROCESS WHEREBY L. A. OLD
REVIEWS IT. AND THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION. I USED ON
WHICH I SET. WE'VE NEVER HAD
ANY DISCUSSION OF THIS QUOTE
NEW AGENCY. TO MY KNOWLEDGE A
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION. SO
LET'S GET BACK TO PROCESS AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO OBJECT TO THE
EXCESSIVE TRAILER. I APPRECIATE
THAT SIR AND I WILL READ ONE
ADDITIONAL SENTENCE- BECAUSE I
THINK YOU KNOW IN MANY
INSTANCES IS UP TO
INTERPRETATION AND I THINK YOU
KNOW THE USES. PERHAPS A CHANGE
OVER THE YEARS QUITE FRANKLY
BUT A TRAILER BILL OF THE BILL
THAT MAKE STATUTORY CHANGES
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. AND SO
WHILE WE TEND TO HARP ON
WHETHER TRAILER BILL TO TRAILER
BILL YOU KNOW I GUESS PERHAPS
THE BIGGER QUESTION IS IT
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE THE
STRUCTURAL CHANGES IN THE
BUDGET. BECAUSE THE TRAILER
BILLS ARE MERELY RESPONDING TO
THE STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT WE
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET ITSELF
AND SO YOU KNOW PERHAPS THAT
SHOULD BE THE BIGGER ARGUMENT-
THAT WE SHOULD. BRING FORWARD.
WHAT THAT ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON THIS TRAILER BILL.
THIRTY NIELSEN WHAT MADAM CHAIR
ON THIS VERY THIS PARTICULAR
BILL CAN SOMEONE TELL ME WHAT
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL OUR
NATIONAL. TO THE BUDGET. YES
THERE IS MONEY IN THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR DEALING WITH PAID
SICK LEAVE EDUCATION M. LABOR
ENFORCEMENT. AND SO THERE IS AN
ALLOCATION THIRTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE
BUDGET THAT REQUIRES ACTION TO
BE TAKEN. I STILL OBJECT FAIR
ENOUGH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SENATOR MELENDEZ. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN I JUST WANT TO
FIND OUT IF SENATOR MORALE I
BELIEVE MADE A MOTION- ARE WE
VOTING ON THAT MOTION. AS I
STATED AT THE TOP OF THE
HEARING SENATOR MELINDA'S ALL
THE MOTIONS WILL BE TAKEN. AT
THE END OF THE HEARING AFTER WE
HEAR ALL PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU IF HE CHOOSES TO MAKE
THAT MOTION AGAIN AT THAT POINT
IT CAN BE ADDRESSED. OF THE
LAST SEVERAL BUDGET HEARINGS
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE WE'VE
HEARD ALL THE TESTIMONY WE'VE
TAKEN PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END
AND WE GO FOR ONLY ABOUT. A
SOMETHING WE'VE DONE THE LAST
MAYBE THREE HEARING. ANY OF
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE ON. IT SEEN
NONE LET'S MOVE ON TO AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT FINANCE.
KERN COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT REALIGNED THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOU
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE TO GO TO THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE TO
COUNTENANCE. THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL CLOSES AND TAKE TO
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE BEGINNING JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT ALLOW CERTAIN
YEARS TO STILL COME TO DJJ
WHILE CHANGES ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IT RAISES THE AGE OF
JURISDICTION TO MAX T. J. J'S
FOR THE REALIGN POPULATION.
INCLUDES INTENT LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH AN ALTERNATIVE
DISPOSITIONAL TRACK BY MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO PREVENT
YOU FROM BEING SENT TO ADULT
COURT. RELATED TO FINDING THE
BILL PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
ESTIMATED YOU AND A MINIMUM OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER COUNTY. THIS CALL
YEARS TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THREE TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
IN THE FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED
BY COUNTY BASED ON 50% OF THE
POPULATION. JUDICATA FOR CRIMES
LISTED IN WEEK SEVEN OH SEVEN
B. AND PENAL CODE TWO NINE ZERO
POINT ZERO ZERO AND- 30% BASED
ON DJJ YOUTH STAGE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND 20%
BASED ON COUNTY POPULATION AGES
AND THREE SEVENTEEN. IT
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE TO ADJUST THE BITE
COUNTY FUNDING FORMULA
DISTRIBUTION BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR THIS POPULATION. PROVIDES
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ON A ONE TIME BASIS FOR
FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS AND
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
REAL LINE POPULATION. TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FINDING EACH
COUNTY WILL BE REQUIRED TO
ESTABLISH A JUVENILE ADVISORY
BODY THAT DEVELOPS AND
IMPLEMENTS A JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT PLAN HAS SPECIFIED.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION WITHIN THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
EFFECTIVE JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. HOUSING THE OFFICE WITHIN
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WILL PROVIDE A
CONNECTION IN UNIFIED APPROACH
BETWEEN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM AND THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THE OFFICE WILL
IDENTIFY AND DEVELOP POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVED
OUTCOMES- PROVIDE TARGETED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IDENTIFYING DISSEMINATE BEST
PRACTICES. COLLECTING CHECK FOR
COMPLETION OF THE COUNTY
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT
PLANS. PROVIDE CONCURRENCE ON
ALL UNITS RELATED IT GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
AND REQUIRES THAT ALL DSCC
JUVENILE GRANT PROGRAMS.
CONSCIENCE ARE MOVED TO THE NEW
OFFICE BY JANUARYTWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. INCLUDES A NEW STATE
LEVEL ON BY ADMIN. FOR YOUTH IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
HER HAS THE OFFICE CA OF ON
THAT OF LOCAL PROGRAMS BEING
YOU KNOW IN THE LINE.
POPULATION THE BILL ALSO
CONTINUES THE WORK OF THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COMMITTEE WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL UNTIL
JULY TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SUBMIT A PLAN BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
UPDATE THE JUVENILE COURT AND
PROBATION STATISTICAL SYSTEM
DATABASE. WHICH WILL DETAIL HOW
TO IMPROVE AND MODERNIZE
STATEWIDE JUVENILE JUSTICE DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING. BACK
INCLUDES ALL THE DETAILS OF THE
BILLS I'M JUST GOING TO SAY WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE DISCUSSION
HARD WORK WAS COMPLETED THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS PROPOSAL AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS. THIRTY
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR I DO KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF DIALOGUE THAT HAS GONE INTO
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE- IN MY
FOCUS ON FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS THE ISSUE OF RURAL
COUNTIES. ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT
I THINK RURAL COUNTIES ONE OF
FOCUSING ON IS A NON ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH. IN I THINK
ON THE MERITS OF THIS BILL-
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE. BUT I'D LIKE TO BE
A TO ASK ABOUT THE ALLOCATION
FORMULA WITHIN THE BILL. IN THE
FACT THAT. WHAT WE JUST HEARD
IS THAT ALL COUNTIES RECEIVED
THAT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THE- PER. IF THIS IS DAY ONE
CONFIRM THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO HOW
CAN WE EXPECT COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES PARTICULARLY IF THOSE
WHO RELIED ON DJ ARE
DISADVANTAGED. UNDER THE
FORMULA I'M GONNA ONE EXAM
MADAM CHAIR AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO YOU. DEALER COUNTY
INCREDIBLY SMALL COUNT PROXY
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND. THERE
BUDGET YEAR TO YEAR IS
INCREDIBLY TIGHT BUT ESPECIALLY
NOW UNDER THE ISSUE OF CODE. SO
WHILE THEY WANT TO STEP UP TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AT TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER USE IT IS GOING TO
BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT
THAT MONEY IS GUARANTEED TO
SUCH A SMALL COUNTY. WHO WANT
TO BE ABLE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING ON BEHALF OF THEIR YOUTH.
SO I WANT TO GET A GUARANTEE
HERE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IF THIS TORRENT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PER USE. IS SOLID
WITHIN THE BUDGET. THE OVERALL
ALLOCATION IS BASED ON TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER USE. AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL PLUS THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
MINIMUM. THAT BY COUNTY
DISTRIBUTION IS. BASED ON THOSE
THREE FACTORS I DESCRIBE 50%
BASED ON YOU'D BETTER EDUCATED.
FOR CRIMES AND WAIT SEVEN OH
SEVEN BEING PENAL CODE TWO NINE
ZERO POINT ZERO ZERO EIGHT. 30%
BASED ON THE JJ'S USAGE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND 20%
BASED ON THE COUNTY'S. YOUTH
POPULATION TOTALS- SO I GUESS
IN RESPONSE TO YOUR THE
QUESTION HERE IS THAT- THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF USERS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE TO GO TO DJJ
TODAY. I DON'T END UP COMING TO
DJJ- IN THE FORMULA WEIGHTS
THAT CATEGORY THE HIGHEST IN
SOME WAY TO REFLECT THAT AND WE
WANT TO PROVIDE COUNTY'S MONEY
TO DEAL WITH THAT. ENTIRE
POPULATION- AND SO LOOKING
FORWARD FOR COUNTIES THAT ARE
HIGHER OR HIGHER YOU LATER
SERVERS AND DJJ ON THAT
POPULATION. I MEAN THEY NEED TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY WITH
THE FOLKS MAYBE THEY'RE
INCARCERATING LOCALLY- TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ON THE ENTIRE NEW.
NEED YEAR- BUT IT'S SORT OF A
AND IT'S ALSO A LOOKING FORWARD
FORMULA THAT REALLY BAD IN SOME
WAYS. AND STATES THAT WHAT IT
WOULD HAVE SINCE 200-018-2000
NINETEEN IS A REFLECTIVE OF
WHAT WILL HAPPEN MOVING
FORWARD. MY WHAT ARE AND THAT
BIGGER POPULATION OF JUDICATA
YOUTH IN THOSE CRIME CATEGORIES
I MENTIONED. ARE ACTUALLY A
MORE HOLISTIC LOOK AT THE
POPULATION THAT ACTUALLY IS
BEING REALIGNED. I'M NOT JUST
THE ONES THAT WERE ACTUALLY
SENT TO DJJ. I THINK THE
FRUSTRATION THAT- AND I AGAIN
I'LL SPEAK MORE ON. RURAL
COUNTIES RURAL COUNTIES RELY ON
DJJ MORE THAN URBAN COUNTIES OR
EVEN SUBURBAN COUNTIES BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WITHIN THE COUNTY. SO
THEN WHAT WE'RE GOING TO START
DOING IS NOW WE'RE GONNA START
LEARNING. ADDITIONAL. AND I GET
IT IN ABSOLUTELY AGREE. WITH Y.
WE'RE GOING DOWN THIS ROAD IT
IS ABSOLUTELY. AFTER FUTURE OF
THE- KIDS. IN IT THIS TIME
THOUGH NEEDING BE A PER. THE
RULE COUNTIES. WHO DO NOT HAVE
THE FINANCES TO BE ABLE TO.
COMPETE WITH SUBURBAN URBAN
COUNTIES THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO DO SO. AND I JUST I HAVE
SOMECONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL IN IF MY LAST QUESTION
IS THIS FINAL PROPOSAL THAT'S
IN FRONT OF US NOW IN THE SAME
PROPOSAL HAS BEEN DISCUSSED.
OVER THE PAST MANY WEEKS WITH
COUNTIES. THIS FUNDING
ALLOCATION WAS ACTUALLY START A
PART OF THE LEGISLATIVE-
INITIAL PROPOSAL THAT WAS
RELEASED AND SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY THREE- LAST- I THINK IT
WAS LAST WEEK- SO. THAT DON'T
BREAK DOWN AS A FIFTY THIRTY
TWENTY HAS BEEN OUT THERE AND
AVAILABLE FOR SOME TIME- IS A
SAMETIME. DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
OKAY WHAT PERCENTAGE BREAKDOWN
FOUND- COULD BE YEARS-
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN USE VARIOUS
FACTORS- AND- WE INCLUDED IT'S
KIND OF LIKE A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT- REVISITING THE
DISTRIBUTION OVER ALL TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S FUNCTIONAL AND
HAS IMPROVED OUTCOMES FOR THE
POPULATION OVERALL. CAN YOU
TELL ME HOW YOU'RE GONNA
REVISIT THIS AND EVALUATE. WE
DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY I THINK
THAT'LL BE BASED ON WHAT TAKES
PLACE THROUGH IMPLEMENTATION
WHAT DATA WERE BEING OUT WILL
BE ABLE TO. HAVE BEEN THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS SO IT'S A
COMMITMENT THAT WERE COMING
BACK TO REVISIT THE
DISTRIBUTION- STAR IN. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THEY CAME TO
YOU'RE WELCOME SIR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AFTER
YOU'RE ELECTED TO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR I YOU REALLY GET
INVOLVED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
PRETTY CRITICAL FOR L. A.
COUNTY TO BE A PARTICIPANT IT
WAS A REWARDING EXPERIENCE FOR
ME TO SERVE ON THEIR BOARD- IN
UNDER EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE- I
SERVED AS SUPERVISOR WHEN
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER WAS
GOVERNOR. I NEVER SAW HIM AS
HE'S ACTIVE IN. WHEN GOVERNOR
BROWN WAS ELECTED HE WAS ED ARE
VERY FOR IT IN THE VERY FIRST
THE SECOND MEETING OR GETTING
THAT THAT HE COULD ATTEND HE
WAS THERE AND- WE HAD A GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP. I DO NOT
KNOW BECAUSE I JUST DON'T KNOW-
IF GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS ATTENDED
BECAUSE HE SAID BOARD MEETINGS.
I'M I'M- FOR SURE TO ERR MAYBE
REASSURED THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DIALOGUE GOING ON BASED
ON WHAT CENTER MCGUIRE YOU
SHARED. BUT WHEN I LOOK AT MY-
COMMENTARY I'M SEEING C. SACK
IN ALL THE COUNTIES OPPOSED
INCLUDING CHEAPER. OFFICER'S
BALIK COUNTIES OPPOSED TO THIS.
REALLY REAL SO I'M CONCERNED
THAT MAYBE THERE HASN'T BEEN
DIALOGUE SO MR COLUMN CAN YOU.
HELP ME OUT HAS BEEN DIALOGUE
AND THE SECOND QUESTION IS
FORMER STATE SENATOR. GLORIA
ROMERO FORMER. DEMOCRATIC
MAJORITY LEADER. HER HEART AND
SOUL INTO. DEALING WITH THIS
PARTICULAR AREA I'M JUST
CURIOUS HAVE YOU OR HAS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CONSULTED
WITH HER ON THIS INITIATIVE.
AND THERE HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF DISCUSSION WITH- THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT'S IN THE
COUNTIES ON THIS PROPOSAL-
UNFORTUNATELY THEY THEY ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT WE ARE AT.
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS IN THE
FUTURE AND REALITY THIS
PROPOSAL IS GONNA TAKE- OVER
FOUR YEARS TO. RESPOND
FERMENTATION INTAKE DOESN'T
COLLECT CLOTHES UNTIL JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND THE REAL
WORK BEGINS NOW AND WE
DEFINITELY- PLAN TO CONTINUE
INCLUDING THEM. IN THEIR
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THIS A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION. THANK
YOU HAVE A GLORIA ROMERO SHE
BEEN CONTACTED. I'LL HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON GLORIA AYE I
HAVE NOT PERSONALLY SPOKE WITH
HER WE SHOULD BE A GREAT
RESOURCE THANK YOU MISTER
CULLEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR MORE LIKE IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE THIS PLACE FOR
ME TO TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
CAMPAIGN RELATED THINGS BUT
I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT THAT. OFF STATE
PROPERTY. MOVING ON. TO
MANAGER- JUST MAKING A
PREDICTION I DON'T THINK I WAS
TALKING ABOUT. OKAY I WOULD SEE
THE VIEW FROM THE RAW. THANK
YOU MANAGER JUST TO PIGGYBACK
ON WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WAS ASKING
ABOUT. I DON'T KNOW I PREFER
CONFESS THAT I DON'T KNOW A LOT
ABOUT THE SERIOUS SO IF MY
QUESTION MAKES NO SENSE. I HOPE
YOU WILL TELL ME. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN THE PAST
OVER TIME SOME COUNTIES HAVE
DEVELOPED MORE MATURE AND
ROBUST PROGRAMS FOR DEALING
WITH THESE. SEVEN OF SEVENTY
JUVENILES. AND OTHER COUNTIES
HAVE REFERRED MORE. T. DJJ
WHICH I THINK YOU REFERENCED.
UNDER THIS PLAN IN MY TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY THEN
BE SOME FUNDING. DISPARITY
BETWEEN TWO WERE MORE ROOM
LOCAL PROGRAMS. AND COUNTIES
WHO NO LONGER HAVE DJJ. TO
REFER THE SEVEN OH SEVEN BE
JUVENILES. TO FINALLY I THINK
AS I DESCRIBED IT IS THAT IT
WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT- THE
BIGGEST PORTION WILL TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ALL THOSE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO GO TO DJJ EVEN IF
THEY JOBS GO- IN OUT. I THINK
SOME OF THAT MAY COME FROM
COUNTY IS CERTAIN COUNTIES
HAVING BETTER PROGRAMS IT MAY
COME FROM CERTAIN COUNTIES-
PREFERRING A CERTAIN. TYPE OF-
ADJUDICATION OR- DISPOSITION
TRACK FOR UNIVERSITY IS MAYBE
AN ALTERNATE PROGRAM THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE GOING TO DJJ SO
I THINK MOVING FORWARD. COUNTY
UNDER MOTTO I THINK IT'S GOING
TO HAVE- COUNTY IS THAT MAYBE
HAVE BEEN SENDING MORE USED TO
DJJ TO I'M CONSIDER FACTORS TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT WITH THE
POPULATION BUT THEY WERE
KEEPING. YOU KNOW AS A
HYPOTHETICAL EXAMPLE MAYBE THEY
WERE I'M KEEPING MORE USE THAN
THEIR HALLS WHERE DOES THE
INTERNET IS SIMILAR YOU HAVE
BEEN A DIFFERENT COUNTY MAY
HAVE RECEIVED OUTPATIENT.
TREATMENT OR SOMETHING ELSE IN
THAT MANNER SO- WHICH IS LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN BEING- HOLDING
SOMEONE OF THE STABILITY SO I
MEAN AGAIN THAT'S A
HYPOTHETICAL HERE BUT I NEED TO
SORT OF GIVE YOU THE START OF.
CONCEPTUALIZED PROBABLY NEED
TAKE PLACE BASED ON THAT AND
HOW THAT KIND OF LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. AND THAT SORT OF.
THE TOWN IS ALSO A YOU AREN'T
YOU SEPARATE AND ENDED. OR AND
OR- FOR- ACTIVITIES WERE ONE OF
THE LABOR THIS. YEAR LOOK AT A
GUY WHO SPENT SIX YEARS DOING
IT PROJECTS NOT. PUBLIC SAFETY
SO. WHEN THE LIGHT SWITCH IS
FLIPPED AND WE GO FROM WHAT WE
HAVE TODAY TO WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING. WELL RIVERSIDE
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE RECEIVE MORE
MONEY LESS MONEY OR THE SAME
MONEY. RIVERSIDE COUNTY BEING A
COUNTY THAT REFERRED MORE
JUVENILES TO DJJ SEVEN SEVEN
BEES. THEN THE COUNTY CAPT AND
LOCAL PROGRAMS. IS THAT A
QUESTION YES SORRY I WAS I WAS
LOOKING AT MY CHART TO SIGN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY YEAH ES THEY
WOULD GET US A SLIGHTLY
SOMETHING SMALLER AMOUNT THAN
IF WE JUST BASED ON. DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE OVERHAUL
OUR NATION'S PROBABLY TAKE BACK
SLIGHTLY SMALLER IT WOULD BE
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY ZERO IF WE
JUST USE ONLY DJJ AS A FACTOR.
AND IT WOULD BE ABOUT TWO POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IF WE
USE- THE FACTORS AS LAID OUT IN
THE TRAILER BILL. OKAY AND I
UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND THE.
INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS WORKING
HERE. SO MY NEXT QUESTION. IS
THERE A PLAN TO CREATE A PATH
TO HELP THOSE COUNTIES WHO.
NEED HELP TO DEVELOP. MORE
MATURE AND ROBUST LOCAL
PROGRAMS TO DEAL WITH THESE
SEVEN SEVEN B. IS THERE SOME
BREADCRUMB APPROACH TO
INCENTIVIZE THE COUNTIES AND
HELP THEM. EXPAND THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET THEM TO EXPAND TO DEAL WITH
JUVENILES. YEAH I THINK THERE'S
AND FOR THOSE BUT IT WILL NOT
ENTITLED TO MONEY SO MONEY A
MONETARY PLAN RIGHT IT'S SO
EASY THE TRAILER BILL
APPROPRIATES NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO ASSIST
COUNTIES MUST START OF FUNDS SO
THAT COULD BE FACILITY UPGRADES
I CAN BE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE CRITICAL
AREA WHERE SOME OF THESE
COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE THOSE
PROGRAMS DEVELOPS AND- DO THAT-
AND THEN SECONDARILY TO I THINK
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT THIS IS
NOT WHERE THE STATE WILL START
SENDING THEIR U. AS A MEDIA
LEAST. YOU'D BETTER IN THE IN
THE COUNTY MEANS JULY ONE IT
WILL BE. YEAH WILL NO LONGER BE
A SENTENCING OPTION EXCEPT FOR
CERTAIN YOU. I'M IMMEDIATELY IN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THEREFORE THERE THE SENATE A
SLOW INCREASE TO A COUNTY IT
HAD TO TAKE OVER THIS
POPULATIONS OVER THE NEXT TEN
MONTHS WITH THAT NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN
HAVING THE TIME TO SORT OF PLAN
FOR THAT- THAT. THE PLANE THE
HOPE IS THAT THOSE COUNTIES
WILL BE ABLE TO SORT OF. EITHER
BUILD UP THE CAPACITY
THEMSELVES OR SORT OF
REGIONALLY FIGURE OUT WHICH
COMPANIES CAN DO Y. AND SORT OF
LOOK AT YOU KNOW MAYBE ONE
COUNTY DOES MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT ONE TO SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT. AND SORT OF BUILD
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES NEEDED FOR
THE USED TO HAVE IF IT IF IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR OR
COUNTY TO HAVE THAT DEDICATED.
PROGRAM SO. I'M I'M A LITTLE
BIT HANDICAP BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW THE LANDSCAPE WHICH BUT
YOU KNOW THE LANDSCAPE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT ARE IMPACTED IN
THIS FASHION SO. GIVEN THE
LANDSCAPE WHICH YOU KNOW. DO
YOU THINK THE NINE POINT
WHATEVER IT WAS MILLION. IS
SUFFICIENT TO ALLOW THOSE
COUNTIES THAT ARE IMPACTED TO.
BUILD UP THE LOCAL PROGRAMS
NECESSARY. TO ATTRACT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING NECESSARY.
TO PROPERLY. A DEALER FOR A
TREAT. AND REHABILITATE THE
JUVENILES WERE TALKING ABOUT.
YEAH I HONESTLY I DON'T HAVE A
FULL ANSWER ON WHETHER IN THE
SUFFICIENCY ABOUT FINDING WILL
BE ABLE TO ALLOW EVERY COUNTY
TO DEVELOP EVERY PROGRAM- AND
IMMEDIATELY I. CAN SAY THAT YOU
KNOW OUR CONVERSATIONS ALL N
HAVE INCLUDED THAT AS THE START
UP SIGNS- AND I'M SURE. BOOKS
WOULD ALWAYS LIKE MORE BUT-
THAT WASN'T AN AREA- BIG
DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE PARTIES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS- AND SO-
YOU KNOW OUR HOPES IS THAT IT
IS SUFFICIENT AND IN
COMBINATION WITH MORE TIME. AND
OR OR COUNTIES TO KIND OF BUILD
THIS SLOWLY AS AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO IMMEDIATELY HAVE A
HUNDRED YEARS THAT THEY DIDN'T
OTHERWISE HAVE ON JULY WIND
IT'LL BE SORT OF THE SLOW
GROWTH INTO THAT PROGRAM OVER
TIME. WHAT I HOPE YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THIS AS WE
MOVE INTO THE- TO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSES AND- FRANKLY
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING UP WITH
MY QUESTIONS IN AN AREA THAT
I'M NOT PARTICULARLY. FAMILIAR
WITH SO THANK YOU MANAGER. OF
COURSE SENATORS COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR- THE QUESTION
SO FAR. I GUESS THE ISSUE FOR
ME IS THAT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS IS KIND OF A
COMPROMISE. PROPOSAL THAT THAT
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF FROM WHAT
THE GOVERNOR HAD PROPOSED- IN
HIS. EITHER IN HIS JANUARY
BUDGET OR MAY REVISED AND- SOME
INTEREST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HADN'T I GUESS I GUESS IT AND
YOU SAID YOU INDICATED THAT.
THE COUNTIES WERE AT THE TABLE.
AND ARE AWARE OF THIS PROPOSAL
AND WE'RE NEGOTIATING AND I MY
PHONE'S BEEN BLOWING UP TODAY
THEN MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. BUDGET AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WE'RE
FINISHING UP BILLS AND SO
EVERYBODY THINKS EVERYTHING'S
BEEN PUT TOGETHER AT THE LAST
MINUTE OR MAYBE IT HAS BEEN
BUT- THE COUNTIES ARE TELLING
ME THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THEY
HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE THAT
THEY'RE NOT PREPARED. TO BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT. THIS AS
QUICKLY AS BOB IS AS IT IS IN
THE BUDGET AND THAT THAT THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
DO THIS RIGHT NOW AND IT HAS
NOT BEEN PART. THAT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN AT THE TABLE
NEGOTIATING THIS SO I AM
CONCERNED CAN YOU TALK TO US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE-
I'M- WE DID THIS BEFORE. WHEN
WE TOOK A AT A WHOLE CATEGORY
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD
NORMALLY GO TO STATE PRISON WE
SENT THEM TO THE COUNTY. AND I
THINK THAT'S- WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS HAS BEEN A SUCCESS.
BUT WE ALSO SEND A LOT OF MONEY
AND SO I'M WONDERING WHY ARE
THE COUNTIES CALLING ME SAYING
WHAT THE F. AND THE- PROBATION
CHIEFS IN PARTICULAR SAYING
THAT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN AT THE
TABLE THIS IS NOT PART OF WHAT
THEY- WOULD HAVE AGREED. TO SO
ADD THIS THERE HAS BEEN- AS I
SAID STATED PREVIOUSLY
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DISCUSSION
WITH THE COUNTY IS ON THE
PROPOSAL OF REALIGNING- THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THESE USED
TO THEM AND- THE FINAL
AGREEMENT EACH YEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE DETAILS IN HERE THAT
THEY ARE NOT IN FULL AGREEMENT
AND- WHICH IS PROBABLY WHY
YOU'RE HEARING FROM THEM- SO IT
YOU KNOW I THINK OVERALL WE DID
OUR BEST TO INCORPORATE- INPUT
FROM MULTIPLE SITES- AND YOU
KNOW THIS IS A- AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TIME AND- THAT'S WHY
IT'S HERE BEING DONE NOW- AND I
THINK THE THING THAT I WOULD.
DESCRIBE IT- DID MENTION
EARLIER IS THAT THIS IS GONNA
BE A MULTI YEAR IMPLEMENTATION-
BEGINNING NEXT YEAR OUR WORK IS
JUST BE GONE ON IT THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE NOT OVER WE
EXPECT TO CONTINUE DISCUSSING.
THIS PROPOSAL- WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS AND SO- WE AND
WE REALIZE THAT TODAY THERE- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- BUT-
OVERALL THEY HAVE BEEN A PART
OF IT- WE DEFINITELY TRY TO
INCORPORATE. MANY COMPONENTS-
THAT THEY NEEDED CONSIDERATION-
AND- AND YOU KNOW WE FEEL LIKE
IT'S A GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN ALL
SIDES- AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
KEEPING THAT CONVERSATION
GOING- TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
WHERE WE CAME. THANK YOU ALSO
TO SKINNER THIRTY NIELSEN MMHM
SENATOR SKINNER FIRST. I WAS
GONNA GIVE HER THE FINAL WORD
IN THAT SHE THE SUB CHAIRS
LET'S GO TO HOUSTON TO NIELSEN
LET ME GO ON AND ALL I'LL BE
BRIEF I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
OBSERVATIONS OF MY TWO
COLLEAGUES OF THIS. SPOKE AND I
DO KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
AGENCY. AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND I TAKE NO
COMFORT IN THE KIND OF. TRUST
US WORDS OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IF ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN COUNTY GOVERNMENT
AND I HAVE NOT BUT I THINK I'M
RATHER EXPERT IN  REPRESENTING
NINETEEN DIFFERENT COUNTIES
OVER THE YEARS. THE WORST THING
THAT COUNTIES CAN NEVER HEAR
FROM THE STATUS TRUST US OR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TRUST US. THE ONLY TIME IN MY
EXPERIENCE THAT THE COUNTIES
HAVE EVER HAD THEIR WORD OF THE
WORD OF THE STATE CAP TO THEM
WAS TRIAL COURT. FUNDING THAT
WAS A LONG BATH. BUT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN HERE THERE'S A MULTI
YEAR WHATEVER OKAY. BUT I WOULD
REMIND FINANCES THE PURPOSE OF
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
REHABILITATION. WHICH REQUIRES
A LOT OF PROGRAMMING. AND ONE
AREA WHICH HAS BEEN NEGLECTED
HISTORICAL ONE THAT WAS UNDER
THE AUTHORITY OF THE STATE.
WHAT WHAT I CALL FOR THE BROKEN
HEART. WHICH IS WHY OUR YOUTH
SO MANY GET INTO DRUGS. ALCOHOL
AND. CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AND
ACTIVITY GANKS. THE NOURISHMENT
OF THE CHILD. LOVE AND
DISCIPLINE AND AFFECTION OF THE
FAMILY. WELL IN THAT THIS
PURPOSE. OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICESYSTEM NOW REMANDED BY
THIS IDEA. TO OUR COUNTIES IS
GOING TO BE ALL ABOUT
REHABILITATION. AND GUESS WHO'S
GOING TO GET SUED. NOT THE
STATE. COUNTY BY COUNTY JUST AS
HAPPENED IN THE ORIGINAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REALIGNMENT.
THE INMATE LAWSUITS THAT SO
BEDEVIL THE STATE. AND PUT THE
STATE INTO RECEIVERSHIP
IMPOSTERS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THOSE LAWSUITS MARCH RIGHT OUT
INTO OUR COUNTY JAILS. AND NOW
THEY'RE GONNA OF MARCH RIGHT
OUT IN DEALING WITH THE
JUVENILE OFFENDERS NOW REMANDED
TO THE AUTHORITY OF THE
COUNTIES. AND AS TO THAT
REHABILITATIVE PURPOSE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE KIND OF
JUST GLOSSES OVER THAT WELL
WE'LL DO SOMETHING HERE WOULD
YOU SHOP IN THERE I'M SORRY
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THAT
CHOICE. THE LAWSUIT WE'LL TELL
YOU WHAT YOUR CHOICES ARE AND
WHAT PROGRAMS WILL HAVE TO BE.
ADMINISTERED I WOULD GIVE HIM
SOME STARTUP MONEY FOR A
FACILITIES. GREAT WHO'S GOING
TO GIVE MONEY TO STAFF THOSE
FACILITIES. TO CONCEIVE OF AND
THE ARCHITECTS OF THOSE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. AT THE
BEST THIS IDEA IS NOT EVEN HALF
COOKED AND I URGE. A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU AND SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I WANT
TO FIRST THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN HAPPENING OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS. AND I
FEEL THAT THIS IS COME A LONG
WAY TOWARDS. I WANT TO PUT THIS
INTO CONTEXT THAT. LAST YEAR
READ THE LEGISLATURE ACTED ON
THE GOVERNOR'S INISH INITIATIVE.
WHICH THE GOVERNOR IN LAST
YEAR'S WERE TO A YEAR AGO-
BUDGET. PROPOSED TO MOVE THE
ENTIRE- HANDLING OF JUVENILES
WITHIN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND WAS VERY
CLEAR THAT THE PURPOSE WAS THAT
WE HAVE TO ACCEPT. AS WE OF- AS
SCIENCE AND MEDICS MEDICINE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IS TELLING US
THAT. JUVENILES WHO ARE IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. ARE
NOT FULLY FORMED ADULTS ENACT
FOR MANY OF THEM IT WAS A
TRAUMA INCIDENT IT COULD BE A
LEARNING DISABILITY IT COULD BE
SO MANY THINGS THAT CAUSED
DIFFERENT THINGS AND NOT AN
ESSENTIAL CRIMINAL NATURE THAT
CAUSED THEM TO. IN GAUGING
WHATEVER BEHAVIORS LED THEM TO
THAT SYSTEM. AND SO THERE WAS
THIS EMBRACING OF THE GOVERNOR
TO HELP ALL OF US LOOK ACT
APPROACHING JUVENILES
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE DO ADULTS
NO WE ALL KNOW THE WE'VE ALWAYS
APPROACHED EVEN KNOWS MUCH TO A
DEGREE DIFFERENTLY. BUT HE
REALLY ASKED US TO LOOK AT IT
THROUGH THE LENS OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AND WE ADOPTED
THAT. NOW A YEAR LATER OF
COURSE WERE IN A PANDEMIC WERE
IN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND IN OUR
ADOPTION OF THAT WE AND THE
GOVERNOR WE'RE SEMI SILENT
ABOUT WHAT WE WOULD DO WITH THE
STATE FACILITIES WHERE WE NOW
HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED KIDS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
STATE FACILITIES- I THINK FIRST
MANY PEOPLE THEN MAYBE THE
GOVERNOR I DON'T SPEAK FOR HIM
BUT I THINK IT WAS ANTICIPATED
THAT OVER TIME. THOSE WOULD
PROBABLY. CLOSE THAT THROUGH
THIS HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
MODEL THERE WOULD BE DEVELOPED
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACHES. BUT
I THINK WE'RE THE PLACE NOW
WHERE. I'M A VERY MUCH THROUGH
BUDGET REASONS AND ALSO BECAUSE
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED ARE HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR A LONG TIME THAT.
THEY FEEL THAT THE YOUTH SHOULD
BE CLOSER TO HOME THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE BETTER TREATMENT
BETTER- DID DIEM FIREMAN IS
BETTER- IF THEY'RE NOT SENT OFF
TO THE CENTRALIZED FACILITIES
SO THE GOVERNOR CAME BACK TO US
THIS YEAR AND SAID. LET'S GO
WITH THE LOCAL APPROACH. AND
BUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
WAS INITIALLY PRESENTED TO US
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR'S IT
DIDN'T HALF THAT HEALTH CONCERT
HUMAN SERVICES COMPONENT AND SO
THE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS HAVE BEEN HOW
CAN WE ACHIEVE. THAT. THAT
DESIRE TO. TREAT OUR KIDS
WITHIN OUR LOCAL AREAS HAVE OUR
COUNTIES WHICH IN MANY CASES NO
I STARTED OUT- JUST LESS THAN
TEN YEARS AGO. THERE WERE MORE
THAN FOUR TIMES. THE NUMBER OF
KIDS IN OUR STATE FACILITIES
THAN TODAY SO WE KNOW OVER TIME
MANY OF OUR COUNTIES HAVE JUST
ON THEIR OWN ACTED TO TAKE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY LOCALLY AND TO
HANDLE THERE ARE KIDS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT MANY OF OUR OWN COUNTY
JUVENILE HALLS HAVE MANY FEWER
KIDS SO ARE COUNTIES THEMSELVES
HAVE REALLY TAKEN AN INITIATIVE
MANY OF THEM. TO APPROACH
JUVENILE JUSTICE A DIFFERENT
WAY. SO WE NOW HAVE FAR FEWER
KIDS AND- THE N. MANY COUNTIES
WERE SAYING YES WE CAN HANDLE
THIS BUT OF COURSE THEY WANT TO
SUPPORT AND SO WHAT I THINK
THAT THIS. MODEL AND- I BUT IT
IT IT'S DISAPPOINTING TO HAVE
THE COUNTIES SO UNIFORMLY
AGAINST AD I THINK REALLY IF.
IF THEY LOOK AT IT A LITTLE
CLOSER I DON'T THINK THAT THEY
WOULD FIND IT SO OBJECTIONABLE
NUMBER ONE. HALF OF A RURAL
COUNTIES HAVE NO KIDS IN OUR
STATE FACILITIES HALF. SO HALF
OF A RULER COUNTIES RIGHT NOW.
HAVE SAID NO CHILD NO EIGHT OF
THE EIGHT HUNDRED. AND UNDER
THE FOREIGN FUNDING FORMULA IF
WE WENT WITH A FUNDING FORMULA
THAT SAID. YOU WOULD ONLY BE
FUNDED IF YOU SENT A KID TO DJJ
HALF OF OUR RURAL COUNTIES
WOULD GET NO MONEY. AND SO THIS
FUNDING FORMULA ENSURES THAT
ALL OF OUR COUNTIES GET MONEY
BECAUSE IT ACCEPTS THAT ARE
COUNTIES UNDER THIS SCENARIO.
WILL BE. HANDLING OUR KIDS AND
THERE'S. WHILE THE TRAILER BILL
SHOWS THE INTAKE OF DJJ
STOPPING ON JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE FACILITY STILL
CLOSE THAT DAY IT WILL NOT BE A
WHOLESALE. AND I BROUGHT UP THE
EIGHT HUNDRED YOUTH THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BECAUSE I WANTED TO.
TO SORT OF HELP US UNDERSTAND
THE SCALE THIS IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN OUR ADULT
REALIGNMENT ARE ADULT
REALIGNMENT WAS SUCH A MUCH
MORE A HUGE SCALE COMPARATIVELY.
WHAT OTHER POINTS DID I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE. SORRY I
BROKE MY GLASSES TODAY AND THEY
KEEP FALLING OFF MY FACE WHICH
MAKES IT VERY HARD FOR ME TO
REACH BUT- OF. SO ONE MOMENT.
D. STATE IS IN THIS PROPOSAL
PUTTING TWO HUNDRED MILLION ON
THE TABLE AND IF WE WERE TO
LOOK AT THIS IS ONLY BEING
THOSE EIGHT HUNDRED BUT WE HOPE
OF COURSE WE ARE HOPING THAT IT
OR NOT HOPING THAT MORE KIDS
GET INTO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT RATHER THAT WE ARE.
PROVIDING A LEVEL THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE ABLE TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS THAT WHEN YOU THINK OF IT
AS IT IS GOING TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY COUNTY GET SOME LEVEL OF
FUNDING I THINK IT'S VERY
RESPONSIVE AND IT ALSO IF YOU
WERE JUST A DIVIDED BY EIGHT
HUNDRED IT'S QUITE A HEALTHY
AMOUNT. NONE OF OUR BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
WHICH NOW HAS A ROLE IN THE
JUVENILES THAT ARE JUST HANDED.
HANDLED ON THE COUNTY LEVEL
NONE OF THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE BEING IMMEDIATELY
TRANSFERRED. AND BECAUSE WE ARE
DOING THIS IN PHASES WE HAVE
TIME TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS AND
ADDITIONALLY THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REFERENCES THAT IT'S
ANTICIPATED THAT THERE WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE. REGIONAL
FACILITIES WERE COUNTIES COULD
COME TOGETHER AND POOL
RESOURCES FOR PERHAPS THOSE
YOUTH THAT NEED A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF SUPERVISION OR HOUSING
FOR EXAMPLE SO WHILE THIS DOES
NOT CROSS EVERY T. AND DOT
EVERY I. I THINK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DID A GOOD JOB OF
EXPLAINING THAT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE DOING AND FACES.
AND IT DOES GIVE US THE ABILITY
TO. ADJUST AND IT'S EVEN BUILT
IN TO GIVE US THE ABILITY TO
ADJUST AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND I
JUST AGAIN REALLY I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
ENGAGEMENT AND I ALSO WANTED TO
JUST EXPRESS THEIR IF WE THINK
BACK TO OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THIS. MANY OF THE
EXPERTS THAT WE HEARD FROM.
REALLY TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PRESERVING THAT
LANDS OF THE HEALTH MODEL FOR
OUR JUVENILES AND I THINK THAT
WE HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB. IN IN.
IN IN SHARING THE DATA IS THERE
IN THIS MODEL. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEN NONE WILL MOVE ON TO AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE THE
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
TRAILER BILL. FINANCE. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND I WAS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON FINANCE. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE IS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE VARIOUS CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
OWE MONEY TO COUNTY IS FOR
THESE FEES ARE FACTORED OF JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
IN ADDITION THE BILL
APPROPRIATE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. BEGINNING IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND EXTENDING THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. TO BACKFILL- FOR THE
REVENUES THAT ARE LOST FROM THE
REPEAL OF THESE FEES. ARE WE
INTEND TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMING
MONTHS TO FINALIZE A
METHODOLOGY FOR ALLOCATING THE
FUNDS ARE AMONG COUNTIES- AND
WE INTEND TO IMPLEMENT THAT AS
PART OF THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
SEEN NONE MOVING ON TO A BEAST
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO CANNABIS
FINANCE. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ZERO IS THAT
CANNABIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THE CHANGES INCLUDE THIS BILL
ARE A SUSPENSION UNTIL TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO OF THE CANNABIS
EXCISE TAX MARKET INCREASE OR A
CULTIVATION TAX INFLATION
INCREASE. ON AMENDMENTS TO THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS CANNABIS TAX GRANT
PROGRAM TO ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
MATERIALLY PARTICIPATING IN THE
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS MARKET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
GRANTS AND ADJUSTING EXISTING
RESTRICTION THAT EACH MEMBER OF
THE CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS
PANEL. FROM A DIFFERENT COUNTY
YOU ONLY APPLY. TO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTED MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. QUESTION FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. THREE MORE
LOT. MATTER CHURCHES
OBSERVATION SKEWS ME. WE'VE HAD
A COUPLE BILLS COME UP RECENTLY.
MILLIONAIRES TAX. A WEALTH TAX
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL WE
GOT A BALLOT MEASURE THAT WAS
REACHED PROPERTY TAX. AND YET
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE PICKING OR
SELECTING. AN INDUSTRY WERE
SAYING LET'S. HOLD BACK OR
MAYBE EVEN REDUCE TAXES. AND
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPTICS I JUST THINK THAT IS NOT
GENERATION MANAGER. I'M SORT OF
A NO BETTER NO WORSE- SO THAT'S
WHERE MY DIFFICULTIES WITH THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. THREE
NINE WILL MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY
BILL. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX OF
THE EARNED INCOME AND YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT BINANCE. THANK
YOU GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JANE CHAMBERLAIN. THE FINANCE
SO AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX
WOULD EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
NINE HUNDRED COME TAX CREDIT
AND THE RELATED YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT. TO ALL TAX RETURNS WHO
FILE WITHIN INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER ALSO
KNOWN AS AND I TEND WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THOSE TAX RETURNS THAT
HAVE A DEPENDENCE. THAT
HAPPENED AND I AND I TEN AS
OPPOSED TO THE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER- TO QUALIFY FOR THE
CREDIT SO I JUST A LITTLE
BACKGROUND IN IN THE BUDGET
DEFICIT AND ACTED A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO. THE EITC OF THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT WAS
EXPANDED. TO I. TEN TAXPAYERS.
IF THE TAX HAD A CHILD A
QUALIFYING CHILD WHO'S FIVE
YEARS OLD OR YOUNGER. SO WHAT
THIS WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
IS AND HE SORT OF TAKES A LOOK
A STEP FURTHER AND GRANTS TO
TOLL ITIN TAXPAYERS. SO THAT SO
THAT. I CAN ESSENTIALLY I TEN
TAXPAYERS WOULD BE TREATED
EQUALLY WITH WITH WITH ALL
TAXPAYERS. SO THAT'S THAT'S
WITH BUILDERS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. THIRTY
DORADO- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS AND STAFF- THEY
WORKED REALLY HARD OVER THE
LAST. COUPLE OF YEARS AT LEAST
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE PROBABLY
BEFORE THAT OUGHT TO EXTEND THE
SEND AND TREAT ALL ALL WORKING
FAMILIES- EQUALLY ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. I THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS REMOTE
MEMBERS. SEEN NONE WE WILL MOVE
ON TO AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THE DEBTOR EXEMPTIONS HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION. FINANCE. EVEN AGAIN
MA'AM CHAIR MEMBERS CRITICAL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE DEBTOR-
EXEMPTIONS HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION
SO CURRENT LAW STATES THAT A
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION PROTECTS
THE VALUE OF A HOMEOWNER'S
PRIMARY RESIDENCE IN THE EVENT
OF A BANKRUPTCY SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDES THAT A SPECIFIED
PORTION IN EQUITY IN THE HOME
STATE IS EXEMPT FROM COUNTY
TOWARDS A JUDGMENT IN DEBT-
THIS BILL INCREASES THE
HOMESTEAD IN THE EXEMPTION IN
PERSONAL BANKRUPTCY CASES TO
THE GREATER OF THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR THE COUNTY MEDIAN.
HOME SALES PRICE IS UP TO SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES THESE
LIMITS SHALL BE ADJUSTED
ANNUALLY FOR INFLATION WITH
THAT VALUABLE TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
MISTER COOK I SEE YOUR HAND UP
THAT WAS JUST BECAUSE YOU WERE
GOING TO BE THE ONE TO SPEAK ON
IT. OKAY THANK YOU. YES ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ANY OF OUR
REMOTE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FIFTEEN NINE WE WILL MOVE ON TO.
AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BOARDS LICENSEES AND REGULATORY
FEES. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL KIMBERLY HARBISON
AGAIN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
INCREASES LICENSING AND
REGULATORY FEES FOR THE BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
AND THE- MEDICAL BOARD AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. PROPOSED FEE
INCREASES ARE NEEDED TO
MAINTAIN EACH FUND'S SOLVENCY
AND MAKE SURE LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT MANDATES CAN BE
CONTINUED WITHOUT DIMINISHING
CONSUMER PROTECTION. OR
REDUCING SERVICES TO LICENSEES
INCLUDING CREATIVE CREATING
SIGNIFICANT LICENSING BACKLOG.
TWO OF THE BOARD DID NOT RAISE
THEIR FEES AND MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS AND ONE HAS A TEMPORARY
INCREASE IN PLACE THAT EXPIRES
IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE BOARD TO LOOK FOR AND
IMPLEMENTED OPPORTUNITIES TO
CUT COSTS WHENEVER POSSIBLE BUT
THESE FEE INCREASES ARE STILL
NEEDED LARGELY AS A RESULT. OF
COST INCREASES FOR THINGS LIKE
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
RETIREMENT. RENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL RATES AND OTHER FACTORS
OUTSIDE THE CONTROL OF THE
BOARD. APPROVING THESE
INCREASES WOULD ALSO NEGATE THE
NEED FOR THE BOARD TO TAKE
LOANS FROM OTHER DC SPECIAL
FUNDS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
SPECIAL FUND LOAN AUTHORITY.
KNOWN AS CONTROL SECTION
FOURTEEN. ACHIEVING FUND
SOLVENCY THAT WAY WOULD
NECESSITATE AN EVEN LARGER FEE-INCREASE IN THE FUTURE BOTH
COVER ONGOING EXPENSES AND TO
PAY BACK THE LOANS. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ALL AT OR NEAR
THEIR CURRENT STATUTORY FEE
LIMITS AND REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE TO AMEND THEIR EXISTING
FEES. THE PROPOSED FEES
INVOLVED IN SUCH THE TO SUPPORT
THE FUNCTIONS OF THE BOARD OR
PROGRAM AND ARE SUPPORTED BY
CONTRACTED FEES STUDIES THAT
WE'VE SHARED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THE OTHER MAIN
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL IS AN
INCREASE IN THE ANNUAL FEE
CHARGED TO LICENSEES. WHO ARE
AUTHORIZED TO UTILIZE THE
STATE'S PRESCRIPTION DRUG
MONITORING PROGRAM NOTICED
YOURS. OR THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE UTILIZATION REVIEW
AND EVALUATION SYSTEM. BUT
HERE'S FEES PAID BY DCA
LICENSEES ARE USED TO
REIMBURSE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR WORKLOAD IDENTIFIED
BY DOJ AND APPROVED THROUGH THE-BUDGET PROCESS TO OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE STATES IN
INCREASING IN THE HERE'S FEE IS
NEEDED TO ADDRESS REVENUE
SHORTFALL. AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF LEGISLATION TOTALING MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION WHICH IS
PASSED IN RECENT YEARS.
ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL PROPOSES
TO CHANGE THE FEE FROM SIX
DOLLARS TO ELEVEN DOLLARS ON
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THEN TO LOWER THE FEE FROM
ELEVEN DOLLARS TO NINE DOLLARS
ON APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AFTER DOJ COMPLETES THE
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
WORKLOAD RELATED TO CURE TO
RESEARCHERS LEGISLATION AND THE
ONGOING COSTS DECLINE. I'D LIKE
TO NOTE THAT THIS THE LEVEL
WOULD NOT COVER ANY ADDITIONAL
COSTS THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO APPROVE FOR DOJ IN THE
OUT YEARS. WHILE DCA CANNOT
RAISE THE CEILING BUT ON ITS
OWN. THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO LOWER THE STATE'S
REGULATION IF THE REASONABLE
COST TO OPERATE AND MAINTAIN
CURES ARE LOWER THAN THE
STATUTORY LIMIT. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE THAT DRUG OVERDOSE
DEATHS HAVE SURPASSED MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCIDENTS IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND YEARS ASSIST
IN FIGHTING THIS EPIDEMIC WHICH
WE ALSO HEARD MORE ABOUT.
EARLIER TONIGHT. THAT CONCLUDES
MY TESTIMONY I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND I ALSO HAVE TAYLOR
SHAKE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIR HERE WITH ME
AS WELL. THANK YOU MS HARBISON
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. UNDERPANTS
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR- FISHY
THE PRESENTATION FROM FINANCE
AND CERTAINLY- SOMEONE WHO ALSO
SERVES ON THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON. BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HAVE SOME
FAMILIAR DAVE BOARDS BUT ALSO
SHOULD DISCLOSE MY CONFLICT OF
INTEREST IS THAT I COME FROM A
TO. BOARD HOUSEHOLD I AM A
LICENSEE OF THE BOARD OF
MEDICINE MY WIFE IS A LICENSEE
THE DENTAL BOARD. ALLIES THAT
NEITHER ONE OF THESE BOARD TO
BE AFFECTED BY THESE FEES
INCREASES SO THERE'S NO
PERSONAL CANGE FOR US BUT- AS
pLICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE HAVE A-
VERY PERSONAL INTERESTS AS WELL
AS THE POLICY INTEREST IN HOW
WE OPERATE OUR BOARDS AND
FINANCE THEM. SO S. SEVERAL
QUESTIONS THE FIRST OF ALL. I
KNOW THAT THROUGH THE-
COMMITTEE WE DO DO EVERY
SEVERAL YEARS- WE REVIEW EACH
BOARD AND- WE ACTUALLY DO ASKED
THE BOARD THEMSELVES ABOUT
THEIR FINANCES. AND THEY TELL
US LIKE WHAT IS GOING ON IN
TERMS OF THE FINANCES YET
ADEQUATE FINANCING AND SO FORTH
I RECOGNIZE THAT SEVERAL THE
BOARDS HERE THAT YOU'VE POINTED
OUT- YOU SAY NEED- INCREASE
FEES. AND A YELLOW. I GUESS ONE
QUESTION IS THAT- I MEAN WE'RE
BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT IN
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES- SO NICE
YEAR TO ACUPUNCTURE LICENSING
BOARD- IS WE'RE GOING FROM
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THAT'S LIKE A
3100% INCREASE. I MEAN THERE'S
SO MANY OF THESE- BUT THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT LIKE 10% 20% OR
EVEN 50% SOME OF THESE ARE LIKE
A 100% 2100% 3100% INCREASES IN
THE FEES- THE- ACUPUNCTURE
TRAINEE FROM 52210024100%
INCREASE ACUPUNCTURE TRAINING
APPLICATION FEE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TWENTY FIVE TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS-
YOU KNOW- AND THEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE BOARD BEHAVIORAL-SCIENCES AND WE OFTEN TALK HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
SHORTAGE WE HAVE. MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE DOUBLING THE FEES FOR A
LICENSED MARRIAGE FAMILY AND-
EDUCATIONAL COLLEGES MORE
DOUBLE HUNDRED TO FIFTY VOCAL
SOCIAL WORKERS YOU KNOW
DOUBLING. SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY YOU KNOW AFRICAN LAZY A
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY I
MEAN WE'RE TALKING DOUBLING
TRIPLING THEIR FEES.
REGISTRATION FEES AND THEN ON
TOP OF THAT IF IT WASN'T BAD
ENOUGH THAT WE ARE DOUBLING
TRIPLING QUADRUPLING.THEIR
FEES THEN WE SAY THE BOARD
THEMSELVES CAN INCREASES HE IS
AGAIN AND OFTENTIMES DOUBLING
THEM AGAIN. AND SO THAT IS
QUITE DISTURBING TO ME I WILL
POINT OUT THAT I KNOW THAT THE-
IT WAS A PREVIOUSLY A BILL THAT
WAS REJECTED BY THE SENATE-
THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWED THE BOARD
TO RAISE FEES WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. SO I
GUESS THERE SIR TWO PARTS THAT-
EXPRESSED CONCERN ONE IS THAT.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE FEE
INCREASE ITSELF AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND SO PERHAPS A MORE
INDEPTH DESTINATION THAT'S WHY
WE NEED TO DOUBLE TRIPLE. THESE
FEES AND THE FOLLOW UP IS THAT
IF THAT IS INSUFFICIENT WHY IS
THAT NOT SUFFICIENT ITSELF AND
WHILE WE ALSO AUTHORIZING THE
BOARD ITSELF WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT TO DOUBLE
THOSE FEES AGAIN. WHY NOT COME
BACK TO LEGISLATURE AND SAY
OKAY WELL. YOU DOUBLE THE FEES
ON UB'S BECAUSE BASED ON THE
WHATEVER INFORMATION YOU'RE-ABOUT TO TELL ME. WHY ARE WE
ALLOWING THE BOARD THEN WE
DOUBLE THE FEES WITHOUT COMING
BACK TO LEGISLATION EXPLAINING
WHY WHAT IS IT THAT'S GOING ON.
IN THAT REGARD SO I IT ALSO
SOME QUESTION ABOUT YOUR THE
LET'S START WITH THIS. FINANCE
THANK YOU DR PAN. I THINK OF IT
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT IT'S
COMING SIDING WITH THE ECONOMIC
RECESSION THAT'S TAKING PLACE
RIGHT NOW BUT FOR SOME OF THESE
LIKE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD HASN'T
RAISE THE FEES IN THIRTY FIVE
YEARS SO. WHEN IT'S OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME THAT IS THAT
LONG ISLAND LATELY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU SAID THAT
ALREADY. SO IT HAS A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE BECAUSE OF
THE TIME OKAY. LET ME POSE. AND
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TRYING TO
RECALL THE LAST TIME THEY WERE
BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT
SAID. THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
BOTH HAVE COMMITTEES THAT
OVERSEE THESE BOARDS- THAT THE-
IT'S COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HERE IN THE SENATE
SIMILAR NAME AND ASSEMBLY.
ANDREWS YOU THESE COMMITTEES ON
A REGULAR ASIS AND I KNOW
BECAUSE I'M A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WE ASKED ABOUT THEIR
FINANCES AND DO THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES. AND SO
USUALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY
TELL US THEY DON'T WE TELL THEM
WELL SHOULD YOU INCREASE YOUR
FEES. SO I AM CURIOUS AS TO SO
YOU I KNOW YOU SAID THAT HE HAS
AN INCREASE IN TWENTY YEARS.
I'M CURIOUS WHAT HAS HAPPENED
SUDDENLY. THAT AT LEAST SINCE
THE LAST TIME THEY HAD A SUNSET
REVIEW THAT'S HAPPENED THAT'S
NOW SAID THAT THEIR THAT THEIR
FINANCIAL SITUATION SUDDENLY
DECLINED SO IT'S NOT TWENTY
YEAR DECLINE. IT'S A MUCH
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME SINCE
LAST SUNSET REVIEW I WHICH I
CAN'T RECALL TO TOP MY HEAD
EXACTLY WHEN LASSEN TO REVIEW
IS FOR THESE BOARDS BUT- YOU
KNOW WE DO THEM. FAIRLY
REGULARLY SO IT'S BY LIKE FOUR
OR FIVE YEARS AT THE OUTSET THE
LONGEST AND PROBABLY SHORTER
THAN THAT. SO WHAT'S HAPPENED
RECENTLY. IT'S NOT SOMETHING
HAPPENED TWENTY YEARS AGO. NO
I'LL I'LL ASK TWENTY SAID
CALLING FOR ASSISTANCE IN A
MOMENT BUT I THINK- PART OF IT
TOO IS OF THE BOARDS HAVE.
TRYING TO BE RESPONSIBLE WITH
THEIR FUNDS OVER TIME AND YOU
KNOW TO SAVE MONEY WHERE THEY
COULD END UP SORT BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T PAID FOR AND MORE
DUTIES- MORE LICENSING REVIEWS
MAR APPLICATIONS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT AND THEY'RE AT THE
POINT NOW WHERE THEY CAN'T.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYMORE. GIVE
LEFT SO THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
COMING NOW BECAUSE THEY'VE
TRIED TO MAKE DO OVER THIS
PERIOD OF TIME. AND IN SOME OF
THE REVIEWS SAID THAT WE CAN
MANAGE IT MORE YOU KNOW WORKING
WITH AND WHAT WE HAVE. AND
THEY'RE AT THE POINT WHERE THEY
CAN'T DO THAT ANYMORE. OKAY SO.
IS THE FEE INCREASE THAT YOU'RE
ASKING THAT WE APPROVE. JUSTIN
OURSELVES SO WE'RE DOUBLING
TRIPLING QUADRUPLING SOME OF
THESE FEES. IS THAT SUFFICIENT
WHY IS THE BOARD NOW AUTHOR
ALSO BEING AUTHORIZED TO DOUBLE
THOSE FEES AGAIN WITH A DOUBLE
DOUBLE THAT'S AFTER THE MAX OUT
OF WHAT WE'RE ALLOWING THEM.
AND THEN YOU'RE SAYING LET'S
DOUBLE IT AGAIN WITH BOARD
APPROVAL ONLY NOW LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT TO HOW MUCH MONEY DO
WE REALLY NEED TO INCREASE THE
FEES. THAT WE SHOULD BE
OVERSEEING. AND NOT WITHOUT
HAVING TO GIVE THE BOARD IT'S
ALREADY TO INCREASE THE FEES
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
WHICH IS REALLY PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE THAT'S A POLICY WE
REJECTED AS A SENATE EARLIER.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT-
DOCTOR PAN. DOUBLING AGAIN I
THINK AREYOU REFERRING TO THE
UP TO X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS NINE
YES SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
HERE YOU HAVE INCREASES THE
LICENSING FEE LET'S SAY I'M
JUST COME PICK ONE AT
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD TWENTY FIVE
TO FIFTY. AND THEN THE BOARD
CAN INCREASE THE FEE UP TO
THREE FIFTY THAT'S ACUPUNCTURE
EIGHT. LICENSED FAMILY
THERAPIST SEVENTY FIVE TO ONE
FIFTY. AUTHORS THE BOARD
INCREASE THE FEES UP TO THREE
HUNDRED SO YOU WILL GO FROM
SEVENTY FIVE TO ONE FIFTY SO
YOU'RE DOUBLING IT. NAY SAYING
THE BOARD ITSELF CAN DOUBLE IT
AGAIN NOW THE THREE HUNDRED-
LICENSES THE EDUCATIONAL THAT
COLLEGE APPLICANTS. INCREASE
FROM ONE HUNDRED TO TWO FIFTY
AUTHORIZES THE- BOARD INCREASE
THE FEE UP TO FIVE HUNDRED SO
AGAIN WE'RE GOING FROM ONE
HUNDRED TO TWO FIFTY. AND THE
BOARD CAN NOW GO FROM TWO FIFTY
TO FIVE HUNDRED DOUBLING AGAIN.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO
WHAT'S GOING ON. WHY IS THE
BOARD BEING GIVEN THIS
AUTHORITY TO RE DOUBLE THE FEE
AFTER WE'RE READY DOUBLED OR
TRIPLED IT. IN THIS- AS AS
WELL. SO HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU
NEED. SO WE- THEM THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION NOT DEPEND SO
WHAT WE NEED IS THE AMOUNT THEY
WERE ASKING FOR NOW. WHERE IN
THE BILL IN VARIOUS PLACES IT
SAYS WE NEED YOU KNOW. THIS FOR
YOURSELF IN THIS AMOUNT NOW.
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED NOW WITH
THE UP TO LANGUAGE IS A CEILING
THEY WERE ASKING YOU TO APPROVE
OR NOT SAYING. IT'S GOING TO BE
WELL I THINK IF WE WANT CAN
YOU. I THINK IF THEY WANT THE-
MONEY. BACK TO LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AND THE OTHER POINT I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IS. THAT
IT'S NOT WITHOUT INPUT JUST
BECAUSE IT'S SET AT A LEVEL NOW.
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER STILL HAS
TO GO THROUGH REGULATORY-
REGULATION PROCESS. AND THEY
TALKED ABOUT THESE FEES WITH
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS SANTA OKAY.
IT'S A REGULATORY PROCESS A PRE
SHEET THAT I WANT TO BE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'VE
REJECTED AS POLICY HERE IN THE
SENATE. THE AUTHORITY YOU GET
THE BOARD TO INCREASE THE SEAS.
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATURE. WHICH
IS WITH ETHICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING US TO DO BECAUSE YOU'RE
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE
THE FEES FROM WHATEVER TO YOU
KNOW THIS EX NUMBER. AND THEN
WE GAVE THE BOARD AUTHORITY TO
AGAIN DOUBLE IT AGAIN. IN MANY
CASES. AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE THAT'S NO
DIFFERENT POLICY DECISION
YOU'VE EMBEDDED IN HERE- SO
WELL I'M NOT HAPPY ABOUT.
INCREASING THE FEES I ALSO
UNDERSTAND WE WANT TO BOARD THE
FUNCTION. I THINK WE'RE BOTH ON
THE SAME. SIDE ON THAT WE WANT
TO BOARD TO FUNCTION. WE WANNA
BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW WE ARE
RECOGNIZED NEEDING THE FEES
DECREASE FEES. BUT WHY IS IT
WILL ME THE BOARD AUTHORITY TO
INCREASE THE FEES EVEN FURTHER
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
TO KNOW IS WHY IS THE
LEGISLATURE NOT. IT IS
BASICALLY LEGISLATION BE
APPROVING ANY FEE INCREASES.
RIGHT AND OF COURSE YOU SHOULD
HAVE A RECORD PROCESS WHERE YOU
GET STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU COME
BACK TO US HE SAID GUESS WHAT.
WE NEED TO INCREASE THE FEES SO
MORE BECAUSE OF THIS WE HEAR
FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
DID OUR ANALYSIS AND ECONOMIC
YOU KNOW WE LOOKED AT THE BOARD
EXPENDITURES BOTTLED BLOOD
CETERA. AND YOU COME TO US AND
YOU EXPLAIN TO US WHY AND THEN
OF COURSE WE WILL SAY OKAY. OR
WE MIGHT HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT BUT ACTUALLY WHAT
YOU'VE DONE HERE AS YOU SAID
WE'RE GOING TO. ASK YOU TO
DOUBLE THE FEES BY THE WAY
THROUGH BUDGET TRAILER BILL
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
TIME FOR EXPLANATION AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO. ALLOW THE BOARD
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
YOU GET AS YOU'RE TELLING US
WILL PROVE IT IN ADVANCE. YES
OF COURSE NOT INCREASING IT
RIGHT AWAY BUT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO DOUBLE IT
AGAIN. THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE
VERY INAPPROPRIATE. MISMAS
HARBISON IF YOU COULD RESPOND
TO THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
WHICH IS YOU KNOW WHY CREATE
THIS AUTOPILOT OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE THE FEES AS OPPOSED
TO. THE EXISTING LEGISLATIVE.
INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. IF YOU CAN
THANK SENATE WEST. I THIS IS US
ASKING FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT TO SAY WE THINK. THIS
IS WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE NOW AND
WE CAN SEE IN THE FUTURE IT MAY
NEED TO GO UP TO. AN ADDITIONAL
LEVEL. THAT WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU. YOU KNOW IMPROVE. THAT
MUCH LEEWAY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
THROUGH REGULATION IN
COMMUNICATION. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE PUBLIC-
SAY THIS IS THE THRESHOLD THAT
YOU. I GO TO AND THEN AFTER
THAT YOU NEED TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE AGAIN-
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR I THINK
YOU KNOW WE PROPOSE THESE
EARLIER IN THE YEAR. IT WAS
DEFERRED IN JUNE BECAUSE OF
COMENZó JUST THE UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT THINGS BY OUT AND TIMING.
I THINK THIS IS AN EXTRA
MEASURE TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN
BE RESPONSIVE. TO THE NEEDS OF
THE DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING CONSUMER
PROTECTION THAT WERE NOT
DELAYED AND HAVING. YOU KNOW.
FUNDS THAT ARE IN ARE. OVER
JOHN. WELL I THINK YOU NEED TO
DO A MUCH BETTER JOB OF
EXPLAINING. THE FEES AND
FRANKLY- THEY SAID- YOU'RE
TAKING YOUR MOVING TAKING
SOMETHING ELSE BRAG OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
I DO NOT FIND YOUR ANSWERS
SATISFACTORY IN THAT REGARD I
THINK IF YOU SIMPLY PRESENTED
US A SET UP FEE INCREASES AND
PRESENTS THE EVIDENCE FOR WHY
YOU NEEDED IT. THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN FINE FOR ME EVEN THOUGH I
RECOGNIZE AS- THAT. BILLS FEES
ARE AND HOW TO PEOPLE ARE
PAYING THEM IT'S AN INCREASE ON
THE SOMETHING THEY HAVE TO PAY.
RIGHT BUT TO GIVE YOURSELF ALSO
THE GRANT THE BOARDS THE
AUTHORITY AFTER DATES AFTER.
THE SENATE HAS REJECTED THAT IN
THE PAST. IS A THREE TO
INCREASE THE FEES WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
FORESEES A STEP TOO FAR AND I'M
AND UNFORTUNATELY I'M ABLE TO
SUPPORT. THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE
OF THAT HE STRIPPED OUT THAT
PERHAPS WILL BE DIFFERENT. LET
ME JUST TOUCH BRIEFLY ON CURES
I APPRECIATE. THE CHAIR GIVING
INTELLIGENCE. REGARDING THE-
INCREASE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE CURES
DATA SYSTEM- SOMEONE WHO AGAIN
HAS TO USE THE SYSTEM. THIS
EXPANSION OF THE CARE SYSTEM IS
THIS TO ALLOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT LICENSED. THE LICENSEES WHO
ARE ACTUALLY PAYING INTO THE
SYSTEM IT TAKES EXPAND ACCESS
TO THE TO ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL
BEYOND PEOPLE WHO HOLD
LICENSES. TO CARE SYSTEM. ARE
YOU REFERRING TO THE DELEGATES
DR GRANT I AM TALKING ABOUT THE
CARE SYSTEM SOBRE INCREASING
THE FEES OF THE CURE TO THE
CARE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
EXPANSION THE CARE SYSTEM. IS
TO EXPAND SO THAT THE CARE
SYSTEM IS NOW ACCEPTABLE TO
PEOPLE BEYOND THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LICENSED FOR PAYING THE
FEES. SO THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER
OF BILLS IN RECENT YEARS- FOR
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THAT
DEPARTMENT JST AS THE C. P. IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THERE'S ONE THAT'S ACTUALLY
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR THAT WE HEARD. EARLIER
THIS EVENING- AB EIGHTY SIX
AND- THAT COMPONENT FOR EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT HAS ONE
POINT. FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEES SO. THE ANSWER IS YES OR
NO I THINK IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE
QUESTION IS IT TO EXPAND THE
CARE SYSTEM FOR USE OF PEOPLE
BEYOND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LICENSED WHO ARE PAYING THIS
FEE. SO. IS DOING A NUMBER OF
THINGS WHICH I WAS TRYING.
METHODICALLY IF YOU'D GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR EXPLANATION THAT'S
FINE HE GO AHEAD. AND SO THERE
ARE DELEGATES THE USER SYSTEM
AND THEY ARE NOT BEING CHARGED
FEES BECAUSE THEY ARE OFTEN
UTILIZING THE SYSTEM ON BEHALF
OF THE LICENSEE. SO FOR EXAMPLE
IN A DOCTOR'S OFFICE YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THE MEDICAL ASSISTANT OR
TECHNICIAN. ACCESS CURES BUT
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT
INDEPENDENTLY THEY'RE DOING IT
ON BEHALF OF A LICENSEE SO WE
DON'T THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
TRY TO THE MEDITATIONAL FEE TO
DO THE WORK OF. THAT DOCTOR'S
OFFICE. OKAY WELL I THINK THAT-
REGARDING THE CARE SYSTEM. I
BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULDN'T IF WE
DO EXPAND THE SYSTEM BEYOND THE
POINT AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POINT ABOUT IF SOMEONE'S ACTING
AS AN AGENT ON BEHALF OF A
LICENSE PERSON THAT'S DIFFERENT
BUT IF WE'RE GONNA EXPAND THE
SYSTEM ANYWAY BEYOND THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE LICENSE. THEN THAT COST
SHOULD BE BORNE MORE BROADLY
THAN JUST SIMPLY THE LICENSEES
BY INCREASING THE SEAS. SO I
THINK WE JUST WANT TO KEEP KEEP
THAT IN MIND AND ANY INCREASE
AND THE CURES FEES IT'S EASY
JUST IT CRANK UP THE FEES ON
THE LICENSEES- BUT AS THE
SYSTEM. IS BEING BROADENED IF
WE'RE ENGAGING PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWING PEOPLE THAN THOSE
PEOPLE SHOULD ALSO SHARE IN THE
COST OF THAT SYSTEM. SO
APPRECIATE- THAT- EXPLANATION
BUT THAT'S THE REASON FOR MY
QUESTION IS ANSWERED ON
QUESTIONS THAT WITH THAT THANK
YOU SOME VERGE MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A
QUICK COMMENT REAL QUICK I JUST
WANTED TO. FOLLOW UP ON THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN HAVING
ON THE SET. LIST LEGISLATION.
YOU KNOW AT THE TIME WE HAVE
COPD AND WE HAVE YOU KNOW
BUSINESSES THAT ARE. ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW I JUST
DON'T BELIEVE IS THE TIME THAT
WE SHOULD BE. RAISING FEES WE
SHOULD BE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
WAYS TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
SO WE CAN SAY THE MONEY IN
THAT. AREA VERSUS RAISING FEES
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT NOTE
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHTS SEEN NONE
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH. WE
HAVE REACHED. THE END OF THE
PRESENTATION TE NUMBER GENDER.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ANY OF THE BILLS THAT
WE HEARD TODAY AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. SIX
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
BOB REID WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS- APPEARING ON BEHALF
OF THE VALLEY ATWATER
COALITION- FORTY THREE
AGRICULTURAL WATER SUPPLIERS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SIX. OPS SPECIFICALLY THE
PROVISION IN THE LEGISLATION
RELATING TO THE FISH AND GAME
CODE. IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO
THE PLACEMENT OF A COMMA IN
THIS PROVISION OF LAW MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WERE UNDER THE
BELIEVE SINCE THIS LAW WENT
INTO EFFECT IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. THAT BOTH COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD TO ACT
ONLY ON THE COMPLAINT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IN ORDER TO PURSUE AN ACTION IN
TRIAL COURT TO COLLECT CIVIL
PENALTIES. AN APPELLATE
DISTRICT DECISION IN THE THIRD
APPELLATE DISTRICT. SAID THAT
BECAUSE IN LAYPERSON'S TERMS
BECAUSE OF THE PLACEMENT OF THE
COMMON IN THIS SUBDIVISION I
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY DID
NOT HAVE TO ONLY ACT UPON THE
COMPLAINT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE. INSTEAD
OF COMING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE GAINING THAT
CLARIFICATION AND FIXING THE
SUBDIVISION THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL NOW WANTS TO MAKE IT
EVEN WORSE BY ADDING IN. HIS
ABILITY TO TAKE ACTION- IMPORT
WITHOUT COMPLAINT OF THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE.
WHAT THIS COMES DOWN TO MADAM
CHAIR IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OVER TIME ESTABLISHES
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
FISH AND WILDLIFE THE
DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ARE PROVIDED THIRTY BY THIS
LEGISLATURE TO. REGULATE AND
ENFORCE OUR VARIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THEY DO SO
WITH A SPECIFIC PURPOSE AND
INTENT IS NO DIFFERENT IN THIS
SECTION EITHER AND SO WE OBJECT
TO THE PROVISION OF THIS BILL.
COMPLETELY AMPS PARTICULARLY AS
PART OF BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER REED
APPRECIATE YOU FOR BEING HERE
WITH US ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITH THIS IS IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE. AREN'T ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM HEARING ROOM
ONE TWELVE. LOOKS PRETTY EMPTY
TO ME. SO AGAIN DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS I AM CLEANING
PROTOCOLS- WE'RE GOING TO
INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT. ON
TODAY'S TESTIMONY. FROM WE ARE.
BASED ON THE HOURS THAT STAFF
AND WE'VE BEEN HERE ALREADY WE
ARE GOING TO WORK VERY HARD TO
HEAR AS MANY WITNESSES AS WE
CAN IN THE NEXT HOUR SIXTY
MINUTES- IF THE MODERATOR CAN
GIVE ME AN IDEA OF HOW MANY
COLORS ARE ON THE LINE. THEN WE
WILL FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH TIME
EACH COLOR HENCE MODERATOR.
SHARE WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE PARTICIPANTS
ON THE LINE ONLY SIX FEET THANK
YOU. AND ALL OF THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY VIA THE PHONE YOU CAN
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL NOW.
AGAIN ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
THE NUMBER IS GOING UP PRETTY
QUICKLY HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY ONE
WERE YOU READY TO BEGAN. YES
MODERATOR THANK YOU I'M READY
TO BEGIN- AND TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CORE HERE- WE HAVE ONE
HOUR. WE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM AS MANY WITNESSES AS
POSSIBLE AND SO YOUR
DISCIPLINE. IN THAT WILL HELP
MAKE SURE MORE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY AND SO I WOULD
STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT EVERYONE
KEEP THEIR TESTIMONY WITH IN. A
MINUTE CLOSER TO FORTY FIVE
SECONDS- IF YOU GET CLOSE TO
THE MINUTE I WILL TELL YOU YOU
HAVE FIVE SECONDS AND WE WILL
HAVE THE MODERATOR CUT YOUR
MIGHT AND MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU
MODERATOR FIRST WITNESS. SHARE
FIRST A LITTLE TINY NUMBER Q.
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WINE TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED. GOOD
EVENING JOSHUA DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
CALLING IN OPPOSITION AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE SHIFT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE POPULATION
TO COUNTY. WE PUT THIS BILL
DOES NOT REPRESENT WHAT THE
TERM REALIGNMENT MEANS IN
CALIFORNIA A REAL LINE IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SOLVE
A COMPLEX PROBLEM AND MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE WAY THAT IMPROVES
OUTCOMES FOR THE POPULATION.
DESPITE OUR INITIAL OPPOSITION
WE SPENT MONTHS NEGOTIATING A
FRAMEWORK THAT WOULD ACHIEVE
STATE LOCAL GOLD WITH OUTCOMES
THAT THE FOREFRONT OF OUR
DISCUSSION. EIGHTY SIX EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT DOES NOT REPRESENT
THOSE NEGOTIATION AND AS
OPPOSED BY THE COUNTY THE
APARTMENTS CATHOLIC
IMPLEMENTATION. NOT ONLY DOES
THE BILL ESTABLISHING
PROBLEMATIC STRUCTURE RELATED
TO THE NEW POPULATION BEING
SHIFTED LOCALLY IT INCLUDES
CONCERNING PROVISION. THAT
THREATEN THE ONGOING THE FACT
THAT THE EXISTING PROGRAMS THE
SAME FINANCIAL PROGRAMS THAT
FIRST GAVE THE ADMINISTRATION A
CONFIDENT CONCORD SUCCEED WITH
THIS NEW PROGRAM. WE REGRET OUR
POSITION AND HOPE FOR MORE
FRUITFUL. DISCUSSIONS IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. NOT WITNESS.
MACROPHYLLA TO LINE ONE ELEVEN
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS A JET FUEL FROM
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I
WANTED TO UP FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BOTH OR THE A
PRE FUNDING- THAT THAT SMALL
BUSINESS. HIRING CREDIT- AND I
ALSO WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE THAT ASSESSMENT
PEELS FOUR- REFORM LANGUAGE
THEY GIVE THAT THEY GIVE THOSE
IMPORTANT BODIES EXTRA TIME TO
WORK THROUGH THE BACKLOG CAUSED
BY COLD IN NINETEEN THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NOT A
LOT NUMBER TWO SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GOAHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND EVENING JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES RIVER
STATE PARK PARTNERS CALIFORNIA
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
O'CLOCK BOB FRANKEN FEATURE.
PREVENTION INSTITUTE CLOCK SHOP
FRIEND OF THE LOS ANGELES RIVER
AND NATURAL RESOURCES AND
COUNCIL LATINO OUTDOORS THREE
MORRIS HERE AT AND COUNSEL OF
THE MEXICAN FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPROPRIATION
MEETING EIGHTY EIGHT U. K.
STATE PARK FOR PROPOSITIONS.
FROM PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT
FOR GRANTS FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
WHAT OPERATING AGREEMENT THAT
STATE PARK. IN ART. AFTER
RECREATIONAL KIND CAN'T BE
OVERSTATED AND THE FUNDING
WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT EXISTING
FACILITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
OTHERWISE HARPER COMMUNITIES
ARE. NOT LEFT IN DISREPAIR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITH.
SHERRI NATURAL LINE Q. FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CARL GARIBAY BEHALF OF
AUDIBLE HEALTH AS WELL TROUT
UNLIMITED AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT THE
PROVISIONS IN AB SET CLEAR BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE WATER
POLLUTION LAWS AGAINST BAD
ACTORS TO PROTECT THE STATE'S
FISH BIRDS MAMMALS OR PLAN
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANKS CAROLINA FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
ELIZABETH EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY JOINING THAT
COUNTY AND PROBATION SHE
PLACES- WHO ARE UNITED IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT YEAH- DRAFTED. AT
THIS OF COURSE IS THE PROPOSAL
TO CLOSE THE JJ AND SHIFT THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS- I JUST WANTED TO
HOLES- IMPORTANT QUESTION ABOUT
THE CONFIDENTIAL NATURE OF THIS
POLICY CHANGE AND- WONDER
WHETHER MORE TIME AND MORE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION. ABOUT
IT APPROACH MIGHT BE WARRANTED
I'M IN A SHORT TIME THAT WE HAD
TO REVIEW THE SUBSTANTIAL
REWRITE OF THE DJJ REALIGNMENT
PROPOSAL SINCE LAST NIGHT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED DRAFTING CONCERNS.
INTERACTION WITH THE NEW OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AT THE TOUCH THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IN THE
LAST MINUTE CHANGES TO THE
FISCAL FRAMEWORK. TAKEN
TOGETHER WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THESE SECOND MAY MAKE UP THE
STRUCTURE ON WORKABLE AND
PERHAPS WILL NOT THE OUT FOR
YOU WHICH IS A SHARED OBJECT
ACCOUNT. THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU NEXT. NOT DOOR TRYING TO
SIXTY TWO PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY WAS A LITTLE
LONGER BRIAN CUMMINGS RELATIVE
TO ABA SIX ON THE OF BOTTLING
CAL AS SOON AND I NOTICED. MANY
OF THE MOST MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE IN
ADDITION WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE EXHILARATION OF
OPPORTUNITY MILLION ANYTHING
BOND FUNDS FOR NATURAL RESOURCE
PROJECTS- SPECIALLY IN THESE
TIMES THOSE INVESTMENTS WILL
COME IN A VERY CRITICAL TIME
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. MAX KQ SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JACKIE CUCAMONGA AND
CAL POLY CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN
AND WE ARE CONCERNED OR AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX ENDING THE
EXCLUSION OF I CAN INDICATE
KELLY I KEEP THE AND THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT THANK YOU MUCH
FOR WANTING TO CHECK ON THIS
AND WE ARE ALSO. OF THE CAL THE
IGP. THANK YOU NECK WITNESS.
WELCOME BACK LITTLE TO ALIGN Q.
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM WITH WIDENING GROUP AND
SEEING COMMENTS ON TWO
DIFFERENT BILLS ON BEHALF OF
TWO DIFFERENT CLIENTS FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY I WOULD LIKE
TO STATE THEIR SUPPORT OF AB
EVEN THINK AT THAT POINT
ALLOCATION FOR EACH CHARACTER
AND AS THE PREVIOUS AT SPEAKER
SO ON THE OCCASION AS INCLUSION
OF. ALL IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS%
IDEA FILERS RETALIATES YOU SEE
NOTHING HAPPEN NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA HI THIS IS KIRTI
FRIED AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED INVESTMENTS FOR THE LONG
TERM THAT WILL BOOST LOCAL
ECONOMIES PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIA WORKERS INVOLVED IN
FORMING A DIRECTOR CHERYL
INEQUITIES IN OUR TAX SYSTEM
THAT CURRENTLY CURRENTLY
ACTIVATED QUALITY FOR IMMIGRANT
WORKERS. AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW
WITNESS THAT. YEAH MAX NINE ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING AIR NOT BE WITH OTHER
ADVOCATE COMMENT ON IT TRAIL
BILL EACH SIXTY FIVE WE URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE PROPOSED
CHANGE TO THE AUDIT GUIDE WHICH
WOULD DRAMATICALLY LIMIT THE
SCOPE OF SCHOOL DISTRICT AUDIT
AND GREATLY REDUCE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN DISTANCE LEARNING THAT WAS
ADOPTED IN THE GYM BUDGET WE
RECOMMEND ENACTING MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION THE SCHOOL YEAR TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT DISPARITY
IN THE AMOUNT OF LAND
INSTRUCTION OFFERED IN
DISTRICTS PROVIDING DISTANCE
LEARNING. I THINK WE APPRECIATE
A LOOK AT THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN BUDGET
OVERVIEW FOR PARENTS AND THE
ANNUAL UPDATE TEMPLATES WILL BE
REVISED TO LINE SOMEBODY
CONTINUITY PLAN ADOPTED THIS
YEAR THE REQUESTED STAKEHOLDERS
BE ENGAGED IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE TEMPLATE AND
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE BOTH OF
THE ENGINE OVERVIEW INDIAN
LACTATE AND RECOMMEND EXTENDING
THE TIME FRAME TO REVISED
BUDGET OVERVIEW TEMPLATE AND
HOW MUCH OF A FIFTEEN TO ALLOW
SUFFICIENT TIME TO MEANINGFULLY
CONSULT WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE EQUITY
COALITION. LETTER FOR
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK NINE
DOOR TO LINE FORTY. PLEASE CALL.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL DEBT THE EXACT DIRECTOR
FOR THE CAL TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
I JOIN YOU TODAY HER VOICE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY ONE
OH SEVEN THE ASSOCIATION AND
ARE MORE THAN EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT AGENCY MEMBERS
BASICALLY HAVE COURT INCLUSION
OF LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL
AUTHORIZING TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
TEMPORARILY APPLY THE TRANSIT
SYSTEM DATA GOOD REPAIR PROGRAM
FUN. THINGS HAPPEN OPERATING
PURPOSES NECESSARY TO RESPOND
TO THE PANDEMIC AND PREVENT
FURTHER TRANSIT SERVICE
REDUCTION THIS MEASURE
RECOGNIZES THAT PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED AN ACCIDENTAL BY ME
CRISIS THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
STATEWIDE AND IF APPROVED WILL
HELP STATE TRANSIT SERVICE THAT
DIRECTLY SUPPORT THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WE
URGE HER AYE VOTE ON. EIGHTY
ONE OF. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THAT'S LINE CUTE FIVE. WE'VE
GOT. GOOD EVENING. I REMEMBER
OF HIS CAROLINE ON THE OF.
EXISTING WRITERS AND DAHLE
NORTH SALON WE'RE STARTING
MENDOCINO IN OPPOSITION THE
GENERAL THE PROPOSAL AB HE
EIGHT OTHER CONCERNS ARE THAT
THE PROGRAM FINAL PRODUCT
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU GET
SOMETHING THAT THE CHINESE AND
RUSSIAN OFFICERS CAN IMPLEMENT
I USUALLY AND I ALSO SUPPORT
ACTUALLY EIGHT EIGHTEEN TWO.
PERCENT FOR DISCO AND HUMBLE
AND JUST GO IT IS ACTUALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK THAT THE
BORDERS TO COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
GRANT MAKING PROGRAMS HELLO
COUNTY IS WHICH PART OF THAT
MEASURE FOR THAT SHRIEK AND
THEN TEMPORARY AND TIES TAX. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS ARE I DON'T
THINK. THAT YOU ACTUALLY DON'T
WANT TO MISS OUT ON THIS YOU
KNOW OUR OPPOSITION IF YOU GET
SICK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. SURE ENOUGH
THOUGHT I TO TRY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIRMAN KOBE IS
BELIEVED SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
AND ECONOMY SUPPORTED FUNDING.
HE HAD A DVD SIX THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND PROGRAM AT
THE PDP THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITH. HE MENTAL KEY EIGHTY
PROOF AHEAD. ASSEMBLY LOG
CHRISTMAS CONCERT ARE LOCAL
BERMAN AND RIGHT A STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SIX R. AND EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NO THAT'S TESTIFIED. NEXT
WITNESS. AXOLOTL LINE Q. EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF NC EAT CLEAN
ENERGY THIRTY MARIN CONTRA
COSTA NAPA AND SOLANOCOUNTIES
A WEEK BEFORE AB EIGHTY SIX
FUNDING FOR THE ALTERNATIVE AND
RENEWABLE FUEL AND BE A
TECHNOLOGY FINE I JUST FOR EASY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH
THAT CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
THAT'D BE EASY THANK THE MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NOW
TOTALING FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NICOLE ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT SIXTY EIGHT
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGN. THE
REALIGNMENT DOES NOT
INCORPORATE INPUT FROM THE
ENTITY TO PROVIDE CARE CUSTODY
AND REHABILITATION OF THE- IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
TIME TO PREPARE LOCAL PROGRAMS
AND FACILITIES. AND IF THAT
WASN'T THE GRANITE STATE
OFFICES AND GROUNDS THE NEW
OFFICE CONSIDERABLE CONTROL
OVER EXISTING LOCAL PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS AND IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING CERTAIN PAPER COUNTY
GOING TO THE FUTURE. IN
ADDITION SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
SUPPORTS THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE IN EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX
PERTAINING TO REALIGNMENT FACT
WELL AS FAR AS THE EXTENSION OF
THE DEADLINE AN AUTHORIZATION
TO CONDUCT ASSESSMENT APPEALS
REMOTELY IN AB ONE SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT HELLO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON THE AFTER
THE FAILURE OF CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. I AM ALSO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF A NUMBER
OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING AND YOUR WAY OF LIFE
ALL ABOUT HER NINE THAT THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION EAST
BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER OUR
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES AND FIGHT
FOR COMMUNITY ECONOMIC%
DEVELOPMENT. LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN POLICY
LINK SAN FRANCISCO FINANCIAL
JUSTICE PROJECT SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY ANNIE'S
PROJECT A COALITION WHO SHARE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE AND WANT TO
EXTEND THEIR GRATITUDE TO YOU
AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. SURE
MACKSVILLE LINE FORTY TWO CALL.
JERRY MEMBERS BRENDAN TO IT ON
BEHALF OF THAT VOICE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE PROVISIONS IN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE THAT
CREATING AN EQUITY ISSUE I
PROHIBITING ANY FUNDING FOR NEW
STUDENTS AT NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE CLASS FROM
THE SCHOOLS WILL BE
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY DEPRIVED OF
FUNDS GENERATED BY STUDENTS.
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
FURTHERMORE IT'S WELL KNOWN
THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PREPARATIONS FOR U. S. SENATE
MARK AT THE NEGOTIATIONS IN
WASHINGTON DC OVER CODE RELIEF
TO THE STATE THIS POLICY COULD
JEOPARDIZE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN RELIEF PROPOSED TO
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.SCHERING ACTUAL TIMELINE TO
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HEDDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF LOW INCOME CONSUMERS SURF I
QUICKLY GO EIGHT NUMBERS EVERY
YEAR AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERY AND EACH AND EVERY MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE AFTER CAREFUL
AND THOUGHTFUL WORK YOU'VE DONE
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR STRENGTHENING OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT HE CHALLENGE WE ALL
FACE FROM THE CURRENT ECONOMIC
CRISIS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS CLICK SUPPORT THE ITEM
NUMBER SHE EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH FIXES THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION TO HELP
PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR HOMES
DURING THIS CRISIS IT IS VITAL
TO DO AS YOU HAVE DONE AND IF
THEY TAKE ACTION TO PREVENT IT.
HARD BEFORE IT HAPPENED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. SCHERING
MAXILLA LINE A ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL- PRODUCTS AS SOON AS
HE ASIAN- CALLING TO EXPRESS
OUR OPPOSITION EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR IN ADDITION TO THE
MANY AMBIGUITIES STILL LEFT IN
THE BILL ARE PRINCIPLE
OBJECTION AT THIS POINT IS THE
INCONSISTENT. APPLICATION OF
EXEMPTION FROM THE BILL ALL
THAT TO EXITING LICENSEES HAVE
BEEN EXEMPTED FROM THE
PROVISIONS THIS BILL INCLUDING
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES INTO THAT
REASON WE OPPOSE. NEXT WITNESS.
TOTALING THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TWENTY
ECONOMIC THREE COOLEY. AND I'M
CALLING ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE PASSAGE TO
MAKE AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE CARE
I THINK ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE IN MIND AND NOT
BASED ARTICLE THANK. YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. SURE THAT
FULL LINE ONE EIGHTY NINE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NICOLE
LIEBERMAN HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF
THREE FOR OVER TEN YEARS
RESIDING IN MISSION VIEJO
CALIFORNIA ORANGE COUNTY I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE WE SHOULD BE
PROVIDING FAIR FUNDING TO ALL
OF OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
INCLUDING OTHER NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HEARD AND
ESSENTIAL THANK YOU TO THE
SENATORS WHO IS MAKING AN
EFFORT TO UNDERSTAND NON
CLASSROOM BEACH TRACKERS IN
THEIR HOME SCHOOL COMMUNITY WE
SEE YOU WE TALK ABOUT YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR THANK YOUNG
TONIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MANFROTTO TO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
FISHING GAME PROVISIONS-
INCLUDING EIGHTY SIX FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MR REID THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
MAXALT ONLINE Q. FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS ANA HOW ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES OF CALIFORNIA AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CAL YANKEE
ADVOCACY COALITION INTO THE
ACTIVE SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU. MAXILLA
TRYING TO THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS I AM
NOT GOING TO CHANGE OPENING
EIGHT PARENTS OF A CHARTER
STUDENT AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED HIS PROPOSITION EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE ADD IS I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE MAKE
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE THEIR
FUNDING FOR ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY. DURING
THE CURRENT FINANCIAL AND SO
MANY STUDENTS NEED MORE CHOICES
FOR SCHOOLING AND- NOT. ARE ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT PLEASE PROVIDE
CARE FUNDING AT LEAST IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THAT PHOTO LINE
ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING SHARE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LILLIAN MARGARET LET CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
AND EAT. THANK PLEASE ACTION
EIGHTEEN OF THE FELDBERG
FINDING WITH THE ALTERNATE AND
RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY FIND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
THANK YOUNG. NEXT WITNESS
MENTAL CAROLINA ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. H. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HURTS
YOUR CLIENT ONBOARDING FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS EIGHTEEN
HEARD HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTY FOR
CALIFORNIA- ON A COUPLE OF A
AND- REPORTING THE REALIGNMENT
BACK THE LANGUAGE CONTAINED IN
AB ET. I DON'T THOUGH LIKE TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THAT- YOUR OLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA I'M NOT AYE DOWN.
ON AB ONE SECOND WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE LANGUAGE I CAN MODIFY AND
SENTIMENT APPEALED FOR DEADLINE
ALTHOUGH IT BREAKING THE
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUES AT
THAT AND RURAL COUNTY.
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE BOARD RIGHT THERE SO
THEY COUNTY. SANTA CLARA AND
VENTURA. FINALLY I IN
OPPOSITION. THANK THE OPIOID
MIDDLE MEANT LAYING. ALSO REFER
THE OPPOSITION OF MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THEIR WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES THAT CALIFORNIA
AND UPWARDLY REVISED THERE IS.
A COUNTY SANTA CLARA AND
RECRUIT AND VENTURA WE DO NOT.
NEED URGENCY AND ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE NOW AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ON AN APPROACH THAT WE
CAN ALL AND COME TO AGREEMENT
ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HELLO HELLO THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY GROUND
EIGHT CAL AND SUPPORT AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BECAUSE
THE PROVIDE SUPPORT TO SMALL
EMPLOYERS WHEN SHARING THAT
LOWER WAGE WORKERS CAN TAKE THE
PAPER LEAVE THE PAPER WITHOUT
RISKING THEIR JOBS AND IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SIX TO BOLSTER THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
SHARE THE LITTLE TRYING TO ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE STATE FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR ROTH AND
COUNTY COUNCIL PROJECTED COUNTY
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SPECS- SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE LETTER FROM
SEATAC RC RC AND OTHER ENTITIES
EXPRESSED MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT I SHARE. WE ALSO DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY WORD AT THIS BILL
AND TOLD LATE THURSDAY
AFTERNOON IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
BEING A LANGUAGE IN THERE ARE
SOME AMBIGUITY THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED I WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
COME UP WITH A WAY TO REACH A
SOLUTION IS GOOD. FOR THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
THANK YOU. MATRILOCAL NINE ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHY NO ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I EIGHTY HARD
AMOUNT THEY CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PTA THE PARK THE
TARGET GROWTH FINING PROVIDED
IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY FIVE THE
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS.
BUT PLANNED GROWTH THANK YOU.
CEMEX THE LOCAL LINE TO USE
THAT. TO SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS LAURA WARD
WITH HOME SCHOOLING ORANGE
COUNTY. CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS
HAVE TO STUDENTS I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE EIGHT SIX
FIVE WITHOUT IT WE NEED AN
AMENDMENT THAT HELP THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE NEED SCHOOL CHOICE.
WE'VE CALLED CALLED AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
FAIR FUNDING FOR ALL OF THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THOSE WHO
CHOOSE NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS WE DO
APPRECIATE THOSE LEGISLATORS
WHO ARE HEARING US. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. WELL TO ALIGN FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GREETING THAT INJURED
MEMBERS OF- THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MATTHEW WELL WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE OP I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIX. AND WE ARE ALSO CLOSE TO
THE H. AWAY HOUSING PROVISIONS
AND. EIGHTY ONE CENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A PHOTO LINE
TO FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD EVENING. MILLENNIALS
UP COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
SIXTY EIGHT QUALITY CHANGE FOR
THE- ORGANIZER DAYTON BUT.
RIGHT AWAY THE COMPANY OPERATES.
PRESS RELEASE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT. THE CARD. OKAY
PROVISIONING PLEASE STAND
INSULT. NOT BY PEOPLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK
HELLO CAROLINA ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SUSPICION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE FISHING GAME PROVISIONS IN
EIGHTY SIX AND JUST WANT TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
MYSTERY WE ALLEGORICAL WHICH
AGENT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
SHARE DON'T AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU
PRESS STAR THEN ZERO IT'S FOR
AN ASSISTANT IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT PRESS ONE THOUSAND.
NEXT BILL WILL COME LINE AT TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IN SCOPE
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
AB. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SIX AND AB
ONE EIGHT SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU.
SCHERING AG THE LOCAL LINE Q.
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL AND
NUMBERS ANDREA BALL AND A HALF
OF THE EXPLORATORIUM K. TWELVE
SCIENCE LEADER NETWORK
COMMENTING ON EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE SECTION FORTY EIGHT
THE EXPLORATORY OF LEADER
NETWORK SEARCH TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX. MORE
THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND CLASSROOM
TEACHERS HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING PROVIDED
BY MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
TEACHER SCIENCE LEADERS I THINK
WE ARE RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
LEARN AND UNDERSTAND SCIENCE
THE NETWORK PROVIDE ONLINE
EXPERIENCES WITH ENGAGING
SCIENCE EXPLORATION AND
INVESTIGATION OF THIS CALLED
FOR AN CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS.
AN EXTERNAL EVALUATION IS
DOCUMENTED THE NETWORK'S
LASTING IMPACT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUED
FUNDING SO THAT STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS CAN CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE AND BENEFIT. FROM THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MACULATA LINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
COULD BE RIGHT WITH THAT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
OUR SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS ON TO BUILD ON AB 1865%
OF OUR- FAMILY TO FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND PARENTS BUT
IT DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH TO
FOURTEEN DAYS PROVIDE REJECTED
AND THEN NOTHING WELL THE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT THE STATE
BUDGET IT MAKES THEM A CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS BANKS.
CONTRACTORS LIABLE FOR THOSE
FEES. APLICADO THAT FIND AND
THEN ON. EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT WE
HAVE TO VERIFY LOCAL TO THE
GOOD COVERAGE. WITH THE AND I
WERE BACK AND- WHAT WE SEE THE
VALUE THAT GOES. AS A FOUR
UNDERTAKING AND ABILITY TO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE UTILIZE
TRAINED. PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS
THANK. YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. SCHERING A LAW.
I. TO SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
SENATOR MITCHELL AND MEMBERS
COMMINGLED NEED JUSTICE
COALITION WE URGE YOU TO CLOSE
BJJ THE RIGHT WAY ACCORDING
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
AFTER DECADES OF ABUSE WITHIN
THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM WE
CANNOT TRANSFER YOU EQUALLY
TROUBLESOME AND IF YOU THAT
COUNTY AND- STRONG OVERSIGHT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
YOUTH. ORGANIZATION PLEASE
ENSURE THAT YOU FIND EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DEVELOPMENT IN COMMON OR
CARE THEY DESERVE BUT I'VE
NEVER GOTTEN EITHER A
CORRECTION FOR LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NOT THE WHOLE
TIME NINETY SIX PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THE LAND CHAIRMAN
RUN AROUND IF EVENING ON THE OF
THE FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA NEXT YEAR AND-
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR WHICH IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT- ENFORCEMENT
STRENGTHENING AND CLARITY BILL
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
STAFF AND MEMBERS. WHO WORK ON
THE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL
AND THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING.
MATT PHILLIPS NINE ONE OH THREE
HE'S GLAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BENJAMIN
BERGEN AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA ACT
COMFORTABLE WHAT THE BOARD
SUPPORT AB THREE THREE THREE
ZERO AS A PERTAINS THE ACT. OF
THE CHANGES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MAXILLA
TRYING TO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A LINE
TO TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY BE NEARED. ARTICLE THAN
I'M GLAD. I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
JUST COALITION STRONG SUPPORT
OF CLOTHING DJJ THE RIGHT WING
SUPPORT THE- CURRENT PROPOSAL
TO- ESTABLISH AN OFFICE AND-
AND WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT- THE FUTURE CON BILLY
ACCOUNTABILITY OR LOCAL- AGENCY
TO TAKE. YEAH THANK. THANK YOU.
MAXTOR CAROLINE Q. FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
TODAY MARTIN DEL WITH CONSUMER
REPORTS- BUT HERE IN THE PORT
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR YOU
ARE TO UPDATE. YOUR BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT INTO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION- THE EIGHT THE
AGENCY HAS GAP THE FOURTEENTH
HOLE. THE FINANCIAL INTO AND
THE LAST TIME THE WORK POSSIBLE.
IT HAPPENS WELL FINANCIAL
WATCHDOG THOUGH REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE STAKEHOLDER
INPUT IN BOTH HOUSES WE'VE BEEN
INSPIRATION AND TURNING UP A
COUPLE OF ONE SECOND GONNA WILL
PROVIDE IMPORTANT COMPREHENSIVE
ON SUBJECT MATTER JURISDICTION
OR THE INDUSTRY INSURANCE THAT
CAN GET BETTER PUBLIC FACING
AGENCY THE CONFERENCE
COMMUNITIES NEED. GOVERNMENT.
TO WORK NOW MORE THAN EVER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT SEMESTER. ALMOST TIMELINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED. THEN NO
RESPONSE ALMOST TO LINE SIX
FEET BURIED PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS LIZ THAT
MENDOZA WITH INLAND COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE- AND AS A
MEMBER OF THE COUNTY ATC
COALITION I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. I'M SORRY
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX AND I'M
ALSO SUPPORTING- AB SIXTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MATT
TRYING TO ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY NO ONE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEAR.
ORIGINAL RESPOND TO MOVE ON TO
THE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING- I'M ROBERT ALEXANDER
WORK WITH OLDER LAW AND ACTIVE
DUTY IN SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY. I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. AS
WELL AS THE AB. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. OF THE HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION. TO CONSUMER MEASURES
WILL OFFER CRITICAL PROTECTIONS
FOR OUR ELDERLY CLIENTS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC UPLOAD IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. SCHERING MAXIMO
CAROLINE TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
PRIMACK WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOL
CENTER CALLING ON BEHALF OF OUR
HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS SCHOOLS-
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROVISION IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE THE CAP ON THE FOR NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. WE THINK IT IS JUST
UNCONSCIONABLE COULD DECLINE TO
STUDENTS ON THE LEFT HAND BACK
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SCHERING ACTUAL
TIMELINE TO NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS COULD SEND THEM BACK
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP AND
ABOUT THE TIME ON THE COURT AND
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN AND
THE SMALL EMPLOYER FAMILY B. E.
T. H. HELLO. WITHOUT LAPS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO MOLD TIMELINE
HELLO TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DEPUTY COUNTY
COUNSEL WILLIAM LET'S OF THE
COUNTY OF MONTEREY CALLING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB. SIX
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL STATED THERE ARE
POTENTIAL COMPONENTS OF EIGHTY
SIX THAT COULD AFFECT THE
RIGHTS OF COUNTIES AND CITIES
THAT HAVE ALREADY I HAVE
ALREADY FILED SUIT. MONTEREY
COUNTY FILED SUIT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE FACT IT IS
A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS
ALREADY DISCUSSING TERMS SUCH
AS ALLOCATIONS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE IT IS
NOT CLEAR THAT. THE STATE IS
FULLY COGNIZANT OF THE COUNTIES
AND CITIES PRIOR DAMAGES AND
FUTURE COSTS TO THE BASEMENT.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT
THEY'VE INVESTIGATED THIS. WE
HAD NOT BEEN CONSULTED WE ARE A
MEMBER OF A COALITION OF THIRTY
THREE COUNTY. AND CITIES RECORD
BY BARON AND BUDD IN WHICH WE
ARE ALSO VERY ACTIVE CO
COUNSEL- AND WE HAVE ATTEMPTED
ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS TO CONFER
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND THEY HAVE REBUFFED
OUR ATTEMPTS TO DO SO- ANY
SUBSTANTIVE DEGREE THEY SAID
THAT THEY WANTED TO MEET BUT WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DISCUSS.
ANY SPECIFICS OF THE SETTLEMENT
WITH THEM. SO WE ARE QUITE
CONCERNED- WE DID NOT HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE AND I WILL
POINT OUT THAT THE FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FIFTEEN METHODOLOGY-
PROPOSED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. IS CONSIDERABLY LESS
GENEROUS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THEY AND OTHER AGREEMENTS SUCH
AS THE ONE OF IMPLEMENTED IN
OHIO. SO FOR THOSE REASONS AND
OTHERS THAT I DON'T HAVE TIME
TO GO INTO- I OPPOSE EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS NFL. SURE WHAT ABOUT
NINE ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
MILLION MCPHERSON WITH THE
OAKLAND CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
SPEAKING TONIGHT FOR OAKLAND
THE ATTORNEY BARBARA PARKER AND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF ON BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX. I
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM MONTEREY AND
IMPOSING EIGHTY SIX. EIGHTY SIX
IS FUNDAMENTALLY PREMATURE IS
PREMISED ON A FUTURE SETTLEMENT
THAT DOES NOT YET EXIST THERE'S
BEEN NO OPPORTUNITY FOR INPUT
FROM COUNTIES AND CITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE LITIGATION AND THE
PROGRAMMATIC EFFORTS TO STEM
THE OPIOID CRISIS- ECHOING HIS
COMMENTS AS WELL. CONTRARY TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL STATEMENT
THE STATE HAS NOT INVITED
COUNTIES AND CITIES BUT HE.
WON'T ADMIT. AT NO. SHOULD BE A
WITHOUT IN BY AND CONSIDERING.
OF THE HEALTH COUNTY AND CITIES
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS AND WE'VE GOT ABOUT
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE MINUTES TO
GO SO I'M GOING TO ASK PEOPLE
TO BE BRIEFED TO GET AS MANY
PEOPLE IN AS POSSIBLE NEXT
WITNESS. SHARE MAX WILL
APPLYING IT TO NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY SIX.
YEAH MY MEANT REVENUE BACK BILL
AND ALSO AB ONE OH SEVEN
EXTENSION OF THE ASSESSMENT
APPEAL BOARD HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SURE ENACT LOCAL TO
ONE EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
TO ONE EIGHTY TWO. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PRESS CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. IT WAS FOR BUT
INSTEAD WAS CRESSMAN ASSISTANT
COUNTY COUNSEL WITH THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA THE FIRST
GOVERNMENT ENTITY IN THE NATION
TO FILE NO GROUPS LAWSUIT. MORE
THAN SIX YEARS AGO WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE HIS PREMATURE BILL IS
PREMISED ON A FUTURE SETTLEMENT
THAT DOES NOT YET EXIST. AND
JUST TO ECHO SOME COMMENTS FROM
SOME OTHER COUNTIES THERE HAS
BEEN NO OPPORTUNITY FOR INPUT
FROM COUNTIES AND CITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE LITIGATION. CONTRARY TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL STATEMENT THE
STATE HAS NOT INVITED COUNTIES
AND CITIES TO THE TABLE. THE
BILL THREATENS THE RIGHT OF
LOCAL ENTITIES TO RECOVER FOR A
LOCAL ABATEMENT EFFORTS AND
AGAIN JUST AS A REMINDER. THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA HAS BEEN
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
LITIGATION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WHEN WE WERE THE FIRST
TO FILE A GOVERNMENTAL SUIT
AGAINST OPIOID MANUFACTURERS
AND WE AND OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES
HAVE LED TO LITIGATION EFFORTS.
SO NO LEGISLATION SHOULD BE
ADOPTED WITHOUT SUCH CRITICAL
INPUT BY PEOPLE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE
LITIGATION FOR MORE FOR MORE
THAN SIX YEARS NOW. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. SURE
ENOUGH LEVEL LINE OH ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE OPEN. HI
THANK YOU. DONNA BAJOR AT.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN ANY BILL
THAT SHRINK- EIGHT EIGHT. WELL
STRENGTHENED OUR OVERALL. OR
ARE OLDER ADULTS CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANKS
A LOT NINE THREE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS JOHN WARD FROM COSTA
MESA AND I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE MAKE AMENDMENTS TO
PROVIDE FAIR FUNDING TO ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS INCLUDING
THOSE CHILDREN. ENROLLED AND
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MACROPHYLLA
COMBINED Q. SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND JAMIE HEALING
DELAY REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIX. WE'VE BEEN LEADING THE
OPIOID LITIGATION OF THE
THOUSANDS OF OKAY CASES
NATIONWIDE SAN FRANCISCO IS ONE
OF ONLY FEW. TO TRIAL. WHILE
THE STATE CASE EIGHT IT ERICA
ATTORNEY GENERAL. INTO THE OF.
THING IS QUOTE GET ALL THE
LOCAL PRINTER. NOT COMPLETE OF
OUR NEW CLAIM. AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL NEVER REACHED OUT TO
HIM. OF THE BILL IT WAS RANA
JEFF. WE WERE NOT INVITED TO
ANY DISCUSSION PRIOR TO THE
HEARING. AND THERE'S CURRENTLY
NO THAT'LL THAT DESPITE PACIFIC
ALLOCATIONS THAT WERE SUGGESTED
TODAY DURING THE HEARING. CAN'T
GO HAS NO WAY OF KNOWING WHAT
AND ON THAT FRONT WE WOULD OR
WOULD NOT RECEIVE OVER ALL OR
IN ANY PARTICULAR YEAR AND
EIGHTY SECOND RIGHT IN THAT
UNCERTAINTY AND CHECKING FUND
FILLING TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATIONS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SHOULD NEGOTIATE
DIRECTLY WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF ANY SETTLEMENT
FUNDS TO LOCALITIES. NOT PUSH
THE CRIED LEGISLATION THE
ATHLETES TO PLEASE THE ABC
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANKS A LOT TIME
SEVEN ONE PLEASE AHEAD YOUR
LINE IF. YES YOU VERY MUCH
WELCOME MANY TODD ON THE ELECT
DISTRICT OR COUNTY AND I FILED
FIRST BECAUSE DREAM AND IT WAS-
LITIGATION IT WAS WAS SANTA
CLARA OBVIOUSLY SANTA CLARA IS
GONE ON THE RECORD IN
OPPOSITION I MEAN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX. I'M ACTUALLY
A DEEPLY OFFENDED ABOUT THE
COMMENTS MADE ABOUT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND WHETHER OR
NOT HE MADE MISREPRESENTATIONS
I'M A FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR
TWELVE YEARS AND A MEMBER OF
YOUR BODIES WERE SECURING THE
STATE ASSEMBLY. AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU SANDERS SKINNER HIT
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD WHEN SHE
SAID BEES- ENTITIES WHO WERE IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
MANUFACTURING NO EXACTLY WHAT
THEY DID WHEN THEY PRODUCED AND
MANUFACTURED THESE OPIOIDS THEY
CREATED ADDICTS. SENATOR BELT
CONSIDER MORAL ARC IT ON THE
HEAD AS SUPERVISORS WERE
SUPERVISORS WHEN THEY TALKED
ABOUT THE PLAGUE THAT IS FACING
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHAT IS
THIS BILL ABOUT IT IS NOT ABOUT
THE BUREAUCRATS OR COUNTY
COUNCILS OR ATTORNEYS. IT'S
ABOUT GETTING MONEY. INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. A DEAL THE S. WHO
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THESE.
AND ADDICTIVE DRUGS IN OUR CAN.
I LISTEN TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S TESTIMONY HE WAS VERY
CLEAR I'VE ALWAYS SAID WHEN I
WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE. IT'S
VERY SIMPLE READ THE BILL
TENTEC SAYS EVERYBODY GETS TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND IT'S
PURSUANT TO THE AGREEMENT I
WOULD CHOOSE ALICE'S SIMPLY. NO
ONE WANTS TO BE ON THE RECORD
VOTING AGAINST THE ABILITY TO
GET MONEY INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
DESPERATELY NEEDED BY THOSE WHO
ARE ADDICTED TO THESE TERRIBLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THAT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MAXILLA CAROLINE TO TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS A RABBIT DENY REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA LIES FOR YOU COULD
COMMUNITY JUSTICE YEAR YCJA
ANALYZE COMPOSED OF OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND FIFTEEN
COUNTY TO CROSS THE STATE WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD CLOSE BJJ THE RIGHT WAY
GOAL RESULTS PUBLISHED
YESTERDAY BY A COUNTRY MUSIC. I
THINK SHOWS THAT TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIA BORDERS SUPPORT
CLOSING STATE YOU CHRISTIANS
EVERYBODY'S AND THEN WITH THE
NEW AGENCY WITH A FOCUS ON
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MAGDALA TRYING TO
SIX THAT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
CLEARLY SHOW THE NOW COUNT OF
JEWISH. CALIFORNIA SPEAKING A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX- INCLUDE ALL I CAN
HOLDERS IN THE COUNT YET YOU
SEE PROGRAM WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT KIND OF
COVERED NINETEEN WHEN SO MANY
ARE SUFFERING INCOME LOST.
THANK YOU. THE NINE ZERO NINE
Q. SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY WATER CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY HOLLISTER AND YOUR
INSTRUCTOR OR AT EIGHTY ONE
EIGHT SIX THAT IT. MAXTOR TWO
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS JOHN SAYS I REPRESENT THIRTY
THREE COUNTY FIVE CITIES.
ACOSTA THE CALIFORNIA IN THE
OPIOID LITIGATION WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY SIX. THERE IS NO
SETTLEMENT THERE IS NO
AGREEMENT AND OUR COUNTY CITIES
ARE EQUAL STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE SUGGESTION THAT THERE IS A
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FIFTEEN
INTRASTATE ALLOCATION THAT'D BE
VERY CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO HAVE WITH YOU TWENTY
GENERAL AND OUR THIRTY THREE
COUNTY THAN FIVE CITIES MUCH
LIKE OTHER COUNTY CITIES HAVE
NOT BEEN INVITED TO THE TABLE.
AND HAVE NOT BEEN INVITED TO
THE CONVERSATION OR HOW THAT
WOULD BE BOND WILL BE. DIVIDED
AMONG THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK
WELL TO ALIGN TOOL FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS BRAD COLE
CHIEF DEPUTY COUNTY COUNSEL
WITH PLASTER COUNTY I ECHO THE
COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY MADE IN
REGARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX TAKES
AWAY THE RIGHTS OF PUBLIC
ENTITIES THAT HAVE NOT FILED
CLAIMS WITHOUT GIVING THEM DUE
PROCESS I MEAN NO ONE REALLY
FOUND OUT ABOUT EIGHTY SIX
UNTIL APPROXIMATELY FOUR DAYS
AGO AT ANY TIME TO THE AG. OR
ANYONE FROM THE AG'S OFFICE
SPEAK WITH ANYONE AT THE SAC OR
THE WEEK IN REGARDS TO EIGHTY
SIX- EIGHTY SIX ALSO HAS
SEVERAL MISSING DETAILS IT IS
THE DISTRICT DID STUDENT THE
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTION OF FNDS-
HAS NOT BEEN AGREED TO IF YOU
READ THE HOUSE ARMED BILL AS I
HAVE IT GIVES SOLE AUTHORITY TO
THE H. G. IT DESCRIBES THE
STATE WIDE OPIOID SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. AS AN AGREEMENT
ENTERED INTO BY THE AGENT FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW WHERE DOES IT MENTION ANY
OF THE LOCAL ENTITIES ARE THE
CITY'S NO NEGATIVE
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO THE AG'S COMMENTS RELATED TO
THE RETENTION BY COUNTY ABOUT
SITE- BY COUNTIES AND CITIES
AND OUTSIDE COUNSEL IT IS THE
WORK OF THE OUTSIDE COUNSEL
THAT HAS BROUGHT THE CORPORATE
DEFENDANTS TO THE POINT OF
MAKING A SETTLEMENT OFFER. NOT
THE WORK OF THE AG'S OFFICE. NO
COUNTY BOARD THE STATE FOR THAT
MATTER COULD HAVE PROSECUTED
THIS CASE IT'S THEIR EXPERTISE
AND AFTER THIRTY ONE YEARS OF
PRACTICING LAW- YOU KNOW WHEN
TO HIRE OUTSIDE COUNSEL THERE
SHOULD BE NO NEGATIVE.
CONNOTATION TO THAT. TEN SECOND
RUSH IN. STUDENT NO THIS THE
SETTLEMENT IS SELLING THAT THE
LEAD AND THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SHOULD BE
INVOLVED IN THE DISK OF THE
DEAL HIM POLICY ISSUES THIS IS
A POLICY QUESTION NOT A
STRUCTURAL CHANGE TO THE BUDGET
YOU HAVE NO SETTLEMENT AT THE
PRESENT TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE GET THE GIST OF YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU'VE EXCEEDED THE
MINUTE THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. SHARON. NINE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
ELIZABETH CALVIN FROM HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH AND WE SUPPORT.
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
I'M SORRY SIXTY EIGHT. CLOSING
DJJ GETTING STATE LEADERSHIP
FOR BEST PRACTICES AND EQUITY
ACROSS FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE IT GIVES
FLEXIBILITY TO COUNTIES. OR IS.
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES BUT IT
WOULD INACTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
SHERIFF MAXWELL TRYING TO SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
VACANCY RATES ONLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN AND THAT'S EXACTLY
PROVISIONS AS WELL AS THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION IN AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
YEAH MAXALT ONLINE Q. SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX FOR PARDEE CALLIE I
G. COALITION AND WANT TO HAVE
THE I. T. THANK YOU SEE ALLEN
EXTENDED TO ALL I CAN HOLDERS
I'M ALSO IMPORTED AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT CLOSE DJJ AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
SERVICS TO THE VIEW. AND
LASTLY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE REGARDING
FEES THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SURE ENOUGH THE LOCAL
LINE TO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO TWO
EIGHTY SIX AGAIN TO EIGHTY SIX
FIGURE LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CANDIDATES
OVER THE LOCAL GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE MODESTO IRRIGATION
DISTRICT KINGS RIVER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT KINGS
RIVER WATER SITUATION ALL IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX- THE
FISHING WILDLIFE PROVISIONS AND
WE LIKE TO ASSOCIATE OUR
REMARKS WITH THAT THOSE WITH
MISTER REED AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT SENATORS WHO HAVE RAISED
QUESTIONS. ABOUT THOSE
PROVISIONS AS WELL THANK YOU.
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN THE CLAN
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO
IN THE COUNTY MARIN IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX UNLIKE
THE ASSERTION BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THERE ARE AMBIGUITIES
IN THE LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY IN
AB SIX AND SECTION ONE ONE NINE
NINE NINE POINT THREE THREE
RELATED TO RELEASING OF CLAIMS
BY GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES AND
ALSO AS IT RELATES THE LANGUAGE
FOR- POSSIBLY AS A NOT A LINE
FOR A MINUTE STRAIGHT LISTING
LAWSUITS THAT THE AG STRESS
WORK AND BE IMPACTED BY THIS.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE THINK YOU
NEED TO HOLD EIGHTY SECOND
ALLOW TIME FOR THESE DISCUSS TO
BE WORKED OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THE COUNTIES DIEGO
ALSO POSES AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT EJJP. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THAT HELLO
MORE CAROLINE THREE HUNDRED YOU
GONE AHEAD AGAIN HIGH YOUR LINE
OF OPEN. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DID LEAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION AND PRO
BONO OF THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR AND EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WE
REPRESENT LOW INCOME CONSUMERS.
BOTH IN A VARIETY OF CONSUMER
LIFE RELATED ISSUES AS WELL AS-
INDIVIDUAL CHAPTER SEVEN
BANKRUPTCY CASES AND BOTH OF
THOSE. LBANK IMPORTANT AS WE
NAVIGATE THE HANDLE CURRENT
INVOLVED SPEND THAT MAKE WORLD
AND PUT IT IN THE GROUND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SURE ENACT A MATERIAL
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR THAT'S ABOUT THE WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL. EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT E ALSO
WITH ME TONIGHT IN A RECORDING
FROM AN ANGRY AND THEN ANY
PACKAGE PERSON. WHO HAD BEEN
ORGANIZING THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THE WORK TO REPEAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE HE HE HAD A ONE MINUTE
RECORDING FOR THE LABEL
ATTENDED A TECHNICAL INABILITY
IS THAT OKAY DO I HAVE YOUR
PERMISSION TO PLAY HER ONE
MINUTE. TESTIMONY YES. WHERE.
THE FOLLOWING. ANALOG. OKAY
OKAY. OKAY. FIVE YOU KNOW COLE.
YOU KNOW OUR. RECORD-EAGLE OR.
LOCAL. I LIKE I WAS. HOWEVER.
IF YOU LOOK. AT THAT BYE BYE
CAN ONLY HANDLE ACTUAL IN. ALL
RIGHT GRANT AWAY YOU KNOW OKAY
YEAH. AND IT IT INCLUDES BURKE
WITH GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATE SAID
LIKE TO COMMENT ON A COUPLE
DIFFERENT BILLS FOR A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT CLIENTS FIRST SAID
LIKE INDICATE THAT SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY IS OPPOSED TO IT
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SIX
PARTICULARLY THE ELECTRICAL
CHARGING PROVISIONS IN SECTION
EIGHTEEN. WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS I'D LIKE TO REGISTER
A STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
WOULD QUADRUPLE THE HOMEOWNER'S
EXEMPTION IN A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IS A PERMANENT INCREASE IT
IS UNRELATED- TIED TO COVE IT
UNLIKE THE FORBEARANCE OR THE
EVICTION LEGISLATION HEARD
EARLIER TODAY AND SENATE
JUDICIARY THIS IS A PERMANENT
INCREASE IN A TRAILER BILL
WITHOUT NEGOTIATION WITHOUT
DISCUSSION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
UNILATERAL INCREASE- IN A
TRAILER BILL THAT WAS PUT INTO
PRINT WITHIN THE LAST TWO DAYS-
WE WOULD URGE YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
JERRY I HOLD THE LINE VIDEO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OURHAN WITH WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA AND WILL COME
DOLLARS I THINK IT'S STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY
PROGRAM. FOR FAMILIES CAN
ACCESS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
EIGHTEEN SEVEN EIGHT SIX SURE
OF THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND I
THINK THAT SHOULD. BE COVERED
UNDERSTAND THAT. HM SOME OF THE
TEAM CALL I HAD. WE CAN HELP
THE HOSPITAL BOARD BEHAVIORAL
PLAN CALL REGARD AB THREE ZERO
REPORTS CORE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL THAT THE BLATANT FEES
THANK YOU. MAX HELLO KITTY
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING COM YOU CAN ALSO
BE HAPPEN SHEL DEFENSE BY THE
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THE
HARM THAT HE J. J. IN QUICKER
ARGUED ABOUT DOCUMENTED AGING
MUST CLOSE NOW AND IT MUST BE
CLOSE THE RIGHT WAY EIGHTY
EIGHT POINT FIFTY EIGHT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING OVERSIGHT
AND SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE DJJ
REALIGNMENT INCLUDE YOUTH
OUTCOMES. AND PUBLIC SAFETY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MOM WE
HAVE TEN TO ON TO ASK PEOPLE
JUST TO SAY THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL THEY'RE CALLING
THAT'S IT. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
SURE ENACT A LAW TO LINE UP
THREE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ- THAT
SHE PROBATION OFFICERS ARE
REGRETTABLY OPPOSITION EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT ON DJJ
REALIGNMENT AND THE VERY LARGE
AND COMPLEX POLICY ISSUES THAT
THREATENS YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HE SAID AT THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE LEADING.
BIRDS JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY SIX AB. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE AND
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SCHERING THAT WILL GO
AT THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING GOING BACK
AS FOR THAT PROJECT THE
COALITION A MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION OF A HUNDRED WHERE
THEY CAN STATEWIDE TO SUPPORT
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE. EIGHT
GROUPS HAVE ASKED HAVE THEIR
NAMES ENTERED INTO THE RECORD
IF I MAY AS ACTION CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
HEALTHCARE LAWCENTER CLEARLY
WORKS COURAGE CAMPAIGN AND DRUG
POLICY ON IT THANK. YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. SURE WELL
NEXT COULD BE TWENTY PLEASE BUT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MORE
TALK ON CALLING ON TWO ISSUES
FIRST REGARDING EIGHTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WE ALSO JOIN OUR FELLOW CITY
AND COUNTY. AND OPPOSE THAT
LEGISLATION SECONDLY AB ONE OH
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
WE SUPPORT PROVISIONS RELATED
TO TRANSIT FLEXIBILITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
SCHERING AG POLITICAL TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THANK YU MADAM CHAIR MITCHELL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND THE
PUBLIC MY NAME IS SARA BACH AND
THE MOTHER OF THREE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AT SCHOOL LEADER AND A
MEMBER OF THE FUND ALL KIDS
COALITION AS A MATTER OF
PRINCIPLE FAIRNESS AND THEN
ENTERED THE VERY FAMILY DURING
A PANDEMIC PLEASE CONSIDER. THE
MOTION BY MORLOCK AND SECOND
FIVE MORAL AND ECHOED BY
MELINDA IS TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A VOTE TONIGHT THROUGHOUT
ALL SCHOOLS INCLUDING A SCHOOL
THEY'RE BEING CALLED CALLED
GRAMLEY THANK YOU IN ORDER.
THANK YOU YOUR IN SUPPORT OF
THE MOTION WE. APPRECIATE IT
NEXT WITNESS THAT. SHARE THANKS
A LOT. THREE TIME THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS BILL.
GOOD EVENING IS A LIFE IS GIVEN
FROM THE UC BERKELEY'S CENTER
FOR CONSUMER LINE ECONOMIC
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. SURE
THREE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS JIM
pFRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
TO VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
AND AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE AND
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR VERY
HARD WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THREE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
AND MARK PEOPLE WAITED
PARENTING CREDENTIALED TEACHER
IN PLASTER COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE AND
ASK FOR AMENDMENT TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR STUDENTS AND NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
THANK YOU ALL OF THE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NATURAL
THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JACKIE TURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CLOSE TO
EIGHTY SIX REGARDING THE OPIATE
LITIGATION CATION BATTLEMENT
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
SHARE AT THREE FORTY YEARS AGO
I HAD. MORGAN PARK THE BUDGET
CONTROLLING THE SITUATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE FISHING GAME
CODE PROVISIONS THAT. EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. SURE IT'S THREE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE
DID ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL PAR WITH TO
QUICKLY DEALER CALIFORNIA RIGHT
COMMISSION WESTERN PLANT HEALTH
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE PROVISIONS OF EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THREE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE MAY
BE NEEDED. THIRD GRADE WILL. HI
MY NAME IS PRETTY MUCH. THE
THREE KIDS THAT MISSION THAT
THAT COUNTY CHARTER SCHOOL IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE AFTER YOU PLEASE MAKE
AMENDMENTS RIGHT PROVIDE
FUNDING TO ALL HEART.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS INCLUDING
GIRLS AND ROLLING GOT A NON
FACTOR BASED THANK. YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. SHARE IT
THREE FORTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBIN A KINDER ON BEHALF OF
HIS CLIENT THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE EIGHT SIX
FOUR THE FBI AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT OF AB
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SIX EIGHT YEAH
THANK YOU. THANK GOODNESS. SURE
THREE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO BACK TO FULL
COMMENTS OF THE KING BALICAMP
ACCORDING TO THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE CHARACTER OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK GOODNESS. THREE FIFTY
SEVEN CRITICAL I HAD. FOR A
LITTLE. CARBURETION IF YOU WERE
A WORKER HOUSING OKAY YOU WHAT
THE. THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SECTION THIRTY ONE OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE GESTATION
TRAILER BILL TO THE NEWS THAT
HAPPENS REVOCATION PROCESS
THANK YOU FOR YOU EN MODERATOR
THIS WILL BE OUR LAST NUMBER
THE PUBLIC TO TESTIFY NEXT
WITNESS. JERRY THREE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF INTER COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRANSPORTATION FOOD PROVISIONS
AND AB ONE OF SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO STUCK IN THERE WITH
US- APPRECIATE YOU FOR KEEPING
YOUR TESTIMONY AT THE SINK
THAT'S POSSIBLE THAT ALLOWED US
TO HEAR FOR MANY MORE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. WE ARE ALLOCATED
IN OUR BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE TO
ALLOW FOR ENOUGH TIME FOR THE
VOTING TO TAKE PLACE. AND SO
MEMBERS- WHO ARE. HERE PRESENT
IF THEY WOULD RETURN BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THE VOTING
PROCESS.
AS I STATED EARLIER AW
SB SIX WITHOUT OBJECTION WAS
HEARD- FOR INFORMATION ONLY AND
A VOTE WILL NOT BE TAKEN TODAY.
DAHLE.
FOR FILE- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR A. B. EIGHTY SIX.
IT'S BEEN MOVED. MISTER SEVEN
SHOP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL BY MID JULY
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO BELL HI
BILL HI CABALLERO. COPYRIGHT
DOLLY YOU KNOW THE SENATE A
DOLLY AS WE DID EARLIER I THINK
IT IF YOU JUST SAY AT LEAST THE
BILL NUMBER JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR
IF YOU JUST SAY AND WE WERE ON
EIGHTY SIX- DALLY AB EIGHTY SIX
NO THANK YOU. DOLLY NO. THE
RAZA. YES I DORADO HI HERTZBERG.
HER TADO HI HER DAUGHTER I
LEYVA. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI. MELENDEZ WHEN IS AB
EIGHTY SIX NOW HELLO I'M I'M
SORRY CENTER CONSIDERED
ANYWHERE ON SCREEN THE LAND IS.
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX NO MELENDEZ
NOW. MORNING MONNING I MONEY I
MORE LOCK. NO MORE LUCK WITH
THEM IS THERE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO SAY THE BILL NUMBER PLEASE
EVERY TO DO IT. MODOC AB EIGHTY
SIX NO THANKS MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. AB EIGHTY SIX NOW THANK
MORRELL NO HAN HI CAN I ROTH
AYE ROTH AYE SKINNER. SKINNER
HI MY COUNTY HI AKOWSKI HI CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG HI.
THIRTEEN FIVE. THIRTEEN FIVE
THE MEASURE IS OUT- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AB ONE OH SEVEN GENERAL
GOVERNMENT SO MOVED IT'S BEEN
MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS. CENTERS
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL HI NIELSEN
NO YES AND NO WELL I BILL I
COPYRIGHT. CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
DALY AB ONE OH SEVEN NO DOLLY
NO TO RAZA I RAZA HI HERTZBERG
HI BECAUSE BURKE HIGH PATADA HI
CAROLINE LEYVA HI I'M MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
AB ONE OF SEVEN NOW MELENDEZ NO
MONEY I. MONNING I'VE MORE LAW.
MOORLACH AB ONE OH SEVEN NO
MOORLACH NO MARIA. AB ONE OH
SEVEN AROUND THE L. BOROUGH NOW
PAN HI PAN HI RAW HI. ROTH AYE
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI MY COUNTY
BY THE GONSKI HI. THIRTEEN
FIVE. THE VOTER THIRTY FIVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION TO PASS
CENTERS MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
HI. NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO BELL
HI. BILL HI CABALLERO. HI DOLLY.
DALY AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR NO
DOLLY NO TORONTO. RATHER AYE
HERTZBERG ALL HERTZBERG AYE HER
TADO AYE MADONNA AYE LEYVA HI
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE CHOIR AYE
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR NOW
MELENDEZ AND NO MONEY HI
MORNING ARE MORE LOCK WARLOCK.
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR
NO. MOORLACH NO MORALE YEAH. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR NO ROAD NO
HAN ALL RIGHT PAN AYE ROTH AYE
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER HI
MY COUNTY HI THE COSBY I.
THIRTEEN FIVE. THIRTEEN FIVE
THE PASSES. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE SEVEN TO MORALE- YOU.
REFERENCE THE MOTION EARLIER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION
NOW SIR I WOULD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- RIGHT NOW THIS BILL
PASSED AND AGAIN STILL EXCLUDES
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS I MOVED TO A MAN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE TO STRIKE
SECTION FOUR THREE FIVE ZERO
FIVE SIX A C. ONE SO THAT THOSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE FUNDING. SIMULATOR
SCHOOLS AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE VERY WELCOME IS
THERE SECOND. OKAY SECONDED THE
SECOND WAS BY SENATOR MORE
LOCK- MR SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE MOTION. CENTER
ON THE ON THE AMENDMENTS TO
EIGHT PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE. ON THE
AMENDMENTS SENATORS MITCHELL
NOW MITCHELL NO NIELSEN YES YES
AND YES. BELL. WELCOME BILL
NELL. CABALLERO CABRIO NEL
PALLY KELLY ON THE AMENDMENTS
HI ALEX HIDER ALSO. NO BROTHER
NO HERTZBERG NOW HERTZBERG KNOW
HER DAUGHTER. THE TITLE NO
LEYVA LEYVA NO MCGUIRE YEAH
MCGUIRE KNOW MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
ON THE AMENDMENTS HI AND AS I
MONEY. NO MONEY NO MORE LOCK.
FOR A LOT OF THE AMENDMENTS HI
MOORLACH HIGH MORALE. WELL ON
THE AMENDMENTS FIVE ZERO I CAN.
PIANO ROCK. SKINNER SKINNER
SKINNER NO CASKEY NO NO I CAN
SKI NO. FIVE FIVE FORTINOS SO
BEFORE I ANNOUNCE THE VOTE I
HAVE BEEN- APPROPRIATELY
CORRECTED REPRIMANDED BY THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE BECAUSE
WE WERE NOT GIVEN THE
AMENDMENTS IN WRITING AND SO WE
DON'T WANT TO BE IN A POSITION
OF SETTING A PRECEDENT AND SO
IF YOU'LL JUST HOLD ON FOR A
MOMENT- LET ME GET THE RULING
BACK FROM THE SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE. SANTA MARIA YOU GOT ME
IN TROUBLE. PROBABLY NOT THE
FIRST TIME WELL THAT'S NOT TRUE
THE. PHYLLIS'S HANG ON AND SEE
WHAT SHE SAYS. YOU LIKE AN
EMAIL MANAGER. NOPE WAIT FOR
THE SECTOR THE CITY TO COME
BACK WITH- HER DIRECTION. THANK
YOU. YEAH YEAH. YEAH YEAH.
RELATED TO YOUR- YEAH. HELLO.
YEAH. THAT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A- MY WHAT. YEAH I THOUGHT. HI
SO. OKAY. GOOD. LATER ON. SO
COLLEAGUES THE VOTE TAKEN WAS
BASED ON AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
SHARED VERBALLY IN CONCEPT THEY
WERE NOT SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IN WRITING AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
VOTE TAKEN WAS ON CONCEPT ALONE
SENATOR NIELSEN TO WHAT PURPOSE
THE RISE OF MANAGER I OBJECT TO
THIS RULING. THERE WAS A TIME
IN THIS INSTITUTION WHAT EVEN
IF COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS HAD TO
BE HANDLED OUT. END OF THE FOR.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT
CHANGED MUCH MUCH SINCE I'VE
BEEN BACK A LOT OF YEARS HERE
DISAPPOINTINGLY THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED AND WE WERE NOT
INFORMED IN ADVANCE THAT THESE
DEMAND WHICH HAD TO BE HANDED
OUT SO I CHALLENGE THAT RULING
AND I THINK IT'S IN CONSISTENT
WITH PAST PRACTICE. AND LET'S
GET BACK IN BE EQUITABLE TO ALL
PARTIES INCLUDING REPUBLICANS.
AND IT WAS FOR THAT REASON SIR
THAT I ACCEPTED THE VERBAL
AMENDMENTS AND SIR I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THE TEN YEARS I HAVE
NOW BEEN HERE I HAVE NEVER BEEN
IN A COMMITTEE. WHERE WE VOTED
ON AMENDMENTS THAT WERE NOT
PROVIDED TO US IN WRITING I
HAVE TO SAY THAT. ALL BUT WE
DID TAKE A VOTE WE DID TAKE A
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS AND SO I
WILL BE HAPPY TO CALL FOR THE
VOTE- CURRENTLY WE TOOK A
VOTE. AND SO LET ME HEAR THE OF
THE- OUTCOME OF THE ROLL CALL.
GOT MY HAND UP. SENATOR
MELENDEZ FOR WHAT PURPOSE. WELL
I THINK YOU GOT HIM HERE JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN
PERSON AT THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE WOULD HAVE NO WAY TO
TURN IS AMENDMENTS IN IN
WRITING SENATOR MELINDA SENATOR
NIELSEN IS ACTUALLY HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS AS IS REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS STAFF SENATOR MORALE. NO
I WAS GONNA MAKE THE SAME
POINTED CENTER MELINDA'S OKAY.
BUT AGAIN I WILL STATE THAT WE-
ARE AS CHAIR I HEARD THE
VERBAL- AND WE TOOK A VOTE ON
WHAT WE UNDERSTOOD THE VERBAL
AMENDMENTS TO BE. SO I'M READY
TO ANNOUNCE THE VOTE. YES WE
CAN THROW CALL. HIS FIVE KNOWS.
TWELVE HIS FIVE KNOWS TWELVE
THE MEASURE FAILS. THE MOTION
FAILS. MOVIE NOT I'LL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION OF FOR A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. IT'S BEEN MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
BILL IN CHIEF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. MOTIONS TO PASS SENATE
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE.
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO BELL WELL
I. CABALLERO. CAREER HIGH
CAREER HIGH DOLLY KELLY AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE NO DOLLY NO
THE RAZA. THE RAGO HI HERTZBERG
NOT I HERTZBERG HIGH AND HER
DAUGHTER I THOUGHT I'D HI THEY
HI MICHAEL RIGHT MCGUIRE I
MULLIN. MELENDEZ EIGHTY SIX
FIVE NOW MELENDEZ AND I'M ON.
HI MY I'VE MORE LOCK. OR UNLOCK
A EIGHT SIX FIVE NO MORE LOCK
NO MORE. AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
NOW RONELL PAN. PAN AYE ROTH
ALL BROUGHT AYE SKINNER. IN R.
I. Y. COUNTY MAKOWSKI HI. HIS
THIRTEEN KNOWS. FIVE FIVE
THIRTEEN DOLLARS FIVE THE
MEASURE CARRIES AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN SO MADE SICK LEAVE.
ALL IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL
ROLL. MOTIONS PASS SENATORS
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO BAIL.
BILL HI CABALLERO HI CABALLERO
HI DOLLY. ALLEY AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN NO KILEY NODE TO
RAZA. TERRADO HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE HER TADO AYE
TITLE LAID. LEYVA MCGUIRE.
BLAIR I MELENDEZ WELL AND IT'S
AB SIX SEVEN MELENDEZ NO.
MONNING I AM LOCKED. FOR LIKE
AB EIGHTEEN SEVEN NO MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. MORRELL EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE L.
MOREAU NOT. NOW MARRANO- M. HI
I ROTH. ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE WHY CASKEY I
REQUEST YOU I. PRICE THIRTEEN
KNOWS. FIVE FIVE THIRTEEN OH
FIVE THE OUT MOTION PASSES AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT YOU WILL
LOVE THIS REALIGNMENT WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS TO PASS CENTERS
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO BAIL.
CABALLERO. DOLLY AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT NO. NO DORADO.
TORONTO HI HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HER TADO. LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
WHEN THERE'S EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT NOW MELENDEZ NOW.
MORNING I MONNING ARE MORE LOCK
MORE LIKE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT NO. MOROCCANOIL MORALE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT NOW
RONELL M. HI I ROTH. ROTH FIVE
SKINNER. SKINNER HI MY COUNTY
HI BECAUSE HE I. WHEN YOU. EACH.
I CAN HEAR YOU. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BELL CARRBORO. HER
TADO MCGUIRE HI WIRE HI. FIVE
TEN KNOWS. FIVE FIVE TEN THOSE
FIVE THE MOTION CARRIES. MOVING
ON TO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES.
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS
SENATORS MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN NOPE NIELSEN NO
BAIL ALL RIGHT BILL HI
COPYRIGHT. CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE NO
CALLING NO DORADO HI ROSA HI
HERTZBERG ONLINE HERTZBERG AYE
HER TADO. TOTAL HIGH LEYVA
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI WIRE HI
MELENDEZ. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE AND MELENDEZ NO MONEY I
MONEY I MORE LOCKED. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE GO MODOC NO
MORALE. MORRELL AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE NO MORALE NO HAN HI
CAN I. RALPH HI BRAVO MIKE
SKINNER. HI SKINNER HI MY
COUNTY HI MY COUNTY HIGH. READ
AND SHARE MOORLACH NO TIME.
MARK OKAY DID YOU TAKE THE BILL
NUMBER PLEASE. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE MORLOCK HIGH MORLOCK
NOTRE I. HI FOURTEEN KNOWS FOR
BEFORE WE- CALL THAT VOTE
MISTER DALI COULD YOU PLEASE
RESTATE YOUR VOTE AND SAY YOUR
NAME FIRST. ALLEY AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE NO THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. SENATE WE COULD CALL
THE VOEPEL RISE FOURTEEN KNOWS
FOR. FIVE FOURTEEN KNOWLES FOR
THE MEASURE CARRIES AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO CANNABIS I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTIONS TO PASS
MESSAGE SENATORS MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN NO NIELSEN
BELL. BILL HI CABALLERO HI
CAROL HI DOLLY. DALLY AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW
DARLING NO RAZA I. TORONTO HI
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG TIE HER
TITLE I TITLE II LEYVA. LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE WIRE HI MELENDEZ.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW
LINDENS NOW MINING. MONNING HI
MARLA. MOORLACH AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO NO MORE LUCKNOW
MORALE. MORRELL AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO NOW RONELL PAN HI
PAM IRA ALL RIGHT ROTH AYE
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER FIVE
ONE CASKEY HI MAKOWSKI I. HIS
THIRTEEN KNOWS. FIVE FIVE
THIRTEEN OH FIVE THE MEASURE
KERRY'S MOVING ONTO AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX EARNED INCOME AND
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT SO MOVE
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTIONS TO PASS
CENTERS MITCHELL HI MITCHELL HI
NIELSEN NOPE NIELSEN NO BILL
BILL HI CAROL HI CAROL HI DOLLY.
DALLY AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX
NOW IN THE EARLY NO DORADO HI
BROTHER I HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG HIGH HER TITLE HI
TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE. BLAIR I'M LINDA.
MELENDEZ EIGHTY ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SIX NO MELENDEZ NO MINING A
MONEY I'M MORE LOCK. AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX NO MORE
LOCK NO MORE. MORRELL AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX NOW RONELL
PAN HI CAN I ROTH AYE ROTH AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER HI MY COUNTY
HI MICHALSKI AYE. HIS THIRTEEN
KNOWS FIVE. FIVE THIRTEEN OH
FIVE THE MEASURE CARRIES ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE- BETTER ON
BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS AND FUTURE
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS HI MOVE
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR WHITE HOUSE. LET'S
CALL THE ROLL MOTIONS TO PASS
CENTERS MITCHELL. AYAY MITCHELL
HI NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NOBEL
BILL HI CAROL HI HI DOLLY.
SALLY AB. ONE EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
NO NO THE RAZA HI THE RAZA HI
HERTZBERG. HI HER HERTZBERG
HIGH PATADA HI THE TITLE I
LEYVA. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE NO
MELENDEZ NOW BONNIE. MONEY HI
MORE LOT. MOORLACH AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. WELL AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE NOW ROOM NO HAN ALL RIGHT
PAN IRA ALL RIGHT ROTH AYE
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI MY COUNTY
HI GARCIA I. FIVE THIRTEEN
KNOWS FIVE. FIVE THIRTEEN OH
FIVE THE MEASURE KERRY'S- THE
LAST VOTE OF THE EVENING-
COLLEAGUES AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS BOARDS LICENSEES AND
REGULATORY FEES UNLIMITED A
MOTION SIR. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE TO CENTERS MITCHELL
HI ANGEL HI NIELSEN NO NIELSEN
NOBEL. BILL HI CABALLERO. DOLLY
AB THIRTY THREE THREE ZERO
DALLY NO DOLLING NO DORADO HI.
ALTHOUGH I HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG HIGH HER TADO HI FOR
TITLE HI LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA.
MELENDEZ AB THIRTY THIRTY NOW
MELENDEZ NOW MINING HI MONNING
HI MORLOCK. MOORLACH AB THREE
THREE ZERO NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. WE'RE ALL AB THREE
THREE THREE ZERO NOW ROAD NO
PAN. ROCK ROTH ROCKS AYE
SKINNER HI THERE I Y. CASKEY BY
MCAFEE HI. HIS ELEVEN KNOWS
FIVE HIS ELEVEN KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE KERRY'S I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
PARTICIPATED REMOTELY- WE GOT
TO THAT VOTING REALLY QUITE
EFFICIENTLY EVERYONE THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
HERE PRESENTS THE BOARD THE-
BUDGET HEARING IS ADJOURNED